Neben iOS und Mac OS X ist iCloud das dritte OS, das über allem schwebt.
Das ist kein Tablet-Effekt.
Was denn, das ist ein iPad-Effekt.
Ich glaube auch wirklich, dass dieser Tablet-Markt, von dem Sie alle reden, existiert überhaupt nicht. Bis Ende dieses Jahres werden wir immer noch kein anderes Tablet sehen, was auch immer halbwegs fertig ist. So, dann richtet mal eure Mikrofone aus, Leute.
Roger, Roger.
Nicht so reinatmen natürlich.
Das ist essential, das gehört dazu.
Wie sagt man, ein Trademark-Feature? Ja, sowas.
Sollte es hier schützen lassen?
Wiedererkennungswert.
Sollte es hier schützen lassen, als Wortfehlmarke.
Und dazu noch ein bisschen Mathe schlürfen.
Ja, genau. Und zusammen ist Rekorde, zum Beispiel, als der am meisten gefletterte, unclaimed man of the world.
Als Einzelperson schon, ja, doch, stimmt. Obwohl der XKCD-Typ wurde auch mit Namen gelistet einzeln.
Aber XKCD ist ja auch mehr so eine Organisation eigentlich. Das XKCD Comic Imperium.
Organisierz, ich würde sagen, ist eher eine Religion, wenn ich mir gewisse Leute so angucke. Hast du dein täglich XKCD schon gelesen? Irgendwer meint, ich müsste lauter sein.
Du müsstest lauter sein oder du bist denn ist lauter, bitte?
Ja, sagen die so.
Die sagen sowieso einiges. Dabei bist du eigentlich schon, also leise bist du nicht. Aber jetzt höre ich dich gerade nicht, deswegen kann ich das nicht checken.
Ja, du meinst, ich muss mal wieder ein bisschen hier ins Mikro labern und so, ja? Noch mehr? Soll ich noch mehr labern? Nee, ich denke mal.
So, jetzt ist das Mobile Max, Ausgabenummer. Na, wer hat mitgezählt?
Moment, Moment. Nummer 73?
73, ja.
So ist es. Eine nicht sagende Zahl. Zu einem denkwürdigen Termin. Nämlich, wieder mal schön strategisch so auf so ein Mittwoch gelegt. Ist ja eigentlich der goldene Tag, so ein bisschen.
Das hat der Tim gut gemacht.
Wenn man sich so mit diesem Apfelscheiß rumschlägt.
Na, bei Apple war der Dienstag schon immer so der Release-Day und Announce-Day und so weiter.
Aber die Retail-Stores machen immer Samstags auf.
Updates und all so ein Kram immer Dienstags.
Wobei da ist es schon so ein bisschen langweilig, darüber zu berichten.
300 oder was?
Ähm, kleinen Moment, Herr Ahrens, da schau ich mal kurz in meine Notizen.
Oh, jetzt hat der mein Real-Name verraten mitten in der Sendung. Jetzt krieg ich wieder Post ohne Ende und alles.
Ich hab nämlich gestern Abend tatsächlich mir Notizen auf Papier gemacht. Ich fand das irgendwie ganz geil, um mich mal so ein bisschen zu erden.
Was ist denn das, wenn das da oben so dreht? Mit wem denn?
Keine Ahnung, hast du den Backup angeschaltet? Oder mit wem hier?
Mit iTunes vielleicht?
357.
Ich erkläre gerade dem Dennis iOS 5.
Das ist gut, 357 Retail-Stores.
Nicht schlecht.
Na gut, dass wir diese Zahl jetzt noch ausgesucht haben.
Und sie haben irgendwie nur so 4 oder 5 oder 6 wirklich in Asien. Und keinen Berlin. Noch nicht. Was ist eigentlich mit dem? Der macht nicht mehr auf dieses Jahr, oder? Kriegen sie das neu hin?
Apple Store Berlin S.
Das wird nicht der 1S. Der ist schon eingelullt.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Apple Mitarbeiter oder ein komplett Irrermensch. Oder vielleicht auch beides.
Ich glaube, es gibt mindestens einen. Und zwar den Typen, der die Glastreppen macht. Angeblich ist das ja irgendwie ein Deutscher.
Ich hab bei Felix Schwänzel, wirres.net, lest du den? X, genau.
Gesegendlich.
Der hat am Wochenende über den Apple Store in Hamburg einen Artikel geschrieben, und zwar über die Architektur da. Das war echt ganz spannend zu lesen, weil der hat ja irgendwie mal Architektur studiert. Und hat dann total andern und hat dann so über...
wirres.net.
Genau und hat da...
Fachblog für Irrelevanz, sehr schön.
Einer der besten deutschen Blogger überhaupt, würde ich mal sagen.
Was steht da um Schwanzreflektion?
Schwänzereflektion.
Nee, Schwänzelflektion.
Schwänzelflektion.
Der heißt Schwänze, Fetigschwänze. Noch weiter, der schreibt sehr viel in letzter Zeit.
In der Tat. War das erste Mal in einem Apple Store.
Genau und hat dann ausführlich über die Verarbeitung der Möbel und aus welchem Material die gemacht sind und dass die massiv sind und wie die Tische funktionieren und dass die ja noch unten was eingelassen haben, damit die die ganzen Netzteile unterbringen und dieses ganze Zeug.
Und das ist eine interessante Perspektive, die ich noch gar nicht so eingenommen habe. Die wird ja hier auch für meinen Studiotisch dann mal interessant.
Dann lasst du einfach einer von Apple kommen hier. Machen die noch keine Möbel?
Genau, mach doch aus deinem Studio einen von Apple Store. Zwei fliegen mit einer Klappe.
Eine Glastreppe würde sich hier sicher gut machen. Muss ich bloß die Nachbarn oben rausjagen.
Oder zum Beamer hoch.
Nee, einfach hoch und wieder runter.
Na gut, das führt jetzt zu nichts.
Also diesen neuen Sink bei dem iOS 5, um mal so wieder mitten reinzuquatschen, so typisch für unsere Sendung, den finde ich voll schick. Früher musste man ja immer oder durfte man ja nichts machen, wenn irgendwie gesynkt wurde. Und jetzt dreht sich da oben halt so ein kleines Ding und man kann sein Phone einfach so die ganze Zeit weiter bedienen.
Ja, weil er macht es ja auch im Hintergrund. Ich meine, du kannst ja auch im Hintergrund per Wi-Fi sinken.
Ja, dafür sind noch alle meine Apps jetzt weg.
Was, ihr seid jetzt nicht wirklich jetzt schon voll auf einem anderen Thema, oder?
Doch.
Jetzt haben wir gerade so schön hier... Es gibt ja auch noch so ein bisschen Feedback. Ich habe eine E-Mail bekommen von jemandem, der in einem Apple Store...
Team ist. Ah, dein Vögelchen.
Nicht mein Vögelchen, aber jemand, der sie irgendwann mal in unserer letzte Sendung gehört hat und...
Und wer hat erzählt, welche Drogen das sind?
Also ich werde dir natürlich jetzt nicht sagen, in welchem Store. Ja, aber er hat das glaube ich ganz gut verstanden, wie wir so ein bisschen drauf abgekotzt haben, auf diese ganzen Eröffnungsdinger, und hat so ein bisschen versucht zu erklären, wie das dazu kommt. Und ich fand so die Erklärung ganz gut. Der Chat, der dreht gerade durch. Ja, Huckel ist nicht da, Huckel kann nicht.
Achso, ja, wo ist eigentlich Huckel?
Huckel weiß, dass er nicht kann. Schon vergessen. Naja, auf jeden Fall berichtet er so, ich fasse das jetzt mal so ein bisschen grob zusammen, von dieser wilden Auswahl, also da bewerben sich wohl irgendwie echt irre viele Leute auf so einen Job beim Apple Store. Und man wird da so in mehreren Phasen ausgesiebt, ich glaube drei, bis du da halt sozusagen da zu den Letzten gehörst. Und du wirst dann auch, auf irgendeiner Phase wird dann auch klar, in was für eine Kategorie sie dich so einsortieren, also ob du nur so ein normaler Verkäufer wirst oder ob du wirklich genius Qualitäten hast, wo du halt wirklich richtig Plan haben musst und bestimmte Dinge wissen musst, etc. Ist ja auch klar, ich mein, das merkt man ja auch. Die Leute bei diesen genius Bars sind gut ausgebildet.
Ja, werden die gut ausgebildet oder die sind ja noch nicht gut ausgebildet, oder?
Naja, du musst wohl auch schon irgendwie Erfahrungen mitbringen, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Was würde mit mir passieren, wenn ich da so hingehen würde? Hab ich schon mal erzählt, dass ich schon mal bei Cassandra gearbeitet hab?
Du hast bei Cassandra gearbeitet?
Ich hab bei PandaSoft gearbeitet.
Ich war da auch nicht lange.
Ihr verkauft mir hier keinen Mac.
Ich bin da auch vom Verkauf, da bin ich ganz schnell weg, bin ich zum Reparatur gekommen, also zum genius geworden. Und da war dann aber Konkurrenz, der fand mich nicht toll. Ich war irgendwie besser als er überhaupt. Und der hat mich dann da raus geeckelt ganz schnell.
Also wenn ich Apple-Händler wäre, und ich wäre jetzt hier konfrontiert mit der Situation, dass ich gegen den original Apple Store ankämpfen müsste, ich würde so einen ganz cool eingerichteten Berlin-Style-Laden machen. Das ist ja nicht der ganze Glastreppenscheiß und so, sondern einfach rockig Berlin, trotzdem aber irgendwie gediegen und edel. Da muss man irgendwie die richtige Melange hinkriegen. Und den Genius Bar, den konnte ich mit einem Dennis Bar. So ein roter Samt-Tron.
Und egal, was man ihnen sagt, sie sagen nimm ZFS.
Told you so. Genau. Du kriegst auch deine eigene Kabine, Max. Ja, so die Tweet-Station irgendwie.
Achso, ich dachte die Flasche an ZFB-Basis.
Wo die Leute dann sich auch ein bisschen Tweet-Beratung geben lassen können.
Nie mehr als 140 Zeichen.
So oft, wie man per Twitter gefragt wird, als man irgendwelche Probleme lösen soll, da könnte man da schon mit Geld verdienen.
Und Hucke macht Desktop-Einrichtungsgestaltungsberatung. Fontgrößen.
Texteditor-Beratung.
Ja, Texteditor-Beratung. Einfach auch so eine gewisse Geschmacksfrage, die da geklärt wird, ob die Farbtöne auch richtig aufeinander abgestimmt sind. Sprich, die Dinge, die wirklich wichtig sind.
Und was wäre dein Anteil da?
Gute Frage.
Ich würde mich wahrscheinlich im Wesentlichen um das Gemeinsame von allem kümmern wollen. Die Linien und die Strukturen. Das Geld.
Achso.
Nein, nein, also dass das sozusagen auch läuft, die Nummer. Also dass das irgendwie flüssig ist. Ich habe da kein gutes Wort dafür, aber es ist... Sollte man nicht ein gutes Geld, nicht ein Wort dafür geben?
Für flüssig sein?
Geld. Nein, weißt du nicht, was ich meine?
Ja, so ein bisschen schon.
Ein bisschen aber nur? Ja. Du meinst, du verstehst mich nicht wirklich?
Management heißt es.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall nicht mehr erklärungsbedürftig.
Wir würden das schon irgendwie hinkriegen. Der Chat schlägt Nokia-Fachverkäufer vor. Ja, naja, also ich könnte schon auf jeden Fall Typberatung geben. So welcher Computer, welche Konstellation passt zu dir? Gerade so in berliner Kontext. Na, kommt da einer so mit einer Freitag-Tasche an und so weiter. Ja, schon so eine breite Schlaufe hat.
Gibt's das noch? Ich dachte, wir wären alle ausgestorben.
Aber wenn du schon mit so einer hardcore dicken Gummimatte ankommst und so breitreifige Schuhe hast und so, kannst du was schleppen. Kannst du auch Mac Pro, irgendwie die drei Q, machen es dir auch nicht mehr aus.
Oder direkt Mac Pro, ne?
Genau, hier haben wir auch noch auf einem Roller unseren fahrbaren Blei-Akku-Pro. Damit hält dann auch der Mac Pro seine 8 Stunden durch pro Tag. Na ja, vielleicht warten wir dann doch ab, was Sache ist. Also ein berlinspezifisches Evangelism wäre vielleicht gar nicht so falsch. Ja, Dennis Bar.
Ich hab mir heute eine Twitter-Taste eingerichtet. Guck mal, ich hab hier eine Taste, wenn ich die drücke, die Capslock-Taste, zack, Twitter vorne.
Du hast wirklich eine Twitter-Taste. Du hast die Capslock-Taste. Aber wie willst du denn dann auf Twitter schreien?
Gar nicht. Ich bin ja eher so der ruhige Typ.
Ach so, so ein Spitzfindiger, ne? Du twitterst immer so ein bisschen von hinten.
So ironisch.
So von der Seite ran, ne?
Ja, das heißt PC-Keyboard-Hack, das ist so eine Erweiterung. Hab mir Rob heute von erzählt, der hat da sein Terminate aufgelegt. Natürlich auch geil, weißt du, so drückst du die kurze Caps Lock-Taste, zack, geht das Ding in Terminate-Modus. Und damit hat er die ganz schlau eigentlich. Also man kann mit diesem PC-Keyboard-Hack die Caps Lock-Taste auf jede beliebige andere Taste legen. Und er hat die dann einfach auf F13 gelegt, was irgendwie, ich glaube, Charcode 115 ist, oder Keycode?
F13?
F13, ne?
Also ich hab gar keine F13-Taste.
Eben.
Und hat dann einfach in seinem Terminate gesagt, alles klar, mit F13 kommst du wieder nach vorne. Und ich hab das Ganze jetzt einfach so mit der Twitter-Apps ab 7 nachgemacht.
Mit F13?
Mit F13.
Wie kannst du F13 drücken, wenn du F13 nicht hast?
Ne, die Caps Lock-Taste ist ja danach deine F13-Taste.
Erst mappt man die physikalische Taste in eine logische Taste um und dann belegt man diese logische Taste.
Genau, also man kann die von Caps Lock auf jeden beliebigen Keycode legen. F13 ist, falls ihr das nachbauen wollt, die 105. Und danach kann man dann im App eurer Wahl sagen, alles klar, mit Caps Lock ist ab sofort das Programm nach vorne holen oder was auch immer. Um jetzt mal vom Thema abzulegen.
Ne, ist super. Ich meine, ich frage mich ja immer, was die Leute gegen die Caps Lock-Taste haben. Ich finde das ja ein bisschen fies und gemein. Ich hab ja die Caps Lock-Taste eigentlich echt lieb. Auch wenn ich einsehen kann, dass sie dann doch eine Menge Raum einnimmt dafür, dass sie eigentlich nicht unbedingt von allen Deutschen regelmäßig genutzt wird. Aber ist schon ein bisschen fies.
Apple hat doch irgendwann diese Verzögerung eingeführt, dass man die nicht mehr so schnell aus Hasen drücken kann. Seitdem ist eigentlich alles entspannt.
Wann haben sie das eigentlich eingebaut? Das ist mir neulich mal aufgefallen und ich dachte, ich werd nicht wieder.
17.06.2007.
Wirklich?
Unglaublich.
Ich glaub, das war so... Ja, beim Dennis Bar muss man sowas auch wissen. Das qualifiziert man.
Ja, da hätte ich ja jetzt schon mein Siri am Start.
Nicht spoilern.
Genau, Geniuses werden jetzt alle gegen Siri ausgetauscht.
Ja, das ist echt cool. Man hüpft da kurz drauf und es geht nicht an. Man drückt so ein bisschen länger und dann ist es halt... Das ist auch geil, weil das auch irgendwie so die Schreibmaschine so ein bisschen echt nachvollzieht, wo man auch so Hub hat. Weißt du, da musste man so richtig tief runterdrücken für den Caps Lock und dann lockte das ja auch so richtig so.
Das war so richtig einrasten. Wo man dann auch eine andere Taste drücken musste, damit es wieder losgeht. Die Schrift hat das, glaube ich. Ja, manchmal gab es sogar Release-Tasten dafür.
Ja, genau, richtig.
Und dann ist auch so richtig der komplette Wagen gehoben worden. Das war richtig Arbeit, immer. So, mechanische Schreibmaschinen, das waren auch Zeiten.
Der Carriage, der Alte. Jaja, früher war alles besser. Aber ihr habt jetzt nicht so spezifisch gegen Caps Lock oder so. Manche Leute machen das ja auch so, dass sie noch...
Das geht einfach nicht mehr...
.noch altschuliger sind. Du hast einfach tot gemacht.
Ja, da kann man auch irgendwo hier...
Ja, also wo ich noch so ein bisschen... Also wo ich vielleicht noch halbwegs mitgehen würde, aus verschiedenen Gründen. Und jetzt, wo ich es gerade sage, kommt mir das gerade ganz interessant vor. Manche Leute tauschen ja Control und Caps Lock gegeneinander aus. Und das hat tatsächlich historischen Kontext, weil ja bei den alten ASCII, bei den alten Terminals war da ja...
Bei Mamiiga.
Bei Mamiiga war da direkt Control, aber auch so bei VT100 Terminals und so weiter war da eigentlich... Control war eigentlich eine relativ große präsente Taste. Und erst Apple hat die so ein bisschen hier... Oder waren es schon auch die PC-Keyboards?
Ich hab mir sagen lassen, dass es auch noch bei japanischen Apple-Tastatoren bis heute so wäre.
Ja, wenn ich bloß diese Lampe noch mitbewegen können würde, das wäre dann toll.
Ich mag halt...
Ich mag halt Statuslämpchen einfach extrem gerne. Ich finde, davon könnte der Mac sowieso mehr haben. Ja, das ist wirklich hart. Das ist wirklich hart.
Also ich hätte mir früher noch eine Apfeltaste gesehen.
Ich hätte gerne nicht nur Funktionstasten, sondern ich hätte auch gerne so Funktions-LEDs. Und zwar können sie die ja gerne so verstecken, wie sie das mit den anderen auch machen, hinter diesem Alu, weißt du? So mit so einer Feinperforation. Und dann hast du einfach nochmal so... Naja, drei. Drei Funktions-LEDs.
Ich gucke Tim nach Fassungslos an.
Ich weiß, dass Steve das nicht durchgehen würde. Aber vielleicht...
Meinst du, Tim ist eher so Disco-Mensch?
Ich denke, er ist immer noch das unbekannte Wesen. Und ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, ob die Veranstaltung gestern das schon so sehr viel weitergebracht hat.
Der hat es nicht drauf. Der Scott Forster kann es besser, sogar Phil Schiller kann es besser. Und wer eigentlich am besten performt hat, war dieser Eddy Cue. Das war der iCloud-Typ. Der war einfach locker, flockig, kommt auf die Bühne, erzählt sein Zeug, ist irgendwie nicht ganz so strikt nach seinen Vorlagen, sondern kann so entspannt erzählen, als wäre das wirklich so...
Tim Cook hat richtig Incredible und ich glaube...
Ja, aber Tim Cook ist wie so ein angestochener Tiger im Zirkuskäfig irgendwie hin und her gerannt, hat dann irgendwie gesagt...
Er hat sogar was Neues gebracht.
Awesome, als wenn er jetzt gelesen hat, jetzt musst du mal Awesome sagen. Also es war einfach zu künstlich.
Er hat sogar was gesagt, was Steve Jobs meiner Meinung nach nie gesagt hat. Er meinte, ein Feature wäre unheard of. Das fand ich sehr souverän.
Und was hat dieser Typ von dieser 3D-Bude, wie heißt diese Spielebude da?
Epic.
Epic, der hat Eye-Melting oder Eyeball-Melting. Das fand ich auch sehr hübsch. Aber ich fand ja, alles in allem, bei Tim, der Fokus, der war schon so mehr auf Ang-
Also man will mehr Cook sagen als Tim, oder? Ist nicht nur wegen der Verwechslungsgefahr, aber er ist mehr so Mr. Cook.
Verstehe. Ich fand der Konkurrenzgedanke kam viel stärker raus. Also ich weiß nicht. Steve hat sicherlich auch öfters so mit Konkurrenzgedanken. Naja, so zum Beispiel, wie viele Leute haben Lion gekauft in der ersten Woche, wie viele Leute haben Win- Also ich meine, die Statistik war ja sowieso ein bisschen absurd, damit sie hinkommt.
Was gab es da vorher auch schon?
Aber gab es in den letzten Jahren immer noch? Was denn? Na so dieses so- Gegen Microsoft auch gerade.
Gegen was auch immer sie gerade eben so notwendig erachtet haben. Also das fand ich jetzt alles, inhaltlich fand ich das alles überhaupt nicht überraschend. Also weder von den Fakten selbst her, als von der Art der Fakten, die sie jetzt herangezogen haben. Da waren jetzt wenig Sachen, die mich jetzt so überrascht hatten.
Ich fand den Fokus ganz spannend. Oder was heißt ganz spannend? Ich fand zwar es ein bisschen aggressiver. Zum Beispiel hat er bei diesen Verkaufszahlen gesagt, also wie viel Marktanteil Mac OS gerade hat. Da waren sie irgendwie bei 20 Prozent oder 25 Prozent oder was auch immer das war.
Da war es schon...
Da hat er noch gesagt, es gibt ja noch 70 Prozent, die nicht unsere Rechner kaufen, es gibt also noch viel zu tun. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dir sowas gesagt hätte. Also es war schon alles ein bisschen mehr auf Push. So ein bisschen mehr auf...
Aber das ist das, was Tim Cook auch schon früher schon mal gesagt hat. Klar. An der Stelle nimmt er auch so wirklich die CEO-Rolle ein. Das verteilt sich jetzt alles neu. Und es war auch interessant, ich meine auch diese Reihung war anders. Wenn Steve Jobs mit anderen die Keynote gemacht hat, weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt wirklich immer so war, aber von meiner Erinnerung war es immer so, Steve Jobs, jemand anders, Steve Jobs, jemand anders, Steve Jobs, jemand anders. Selten, also ich kann mich an keine einzige Keynote erinnern, wo es wirklich am Anfang Steve Jobs und dann einer nach dem anderen und jeweils an den anderen, an den nächsten übergeben, bis dann am Ende nur noch Steve Jobs.
Das ist hier mehr so ein Staffellauf.
Normalerweise war das immer Steve Jobs dazwischen und jetzt ist es, ja ich weiß auch nicht, wo die ganzen Scheißfliegen herkommen, die scheinen sich jetzt bei dem Sommer irgendwie mücken. Also das war ein Unterschied und das war in gewisser Hinsicht okay, weil dadurch hat er sich zurückgenommen, dadurch hat er eben auch gar nicht erst versucht, jetzt hier der Zeremonienmeister zu sein. Aber es war schon klar, dass es mit ihm anfängt und mit ihm endet. Er hat auch irgendwie seinen Witz gebracht, das war auch okay, er hat auch gesessen, er war jetzt kein Schenkelklopfer, aber er war in der Lage, das Eis zu brechen.
Was war der Witz?
Naja, das wäre jetzt seine erste Produkteinführung, seitdem er CEO wäre, da hätte er sicherlich der ein oder andere schon von gehört. Oder so, eigentlich hat er es formuliert.
Ich glaube, er hat gesagt, wir wissen es sicherlich nicht, aber für mich ist das meine erste Produkteinführung.
Irgendwie so eine Formulierung war das richtig. Da dachte ich mir, okay, ich meine, man muss jetzt mit ihm nicht zu hart sein, das verteilt sich jetzt anders. Und ich meine, das iPhone wurde dann von Phil Schiller präsentiert.
Wobei er ist ja auch mehr, er ist ja auch mehr der für Finanzen und der, also er ist ja nicht so der Technikmensch und das hat dann die Bühne, den Technikmenschen überlässt, hey, super.
Genau.
Das ist doch großartig und ich fand auch, er hat dem ganzen mehr so einen Rahmen gegeben. Also bei Steve war das immer, das war seine Show und hier und das sind Leute, die dürfen für mich präsentieren und er hat im Wesentlichen, würde ich sagen, so den Leuten, ich gestikuliere wild rum, so einen Rahmen gegeben, hat am Anfang die Gäste begrüßt und am Ende dann verabschiedet und hier, das ist eure Show.
Das Einzige, was so ein bisschen fehlt, aber das konnte auch diesmal gar nicht so stattfinden, weil sie ja eigentlich keinen Formfaktor vorgestellt haben, den es nicht schon vorher gegeben hat. Nee, nicht Johnny Eve, sondern was weiß ich, so ein Moment, wo dann Steve Jobs irgendwie so das neue Gerät aus seiner Halterung nimmt und die Kamera hält und dann so Isn't it beautiful? Oder was auch immer er dann irgendwie gerade so von sich gibt.
Die hatten es nicht mehr dabei, ne? Ja doch, die Epic-Typen hatten es ja anscheinend, aber sonst?
Bei der Serien-Präsentation hatten sie es auch.
Was sollen sie da noch zeigen? Das Ding ist unverändert. Und alle Änderungen sind innen. Vielleicht kommen wir mal zum Inhalt, hm?
Wir machen jetzt hier Zurückspuren. Du warst dabei, von den Vögelchen zu erzählen, warum die im Apple Store da so abgehen.
Stimmt.
Wir haben dich abgelenkt.
Wir entschuldigen sehr gut, Dennis.
Das gibt einen extra Punkt, Dennis. Wo war ich denn? Genau, Dennis Bar. Jetzt erinnere ich mich. Sie werden ausgewählt und in verschiedenen Stufen und ausgeteilt nach Genius Bar oder nicht Genius Bar. Ab einem bestimmten Punkt weißt du dann, dass du das genommen wirst. Ich glaube, da gibt es so drei Auswahl. Ich muss die E-Mail nochmal nachlesen.
Hat er auch erzählt, was die Grundvoraussetzungen sind für so einen Job? Also irgendwie abgeschlossenes Hochstuhlstudium im Volkswirtschaft?
Er ist jetzt auch wirklich mehr auf diese Geschichte eingegangen, warum wird da geklatscht? Und er meinte halt, dass er sich das auch gefragt hätte. Weil er dann irgendwie dabei war.
Beim Klatschen?
Ja, bei der ganzen Klatscherei. Und dann meinte er halt, dass eben zunächst einmal so diese Ausbildung ist so, abgesehen von sonstigen Materialien, was du dir so reinziehen musst. Du hast ja so eine Hardcore-Intensiv-Training- Woche oder 10 Tage oder so, wo du im Hotel abhängst und dann hast du da deine Gruppe, ich weiß nicht genau wie groß die ist, wo du quasi die Essenz da eingebügelt bekommst und wo du halt auch klar gemacht wird, wie awesome das alles ist. Ja, wie The Apple Way ist. Was bedeutet der Kunde für uns und dass das irgendwie alles so kundenzentriert ist. Da würde dann aber auch schon recht viel rumgeklatscht werden. Also diese Beklatschung, das ist wohl auch schon so Teil dieser ganzen... Also ist halt so, wie Apple das macht. Ob das jetzt, das ist sicherlich auch... Ich meine, das ist ein... Natürlich ist das amerikanisch. Wenn Apple das macht, ist das amerikanisch. Gibt's amerikanische als Apple? Eigentlich nicht, oder?
Was denn? Was denn jetzt amerikanisch ist? Ich finde Apple eigentlich sehr unamerikanisch. Ich glaube, dass...
Das ist doch der fleisch gewordene American Dream, tralala, Start-up, Tech, Brillanz, Pipapo, Kalifornien.
Also ich glaube, aus amerikanischer Sicht ist das extrem europäisch. So Wertlegen auf Design, alles schön schlank, dünn, leichte Materialien. Amerikanisch ist doch eher Cadillac, fette Karre, fette Breitreifen, tiefer gelegt. Bei Autos. Bei Autos, aber auch so bei so Dickauftragen, immer schön.
Also ich finde Apple ist eigentlich eher so schwedisch.
Und hier so Steve Jobs als ist der Atheist auf jeden Fall so veganer. Das ist halt diese Hippie-Kommune. Ja, eigentlich doch, finde ich, sehr unamerikanisch.
Naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall ist es wohl so, dass schon in dieser Phase da so ein bisschen die Basis dafür gelegt wird, dass eben die Leute, die dann letzten Endes in diesen Laden arbeiten, auch einen akuten Bezug bekommen zu ihrem Laden und ihrem Team. Ist ja auch klar. Was ich nicht wusste, ist, dass die dann eben auch –gut, was heißt, was ich nicht wusste, was man sich vielleicht hätte auch denken können, was man vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang erstmal nicht so bedenkt ist, dass sie dann eben auch am Schluss selber aktiv diesen ganzen Laden zusammenbauen. Also die sägen jetzt nicht die Tische oder so, sondern die richten ihn halt ein, also das Team selbst richtet ihn her. Das ist nicht so, dass da jetzt die Apple Store Retail wir bauen das Dingtruppe kommt, sondern die Leute, die da letzten Endes da auch drinstehen und dich serven.
Damit gleich so ein Teamgefühl entsteht, ist doch logisch.
Ja, genau, natürlich, klar. Deswegen meinte ich ja. Wenn man erstmal drüber nachdenkt, dann ist das irgendwie auch alles nachvollziehbar. So, und dann ist das natürlich so auf den letzten Drücker, wie das immer so ist. Und dann macht dieser Scheiß Laden auf. Und das war dann, da muss ich auch sagen, das kann ich auch echt gut verstehen, ja. So, dass man dann eben auch stolz ist. Das klingt auf jeden Fall plausibel. Auf das, was man dann auch da geleistet hat. Und dann hast du natürlich dann so eine Situation, wo sich das alles aufschaukelt. Wahrscheinlich muss da einfach nur mal einer irgendwie so kurz machen. Und dann ist es vorbei.
Nee, das stelle ich mir vor. Ich meine, das ist quasi dann, wenn du den selber aufbaust, dann ist es ja dann so als Team auch, das ist unser Laden. Das ist ja nicht mehr so ein Laden, wo du einfach nur reingehst und jetzt bist du der Verkäufer, sondern hast du den selber. Und dann stehen die da vorne schlangenweise und fallen in diesen Laden rein. Natürlich, also kann ich verstehen, dass man noch ein bisschen...
Ich frage mich jetzt gerade, wie denn das wäre, wenn wir uns hier mal so ein bisschen beklatschen würden. Hey! Wir sind gut. Wir bringen das.
Mit den Hörern abklatschen.
Alles für die Hörer.
Ja, das befreit oder man fühlt sich gleich viel besser.
Da müssen wir noch mal ein bisschen dran arbeiten.
Wir waren auch nur zu dritt. Ich meine, wir können ja auch mal... Da kann ja mal jemand ein schönes Klatschen hier so einspielen.
Leider hat der Chat jetzt...
Hört auf mit der Scheiße.
Der Chat hat Delay.
Mach mal irgendwie, mach mal den Chat nach vorne übrigens, weil da ist nicht so wahnsinnig viel.
Holt doch mal den Chat nach vorne.
Die haben meinen Bug gefixt. Endlich. Hat ja nur zwei Jahre gedauert.
Mit iOS 5.
Na, die Bilder waren nicht mehr richtig sortiert. Und jetzt sind die richtig sortiert, so wie sie aufgenommen wurden. Weil ich hab irgendwann mal Backup eingespielt und dann hat er das Datum der Files aus dem Backup genommen und die waren anscheinend irgendwie neu. Und da war alles kreuz und quer. Und jetzt stimmt's wieder. Voll toll. Gut, also so eine Genius-Typ, ob die eine spezielle Ausbildung vorher brauchen oder was die da so nehmen, also wahrscheinlich muss man schon irgendwie Perfect English können, nehme ich an, hier so in Deutschland.
Ja, die Genius-Jungs, die werden dann wohl auch zu einer etwas längeren Session da auch wohl teilweise in die USA eingeflogen oder alle, ich weiß gar nicht ganz genau.
Ja, ich glaube, da fliegt man dann nach Cappatino nach Amerika.
Tja, nachdem wir uns jetzt hier so in Rage gequatscht haben.
Der Monkey Dom, der war doch letztens noch mal da drüben, oder? Wollten die den abwärmen?
Ich dachte, der wird jetzt Apple mit dabei tauschen oder so.
Nö, der war doch erst gerade da. Ja, also ich weiß nichts Genaueres, sondern ich interpoliere das jetzt mal aus dem, was er selbst so public gesprochen hat. Also vielleicht weiß ich auch genaueres, aber man weiß das ja immer nicht so genau.
Dann erzähl doch mal was alle wissen, nur ich nicht.
Naja, ich meine, du kannst auch eins und eins zusammenzählen.
Naja, wenn ich eins und eins zusammenzähle, dann war er zu...
Der hat das echte iPhone 5 gesehen.
Was bezweifle ich im Nurigen.
Und wenn, dann in so einem riesen Rahmenklopper und was willst du da großartig sehen, auch so, dass da so ein schnelleres OS läuft, also gesehen hat das ja sowieso vorher schon.
Es ging da weniger ums zeigen, sondern es ging da wahrscheinlich vermutlich eher darum, dass bestimmte Software-Entwickler kurz vor dem Release da nochmal in so eine, wie nennt man denn das, wenn so Developer mit Apple-Technikern da in Kerkler gesperrt werden. Sit-in.
Ja, aber was hat denn der Monkey für dicke große Tools? Oder er hat irgendwelche neuen Sachen am Start, die ich ja noch nicht kenne.
Ich vermute einfach mal, dass es sich hierbei im Wesentlichen um Game Center handelt. Weil Game Center wird freigeschaltet demnächst. Es wird dann sozusagen live geschaltet, hat neue Features mit Pipapo, Profil-Build und Tralala. Und sie wollen sicherlich sicherstellen, dass eine kritische Masse an wirklich populären Spielen...
Aber haben denn die Monkey so ein High-Profile-App?
Na, Kakason.
Ist es so doll viel verkauft?
iPhone-Spiel des Jahres. Im deutschen iTunes Store.
Na ja, hast du bestimmt schon ein paar, die du da kaufen.
Na, die waren irgendwie wochenlang die Nummer 1. Es gibt nicht so viele, die wochenlang die Nummer 1 waren.
Außer Angry Birds, Flight Control und...
Die werden sie vom Duel eingeladen haben.
Duel Jump.
Naja, mit denen saßen sie wahrscheinlich auch in einem Raum. Und dann haben sie mal...
Und wie lange ist deine?
Ich weiß es nicht, ne? Ich hab jetzt davon nichts Konkretes gehört. Das ist jetzt das, was ich mir jetzt selber...
Ich dachte, die wollen den abwerben. Deswegen fliegt man da rüber, weil sonst in anderen Kram kann man auch remote irgendwie fixen.
Ich glaube, wenn sie ihn wirklich abwerben wollen würden, dann würde er nicht darüber reden.
Dass er da mal hinfliegt, wieso nicht? Haben andere auch gemacht. Die Dev-Team-Jungs, die iPhone-Hacker hier, weißt du schon? Der hat doch ein T-Shirt gehabt, so ich war da, aber ich darf nicht mehr sagen. Tim will nicht ausrücken.
Ja, ich kann da nicht mehr zu sagen.
Ich verstehe es ja.
Ich habe mir das jetzt einfach mal zusammen interpoliert und das ist das, was ich denke, weil einfach iOS-Redist steht an, Gamecenter-Changes stehen an und sie wollen natürlich sicherstellen, dass High-Profile-Upstars sicher sind. Was ich mir auch noch hätte vorstellen, können, was aber jetzt im Rahmen der Präsentation, wie sie gelaufen ist, wahrscheinlich gar nicht weiter zur Diskussion stand. Du hast ja auch, was weiß ich so, bei diversen iOS- und MacOS-Releases haben wir ja auch schon gesehen, dass gleich so eine ganze Reihe von Software-Entwicklern auf die Bühne gegangen sind. Dass sie so vier, fünf, sechs ihre Spiele demonstriert haben und hier und was wir alles mit dem iPad machen können und so weiter. Und dass sie dann in solchen Sessions dann auch die rauspicken, mit denen sie auf die Bühne gehen wollen. Und dann gegebenenfalls auch gleich entsprechende Briefen oder Pipapo. Aber auch das ist eine reine Vermutung meinerseits. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber die können ja auch, die können das ja auch mit dem iOS programmieren.
Jaja, die machen tolle Sachen.
Ja, wir können mal zum iPhone kommen.
Kommen wir mal zum iPhone.
Hab ich die Klatschgeschichte jetzt ordentlich abgearbeitet? Jaja, das war schön. Ja, ich denke schon. Also vielen Dank für den Beitrag. War auf jeden Fall ein schöner Einblick.
Ich war am Sonntag beim Apple Store.
Frankfurt.
Achso, wollen wir das vielleicht noch ein bisschen vorne wegschieben?
Na, wenn wir jetzt sowieso bei den Apple Store spenden. Ich wollte in Paris, wo ich eigentlich in Apple Store stand, direkt neben einen und hab's nicht gemerkt.
Weil sie nicht geklatscht haben?
Ja, genau, weil sie nicht ausreichend geklatscht sind. Ja. Und ich stand tatsächlich da, bloß zu dem Zeitpunkt dachte ich die ganze Zeit, es gibt nur einen. Also ich hab einfach zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht mich wirklich erkundigt, wo denn die Stores sind. Wo der Store ist. Und hab ja danach erst gemerkt, dass ich wohl in 100 Meter Entfernung von dem Teil gestanden haben muss.
Hättest du mal Siri gefragt.
Ja, hab ich mal Siri gefragt.
Ja, ich war in Frankfurt um meinen iPad-Cover aus... Also eigentlich war ich in Frankfurt und bin an Apple Store gegangen und hab dann gedacht, irgendwas muss ich jetzt auch hier machen. Dann hab ich meinen iPad-Cover ausgetauscht, weil das so ein bisschen Auflösungserscheinungen gezeigt hat. Na, ich dachte, kann ich mal austauschen.
Wurde auch problemlos.
Absolut problemlos. Das hat echt gut geklappt. Ich brauchte nicht mal...
War das ein Kunststoff-Cover?
Nee, ich hab... Ich hab ein Leder.
Das rote, ne?
Ich hab sogar das rote. Rotes Leder.
Rotes Leder. Das hat sich aufgelöst.
Das hat sich an der Ecke so ein bisschen so... Na, es hat sich also bei den Lederschichten so auseinanderlagen, die wahrscheinlich verklebt sind. Die sind so auseinander und dann ist halt die Pappe oder was auch immer das Material da im Mittelpunkt ist, das ist halt rausgekommen. Und da sah halt nicht so sonderlich schön aus. Und ja, ich war auf der... Kann ich ja vielleicht nochmal... Ich war auf der McCoon. Das ist so eine... Eigentlich ein erstes Jahr nie Mac, aber auch iOS-Entwicklerkonferenz.
Ach, du warst auf der McCoon.
Genau. Und hab mich da mal so ein bisschen zuquatschen lassen.
Ich hab gehört, da wird man gesiezt.
Da wird man gesiezt. Stimmt, da wurde man auch gesiezt. Also ich fand's... Also nee, man wurde nicht pauschal gesiezt. Es gab einen, der einen ganz spannenden Vortrag gehalten hat, nämlich, wie man Prototyping in Objective-C rein kriegt. Der hatte aus Spaß und Laune so ein paar Klassen gebaut und hat dann die Objective-C Runtime so weit aufgebohrt, dass er quasi Prototyping unterstützt hat. Was ganz knuffig klang. Aber so alles in allem, muss ich leider sagen, fand ich es nicht so berauschend. Also es ist irgendwie...
Woran lag's?
Ach, so viele Dinge. Also ich fand die Location nicht sonderlich toll.
Was war die Location?
Das ist irgendeine Jugendherberge da. Die Location an sich war gar nicht verkehrt. Das Problem war, es gab nicht irgendwo eine Ecke, wo man sich hinsetzen konnte oder sowas. Jedenfalls habe ich keine gefunden. Sondern man saß im Vortragsraum oder stand irgendwie draußen rum oder so. Oder stand irgendwo im Weg. Also ich habe mich 80% der Zeit im Weg stehend gefühlt. Sodass man eigentlich nicht wirklich reden konnte. Ich fand es ein bisschen zu... Also es hätte mehr Mac-Kultur. Ich glaube, die gibt es auch unter Mac-Entwicklern und iOS-Entwicklern. Das ist ja auch so eine eigene Kultur. Also zum Beispiel hätte ich es ganz cool gefunden, wenn da eben so ein paar Mac-Podcaster wären. Oder irgendwie ein paar von den Bloggern. Wenn das nicht nur die Entwickler unter sich wären, sondern wenn das auch so ein bisschen darüber hinausgehen würde. Dass man ein bisschen Show macht. Genau, dass man so ein bisschen Show macht. Das hat so komplett gefehlt. Weil so waren das alles sehr techniklastige Vorträge. Zu vielen Themen kann ich mir da auch die entsprechenden WWDC-Videos angucken. Da erfahre ich grob das Gleiche nur von kompetenteren Leuten. Weil halt von denen, die es entwickelt haben und nicht von Leuten, die es anwenden wollen. Und ich fand, die meisten Vorträge haben immer gleich eine Stunde gedauert, ich glaube sogar alle. Und man hat schon deutlich gemerkt, dass es vielen der Vortragenden ganz schön dehnen mussten, um eine Stunde vollzukriegen. Und ich finde, so eine halbe bis dreiviertel Stunde hätte es da gut getan, dann hätte man auch, Sie haben vorher gesagt, dass Sie massenhaft Themen ablehnen müssen, hätten Sie mehr reinnehmen können. Und dann ist es auch nicht so schlimm, wenn man in einem falschen Vortrag sitzt, dass es dann eh nur eine halbe Stunde dauert. Also so fand ich das so.
Also ich hab Mails bekommen von denen, aber nur so Pressemitteilungen. Pressemeldungen, wie sie es nennen.
Ja, also es war sehr unberlinerisch, muss ich mal sagen. So alles in einem.
Ich finde die Idee ja cool, dass man so ein Event halt auch kulturell auflebt, das ist guter Einwand. Aber auf die Idee scheinen sie nicht gekommen zu sein.
Ich weiß natürlich auch gar nicht, ob das überhaupt ihr Ziel ist, aber...
Offensichtlich nicht, sonst wäre es ja verfolgt.
Oder sie haben es einfach nicht hingekriegt oder sind noch gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen.
Ja, aber das ändert ja nichts daran, dass die Idee gut ist.
Also, und sowas muss in Berlin sein. Wobei Frankfurt fand ich jetzt eigentlich, ich war das erste Mal in meinem Leben in Frankfurt, war gar nicht... Na okay, dieses Sachsenhausen ist schon wirklich da, diese Kneipen-Gegend, das ist schon weitgehend unerträglich, das muss ich echt mal sagen. Ja, gut, dann...
Also mir gibt's nichts zu berichten davon.
Mir fällt jetzt, ich werf gern nochmal was ein, wenn mir noch was einfällt.
Wie viele Tage ging das?
Die fingen Sonntag und Sonntag, immer ein relativ, ich glaub ging um 11 oder 10.30 Uhr los mit der Keynote und ging dann so bis 17 Uhr jeweils. Am zweiten Tag war ich gar nicht bis zum Ende da. Am ersten schon, dann gab's am Sonnenabend gab's nochmal eine Party.
Auf der warst du auch?
Auf der war ich auch. Ja, ja, ja. Schon bessere Partys gesehen. Also war jetzt nicht schlecht, es war extrem voll. Also sie hatten so viele Anmeldungen wie noch nie zuvor. Es waren irgendwie 436 Leute, die da waren.
Das ist voll, das ist viel.
Das war für die absoluter Rekord. Und darum war das glaube ich auch. Diese Kneipe, in der da diese Party war, wir waren alle draußen drin, da hätten wir noch Platz gekriegt, aber in dem schlimmen Wetter wollten alle draußen sein. Und das war einfach gerammelt voll. Und so richtig viel Bewegung war da auch nicht drin. Muss ich auch sagen, kenne ich da auch niemanden so richtig. Und dreieinhalb Mal bin ich auch angesprochen worden. Aber jetzt war es auch nicht so, dass ich das Gefühl hatte, dass ich da großartig bekannt bin. Insofern habe ich mich da im Wesentlichen an meine Peer-Group gehalten und mich mitschleifen lassen.
Aber das ist schon so die größte deutsche...
Ich glaube sogar die einzige.
Ist das die einzige auch?
Ich glaube schon, ja. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Also falls noch jemand eine andere hat, dann sagt Bescheid. Also ich weiß, dass irgendjemand wollte hier mal in Berlin die 360-Iphone-Dev irgendwie machen. 360 Grad, die es auch in Amerika gibt. Aber das hat nicht geklappt. Ansonsten weiß ich nicht.
Also es wäre jetzt für mich zeitlich nicht gegangen, aber interessanterweise fand ich das jetzt aus denselben Gründen nicht interessant. Für mich, die du gesagt hast. Weil es mich jetzt, da ich kein iOS-Development mache und kein Mac-Development mache, so direkt nicht tangiert, auch wenn mich das an sich interessieren würde, aber wenn da sozusagen kulturell auch nichts anderes läuft als das, strahlt es irgendwie nicht besonders nicht ab.
Sehr lustig, hier ist auf einem der Bilder, also gerade jemand im Chat hat Fotos veröffentlicht von der Maccoon, Link zur Gallery gepackt, und auf dem letzten Bild ist Markus Feendrauf, ein alter Freund von mir, der da war, aber der offensichtlich, wir haben uns verpasst. Also ich wusste nicht mal, dass er da ist, und dann hab ich jemand getroffen, der so, hey, du hast doch was mit Markus Feendrauf zusammen gemacht, den kenn ich schon lange, und er so, ja, der ist vor einer halben Stunde abgefahren. Ja, insofern, das wär ja auch ganz lustig gewesen.
Und das trotz Twitter und all den ganzen...
Ja, ich war da auch ein bisschen unkoordiniert, muss ich auch sagen. Achso, und was echt überhaupt nicht geht auf so einer Konferenz, was wirklich auf gar keinen Fall sei, es gab kein WLAN.
Also es gab kein was? Es gab kein WLAN?
Es gab kein WLAN.
Auf einer Developer-Konferenz?
Ja, es gab kein WLAN. Also es gab so ein Jugendherbergen, internes WLAN, wo man sich irgendwie für 10 Euro für zwei Tage hätte WLAN per Kreditkarte zusammenklicken können und dann läuft die... und das war... Aber darüber hinaus gab's nichts. Und ich hab die gefragt, ich meinte, ja, nee, das ist jetzt alles so ein bisschen... Das ist jetzt alles so ein bisschen... Hier mal, ja, und wir hätten das nicht hinbekommen und so mit dem WLAN und so, aber... Das geht nicht. Vor allen Dingen, weil dann... Zumindest in dem einen Raum, da gab's dann nicht mal... Da hatte ich dann mit O2 zumindest keinen Empfang. Und dann sitzt wir so total auf dem Trockenen. Und ich glaub zwar nicht an Internetsucht oder so was, aber das kann schon hart sein, wenn man feststellt, wenn man tief eingebunkert in irgendeinem Vortrag sitzt und mittendrin feststellt, dass das nicht so das eigene Thema war. Und man da nicht wieder rauskommt.
Hm, ich blätter hier gerade etwas Gedanken verloren durch diese Foto.
Das ist der Peter Maurer heißt der. Der hat so Indie, also wie man sich quasi selbstständig macht als Mac-Entwickler. Der hat so hier dieses Witch geschrieben, was ich jeden Tag nutze. Der hat dieses, wie heißt das, Moon? Nein, Nun? Wie heißt denn dieses Tool, was?
Der grüßt mit Willkommen auf der Metaebene.
Und leider war auch der ein bisschen, ich dachte er erzählt so ein bisschen so, was er für Erfahrungen gesammelt hat. Und auch mal so ein paar Schoten aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern. Und weiß ja teufelfass, aber es kam leider überhaupt nicht. So im Wesentlichen kam, wer sich selbstständig macht, muss damit rechnen, kein Geld zu verdienen. Ja guck mal, da bin ich ja sogar drauf. Siehst du? Genau, das ist Andreas, mit dem hab ich mich da getroffen.
Macht er aber auch da.
Unsere Hörer schlafen gerade allein.
Na ja, Entschuldigung, ich versuche einen Eindruck davon zu gewinnen, wie es auf so einer Konferenz ist.
Das ist doch kein Videopodcast.
Also muss ich mal dieses Magical Weather ausmachen, das macht mich wahnsinnig, es regnet die ganze Zeit.
So, jetzt wollen wir ein bisschen wieder über Max reden.
Ja, oder über das iPhone.
Wieso, gibt es Neuigkeiten?
Ja, es gibt ein neues iPhone.
Ach Quatsch, es gibt ein altes iPhone und Apple tut so, als ob das ein neues iPhone wäre, also wenn es kein neues Gehäuse hat, dann ist es kein neues iPhone.
Das ist alles neu, hast du gestern nicht zugehört?
Hat nicht mal eine 5 hinten. Scheiß Apple.
Aber habt ihr gesehen, dieses Video, also die haben ja wie immer keinen Livestream gemacht, sondern es gibt ja jetzt irgendwie Stunden später ein Video und es kommt in der Webseite und es hat keinen Startband, sondern es geht einfach los und man kann nicht Vorwärtsspuren und nichts, gar nichts machen, ne?
Ich fand der Stream kam erstaunlich schnell. Normalerweise hat das ja immer so ewig gedauert. Aber gestern ging das ja relativ flott.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wann es fertig war. Ich hab nur kurz gefragt und dann kam gleich was. Naja, wollen wir mal vielleicht mal gucken. Also, was mich ja die ganze Zeit bearbeitet hat, ist ja, was das denn nun mit dieser Product-Transition auf sich hat und irgendwie kann ich keinerlei, keinerlei... Also ich dachte ja, als dieses Gerücht kam mit, dass die Spiele für den normalen iPod nicht mehr im iTunes Store zu kaufen sind, dass jetzt zumindest das Ende von dem Classic gekommen wäre, aber dem scheint ja wohl nicht so zu sein. Zumindest ist er noch im Store. Vielleicht droppen sie das Teil auch zwei Wochen später, um überhaupt gar nicht erst irgendwie irgendeine Aufmerksamkeit dafür zu erzeugen. Aber es macht zumindest nicht so den Eindruck, als ob der Nano oder der Touch irgendwie weggeht, auch wenn sie sich da ja wohl extrem zurückgehalten haben.
Nein, der Nano bleibt.
Ich kann dir sagen, ich weiß, dass diese riesengroße Transition ist.
Na dann?
Na, von Steve zu Tim.
Das ist aber kein Product. Nee, die sind reserviert. Aber ich hab noch...
Juhu, wir kriegen Süßigkeiten.
Ich hab noch mehr. Ja, unsere Hörer, du kannst ja mal im Chat eine Abstimmung starten.
Wer von uns jetzt gleich ins Mikro schmatzen darf.
Hier, ich kann euch da mal... Diese weiße Box dahinten, da sind leckere Leckerlis.
Da passen ja Schuhgröße 45 rein.
Das hab ich jetzt mit Holgi ausreichend durch. Das sind Tim Tams, das ist ganz schlimm.
Wir kriegen jetzt hier die... Ganz schlimm, ihr wolltet es so. Wir kriegen jetzt Not Safe for Work, das ist sehr gut.
Die machen von jeder Sorte eins auf, ne?
Wo wir mal das Zeug hier... So, erzähl weiter.
Die Tim Tams sind übrigens...
Moment, einmal noch.
Das ist wirklich cool.
Die Crunch kenn ich selber noch nicht. Das Meter-Ebene höherer Imperium, das wird irgendwann noch mal daran eingehen, dass wir hier so viel essen.
Also das hier ist ziemlich geiles Zeug.
Dann kann ich ja mal so ein bisschen was über das iPhone. Ich will jetzt auch so einen Crunch.
Du erzählst jetzt erstmal. Immer nur kann einer schmelzen.
Ich will trotzdem einen in der Hand haben.
In der Hand haben, die schmelzen.
Ja, da sollen sie ja auch. Eye melting. Was Besonderes ist mir aufgefallen? Mal gucken. Ich schau mal in meine Notizen. Also sie haben eine ganze Menge Zahlen rausgelassen, über alles Mögliche. Und das wenigste davon fand ich wirklich total überraschend, aber es war ganz gut, dass sie das festgehalten haben. Zum Beispiel sprachen sie bei... Ich will jetzt mal kurz beim iPhone bleiben. Dass das iPhone 4 schon 50% aller iPhones ausmacht.
Echt, hat er gesagt?
Die sie jemals verkauft haben sogar, ne?
Ja, das hat er gesagt.
Wobei das jetzt wirklich keine überraschende Zahl ist.
Nee, ist alles keine überraschende Zahl. Ich sag das. Nur so mal interessant, diese Zahlen auch mal so zu hören. Und dann haben sie irgendwie noch gesagt, dass die 250... Milliarden... Billion...
Was?
Million, können sie aber nicht...
Million, was denn?
Ich nicht gerade falsch?
Sag schon.
250 irgendeinen Billion IOS-Devices.
Na, Million, Billion, 250 Milliarden IOS-Devices pro Einwohner...
Das macht ja auch keinen Sinn.
250, wie viele werden das? Es werden noch deutlich mehr.
Ich wurde nicht richtig irgendwie... Ja, Billion, Billion. Also 250 Millionen IOS-Devices gibt es.
Das nehmen wir nicht. Ja, das ist eine ganze Menge.
Aber auch schon über 300 Millionen iPods. Na, alles nicht so spannend, wenn man in der Notiz nicht ehrlich sein soll.
Ja, lass uns mal über... Hey, kommt, lass uns mal...
Ne, also das iPhone. Was ist drin? A5 Dual Core.
War zu erwarten.
War zu erwarten. 64 GB RAM. Wurde Zeit, ja. So, dann Graphics neu.
Dual Core angeblich.
Ja.
Also haben sie gesagt, nicht angeblich, sondern...
Dual Core Graphics.
Siebenmal schneller. Also schon noch irgendwie...
Das ist halt die neue Generation von diesem... Wie hieß diese Bude noch gleich? Diese britische Grafik... Bude.
Ich hab mich nicht gemerkt.
Ich auch nicht.
Ist das die gleiche Grafik wie schon im iPad 2, oder ist das irgendwie noch was komplett Neues?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Aber beim iPad 2 haben sie meines Wissens nicht von Dual Core Graphics gesprochen. Kann schon sein, dass sie beim iPhone jetzt was zum Einsatz gebracht haben, was im iPad 2 so noch nicht drin ist.
Peasemi, aber die meinen wir nicht. Wir meinen die andere Bude danach.
Peasemi gehört ja Apple und, mein Gott, wie heißt denn der Laden? Hab ich nicht die ganze Zeit dräugig quatscht. Dann fällt einem auch nichts mehr ein, ne?
Besser Kamera?
Achso, der sucht die Grafikkamera raus.
Ja, ich komm nicht drauf.
Irgendwas mit S, oder E mit I? Ist doch egal, ist nicht so wichtig.
So, und dann haben sie an der Antenne rumgeschraubt und sie haben sich extrem zurückgehalten.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie nicht Antennagate zu benutzen.
Nicht irgendwie Antennagate zu sagen, oder so, hab ich so den Eindruck gehabt. Ja, aber was macht das Teil? Sie schalten zwischen Receive und Send hin und her. Weil bei UMTS ist es so, dass du teilweise auf der einen Frequenz sendest und auf der anderen Frequenz empfängst. Du machst halt nicht das hin und zurück auf derselben Frequenz. Das heißt, du hast halt auch eine Antenne, die eben den einen Frequenzteil bedient und eine andere Antenne, die anderen Frequenzteil bedient. Und sie können aber dann, je nach Bedarf, die Antennen hin und her schalten, je nachdem, ja, jetzt weiß ich halt auch nicht genau, was der wirkliche Gewinn an der Stelle ist.
Sie können mal mit der einen senden und mal mit der anderen senden und sich wahrscheinlich von der Gegenstelle sagen lassen, was besser angekommen ist.
Also er hat es nicht gesagt, aber ich vermute mal, was sie damit meinen, ist, sie können adaptiv so hin und her schalten, wie es gerade besser ist, so machen sie es.
Ja, und zwar während des Telefonats wohl. Also die Sprachqualität ist besser geworden und die Empfangsqualität.
Na, Sprachqualität hängt ja auch vom Netz ab.
Nee, da kommt ja auf den Codec an.
Naja, aber der Codec muss auch übertragen werden. Also die haben eine Antenne rumgeschraubt.
Imagination, verstehe.
Also das bleibt abzuwarten, was das bringt. Ich glaube, die Amerikaner haben da sowieso relativ wenig von diesem ganzen schnelleren HSPA-Kram. Das funktioniert wahrscheinlich eher alles nur in Europa so richtig.
Sie haben kein LTE, hatte ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht mit gerechnet, aber ist vielleicht eine Erwähnung wert.
Ist ja auch noch zu früh.
Ist eine Erwähnung wert.
Es gibt halt einfach noch kein LTE.
Nein, nicht wirklich. In Deutschland gibt es mittlerweile schon ein paar Regionen.
Ja, und da hast du halt mal ein Mast, wo LTE kommt, aber...
Ja, also das hätte mich gewundert, aber wie gesagt, ist trotzdem eine Erwähnung wert.
Sie haben gesagt, dass es ein Worldphone ist. Da fragte ich mich natürlich, was bedeutet das eigentlich bei diesen CDMA-Netzen in den USA? Geil, das heißt, man kann es wieder......drogen kann.
Das ist ein typischer Dennis.
Ja, die haben jetzt alle einen SIM-Karten-Slot. Dann kannst du eine SIM-Karte reinpappen.
Das heißt auch die Amis, die das gar nicht gewohnt sind, haben jetzt so einen Slot.
Na ja, AT&T und T-Mobile.
Und dann steht dann, for EU use only.
Wieso, aber AT&T und...
Und dann sind die Verizon-Kunden.
Es gibt ja vier Netze. Zwei haben CDMA und zwei haben ja... Und das funktioniert jetzt wahrscheinlich dann auch bei T-Mobile USA? Weil bei denen ist ja bisher nur ohne 3G immer.
T-Mobile funktioniert immer noch nicht, weil T-Mobile unter anderem 1700 MHz Frequenz benutzt. Und das iPhone kann das iPhone immer noch nicht. Also...
Hast du geguckt, ja?
Ich hab geguckt. Ich bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher, weil da ist 1700 und 2100 genannt und das iPhone kann 2100, aber 1700 nicht. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob das erforderlich ist, um im T-Mobile-Netz zu kommunizieren oder ob das bedeutet, dass du nur dann 3G hast, wenn du gerade mit 2100 unterwegs bist. Oder ob das tatsächlich Descent- und Receive-Frequenzen sind bei UMTS. Das weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Okay, wir wissen es nicht.
Und in dem letzten Fall wäre es eben nicht möglich. Auf jeden Fall stehen die ein bisschen doof da. Ist aber auch insofern vollkommen irrelevant. Als dass die ja eh von AT&T gekauft werden.
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht ist es noch nicht durch, ne?
Ja, ich glaube.
Na ja, das ist halt...
Da hat da so eine andere Firma was dagegen, die gerade so einen dicken Deal gemacht hat.
Ja, das ist, was da so gerüchtet wird, das ist ja richtig krass, oder?
So was wurde ja gerüchtet.
Hast du nicht mitbekommen gestern? Hast du dich auch gestern, aber schon vorgestern?
Vorgestern haben sie sich verpflichtet, in den nächsten vier Jahren 30 Millionen gerüchteweise iPhones abzunehmen.
Ja, für 20 Milliarden Dollar.
Und wenn das schief geht, also wenn die kommende iPhone-Generation oder die danach oder so sich nicht mehr verkauft, dann ist Sprint pleite.
30 Millionen für ein Jahr.
Für vier Jahre. Na ja, aber sie haben es wohl verkauft, Sprint selber, wenn das schief geht.
Das muss man ja schon ganz gut bezahlen, die Jungs.
Offensichtlich nicht. Ich habe Armkleidentecos ausnehmen.
Wie gesagt, wenn ich das richtig interpretiere, dann sind die iPhones jetzt im Durchschnitt um 100 Euro teurer geworden in Deutschland. Weil das Kleinste kostet jetzt 6,29 und ich glaube, das hat letztes Jahr noch 5,29 gekostet.
Ist man so doof, dass man das danach dann immer nicht weiß. Man ist so blöd, mal einen ordentlichen Screenshot zu machen.
Ich weiß, dass das 32 Gigabyte letztes Jahr 7,29 gekostet hat. Und wenn es dieses Jahr auch drei Größen gibt und das kleinste wird, gerade ab 6,29 steht da genau so. Und das ist wahrscheinlich die 16 GB Version. Ja, so dann kostet es 32er 7,29 und das 64er 8,29. Damit ist der Preis um 100 Euro gestiegen pro Modell.
Du musst deinen Dings aufsetzen.
Wo ist denn hier der Preis? Ab 6,29, da sind keine Einzelpreise. Das heißt, wenn der Spiegel schreibt, Apple ist in der Normalität angekommen und sie müssen jetzt die Konkurrenz fürchten. Also ich weiß ja nicht, wenn Apple meinen würde, da wäre Konkurrenz, würden sie nicht die Preise um 100 Euro anheben.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die wirklich die Preise um 100 Euro abgehoben haben. Weil guck mal, das 8 Gigabyte, das alte iPhone 4, kostet jetzt nach Preisreduktion 519 Euro.
Ja, aber das ist auch das alte vom letzten Jahr.
Ja, wie viel hat dieses Gerät letztes Jahr gekostet?
100 Euro mehr.
Also 629 für die 8 Gigabyte Version.
Obwohl.
Das würde bedeuten, dass...
Nee, der Chat muss mal hier kurz mithelfen, Jungs. Ich habe letztes Jahr für 32 Gigabyte 729 bezahlt.
Und das war die Top-Version?
Ja, aber es kann auch sein, dass die 32 Gigabyte jetzt immer noch 729 kostet.
Ach so, ja, die kostet auch noch 729.
Ja, so könnte man es natürlich sehen. Aber das ist natürlich der Trick. Denn Apple macht das mit gleicher Gigabyte Zahl. Zahlt den gleichen Preis wie letztes Jahr. Nur, dass es die ganz kleine Gigabyte-Version mit 8 wird es halt einfach gar nicht mehr geben. Und dafür kamen halt jetzt eine 64 Gigabyte-Version dazu. Also sie nutzen halt das, umso psychologisch sozusagen ist, eigentlich gar nicht teurer geworden, sondern man kriegt halt mehr Speicher dafür, weißt du? Aber das ist halt auch ein neues Phone. Man muss jedes Jahr auch immer bei gleichem Preis so ein bisschen updaten, was wir mit dem Rest ja auch tun. Das heißt, das ist faktisch eine Preiserhöhung.
Kann man so sehen.
Ich sehe das so.
Na ja, und halt auch 32 Gigabyte mehr Flash drin. Machen sie bestimmt Gewinn.
Und wer weiß sogar, ob das 64er nur 100 Euro mehr kostet, weil ist ja immerhin 32 Gigabyte mehr. Vielleicht ist das ja schon auch...
Warten wir mal ab, bis die Preise wirklich feststehen, weil wir müssen müßig jetzt über Preise zu reden. Ja, und am Ende ist das nicht.
Ich glaube, die Preise jetzt da stehen.
Warte mal, was wird hier im Chat? Siehe Apple Store ab.
Ja, das sind die aktuellen Preise, die wir da gerade auf der Seite auch haben.
Was? Wo? Wo sind denn hier Preise?
Ach, man, steht da noch nicht.
Hier oben steht in der Apple Store ab, steht 16 GB, 629, 32, 739, das heißt, das wäre 10 Euro teurer als das letzte. Genau, aber du kriegst ja auch mehr dafür.
Ich kriege auch so bei einem neuen iPhone mehr dafür.
Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall 849. Das sind sogar 110 Euro Schritte, nicht nur 100 Euro.
Gott, das gibt ja echt, ich probiere hier gerade mal so die...
850 Euro, ihr Schweine!
Sag ich doch.
Gab es denn letztes Jahr überhaupt schon eine 8 GB Version von dem iPhone? Gab es nicht einfach nur 16 und 32 und das war's? Ich probiere das gerade auszufinden. Ich glaube nämlich, die 8 GB Version ist jetzt quasi neu.
Es kann sein, dass es die 8 GB nur als 3 GS gab, ne? Ich weiß nicht so genau. Ich finde auf jeden Fall, der Top-Preis ist ganz schön nach oben gerutscht.
Aber ist er gar nicht.
Ja, ich finde, habe ich gesagt.
Auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist das schon ein Premium Device. Das bleibt so und sie verdienen immer noch eine Menge Holz an dem Teil.
Davon kann man ausgehen.
Ja, aber wird ja trotzdem gekauft.
Aber womit du natürlich absolut recht hast, quasi die 8 GB Version vom iPhone 4, die sie jetzt verkaufen, die ist gar nicht billiger geworden. Also sie haben den Preis vom iPhone 4 nicht wirklich gesenkt, sondern sie bauen einfach weniger Speicher ein und verkaufen es dann mit der gleichen Preislogik, wie jetzt das iPhone 4S sozusagen. Das finde ich schon echt hart.
Ja, ein Telefon, was irgendwie bald anderthalb Jahre alt ist, ist übertrieben.
Das ist erstaunlich, dass das so ein 110 Euro Schritt. Ja, wir haben jetzt im Prinzip, wenn wir mal das 3GS mal rausnehmen, haben wir immer so einen 110 Euro Schrittweite vom iPhone 4 mit 8 GB, 16, 32, 64. Also eigentlich ist es ganz einfach. Das basis iPhone 4 Telefon kostet 520 Euro und dann kannst du für je 110 Euro immer deinen Speicher verdoppeln und bei dem ersten Schritt kriegst du zufällig auch noch mehr Performance dazu.
Was ja okay ist, weil du ja auch nur 8 GB mehr kriegst, wobei du beim nächsten Schritt schon 16 GB mehr kriegst und bei dem Schritt danach kriegst du eigentlich 32 GB mehr. Also sozusagen der oberste Schritt lohnt sich am meisten.
Naja, so ist das halt.
So kann man es aussehen. Dann ist ja klar, was man kauft. Dann kauft man halt einfach recht viel Spaß.
Und ich meine, wenn man damit wirklich so ein bisschen, also die Bilder, die man mit dem Ding schießt, sind viel größer. Die Videos, die man damit macht, sind viel größer.
Wenn man es auf 1080 einstellt, ich schätze mal, da kann man es auf 27 machen, oder?
Ja, wer macht denn sowas? Immer erstmal volle Pulle und später runterrechnen.
Also ich muss sagen, ich habe im Augenblick auf meinem iPhone 4 etwas mehr als die Hälfte belegt.
Aber das ist voll gut.
Ich glaube, ich werde mit 32 GB noch kommen.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt meinen 4G verkaufe, kriege ich einen voll guten Preis, weil der eigentlich gar nicht runtergegangen ist.
Überhaupt nicht, der ist nicht die Bohne runtergegangen. Das ist echt krass.
Voll geil. Für 700 könnte er meins haben.
Die verkloppen das weiterhin zum alten Preis weiter. Das ist echt krass.
Ja, 600, ich bin nicht so.
Ein bisschen billiger musst du schon werden, aber.
85.
Ich verkaufe mein iPhone 4 noch nicht.
Wieso nicht?
Ich stehe auf Backup.
Hast du zwei jetzt auch schon?
Ich habe mein 3GS jetzt schon verklappt.
Also hast du gerade gar kein Backup.
Genau, in Erwartung von dem nächsten Upgrade.
Um das zu bestellen.
Also du bestellst dir das 4S und behältst deinen Vierer.
Genau.
Was mich jetzt nochmal interessiert ist, ob es vielleicht noch irgendeinen Deal gibt, den ich vielleicht nutzen könnte. Keine Ahnung, ich bin ja auch schon seit Ewigkeiten O2-Kunde. Ob die da irgendwie interessante Upgrades bieten?
Wenn du einen neuen 2-Jahres-Vertrag abschließt, dann kriegst du bestimmt irgendwas. Ja, also die Tarife hab ich mir überhaupt nicht angehuckt. Wollen wir mal über das Gerät selber weiter reden?
Also Kamera.
Kamera. Jeh, Kamera.
Also ich bin kein Kameraprofi, aber das klang ganz gut.
Ja, ich bin auch kein Profi, aber wenn die sagen, kommt ein besseres Bild raus, dann kommt ein besseres Bild raus, was will ich mehr?
Also die haben ja diese Nummer mit dem Meerlicht, die auf dem Pixel drauffallen. Da haben wir gesagt, wenn man da noch die Auflösung weiter erhöht, hier von, was haben wir im Moment, 5 glaube ich, auf 8 Gigapixel, dann hat natürlich eigentlich der einzelne Pixel weniger Licht. Also du hast irgendwann keine Erhöhung der Bildqualität mehr. Und darum, aber sie haben ja damit geworben, dass sie jetzt mehr Licht pro Pixel sozusagen draufkommt. Und das kommt ja dadurch, dass sie, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, also ich habe irgendwann mal vor Ewigkeiten was darüber gelesen, als das so in die Mittelklasse Click-Kameras reingezogen ist, dass da nämlich weniger Elektronik dazwischen liegt auf dem eigentlichen Sensor. Also das ist so ein Sandwich und das Licht muss durch ein relativ viel Technik durch, bevor es danach auf dem Sensor auftritt und das ist halt näher dran.
Backlight-Illumination oder was?
Genau, ist das das oder ist das was anderes? Und haben damit irgendwie gesagt, dass es pro Pixel 60 Prozent mehr Licht wäre und das wäre schon, also nicht nicht aufs gesamte Bild, das 60 Prozent mehr vom Licht ankommt, sondern das pro Pixel 60 Prozent.
Was heißt denn das? Backlight-Illumination.
Backlight oder Backlight?
Also was wird denn da illuminiert?
Keine Ahnung, ich glaube vorher war irgendein Bauteil direkt neben dem Sensor und hat an der Stelle wurde sozusagen kein Licht eingefangen. Jetzt ist dieses Teil hinter dem Sensor und deswegen kann die komplette Fläche für die Sensoren benutzt werden. Was heißt das mehr von dem Licht eingefangen wird, irgendwie so. Gibt es ja auch schon seit einer Weile, aber anscheinend noch nicht in Mobiltelefonen.
Also ich finde das...
Das Licht trifft nach dem Passierenden. In der Wikipedia. Und wie sie jetzt... Hier ist nur von der Frontside-Illumination. Also da liegt noch ein bisschen Elektronik davor und die muss dann quasi passiert werden. Und da ist so ein Raster drauf und natürlich schluckt diese Elektronik auch schon Teil des Geldes. Das Geldes auch.
Nee, aber bessere Kamera kann nicht schaden.
Also ich freu mich sehr über eine bessere Kamera, weil...
Vor allem eine Kamera, die schneller anspricht. Wenn das wirklich stimmt, dass das Ding schon mal in einer Sekunde am Start ist, was ich schon für Fotoschussgelegenheiten verpasst habe, weil dieses Ding einfach so ein Schnarcher ist.
Und was halt noch dazukommt, also es ist ja so, also auch schon mit iOS 5, also hier bei dem 4er habe ich das nicht, dass hier bei Slide to Unlock kommt doch jetzt der Kamera-Button rechts davon. Genau, wenn du schon mal mit einer Hand irgendwie versuchst, das, dieses Slide to Unlock, so komplett rüber zu ziehen, das ist schon manchmal immer nicht so easy, bis zum Ende zu ziehen. Deswegen, wenn dieser Button genau rechts kommt, muss man den auch nur noch ganz entspannt bis zur Mitte ziehen. Und man kann sein iPhone viel leichter aufmachen, was?
Also ich find das ja mit dem Button eher ein bisschen, ich mach da einfach mal Button.
Ja, wo schalte ich den ein?
Ich hab's noch nicht gefunden. Dann doppelklick auf Homebutton.
Da ist er.
So geht das, verstehe.
Und jetzt hast du da einen Button mit der Kamera.
Also ich dachte, man kann sich den Preferences irgendwie einstellen. Nee leider nicht, das wäre natürlich voll gescheitert. Naja, so geht's auch. Ich dachte die machen den einfach da dauerhaft hin, also was soll's.
Na das Dove, was ich daran ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen blöd finde, ist, dass ich meistens vergesse, dass es ja noch diesen Button gibt, sondern doch wieder über die klassische Möglichkeit da rangehe. Und insofern kann man das ruhig besser machen. Und ich hätt's ja schön gefunden, wenn sie eine Möglichkeit finden, dass man direkt einfach diesen Auslöse-Button, also diesen Volume-Ab-Button, lang genug gedrückt hält, und das dann automatisch die Kamera-App startet oder so was. Das hätt ich ja am besten gefunden, um schnell in die Kamera zu kommen.
Ja, aber das ist schon okay. Du brauchst jetzt nicht schnell in der Panik irgendwie deinen Code eintippen. Ich denke mal, das geht schon.
Ja, stimmt. Mit dem Code eintippen, das ist natürlich noch mal eine besonders spaßige Sache.
Und die Bilder landen dann ja auch erst in deiner Sammlung, wenn du wirklich...
Naja, was ich auf jeden Fall ganz cool finde, ist, dass natürlich die ganze Zubehörindustrie, die sich jetzt für das iPhone 4 entwickelt hat, dass die natürlich jetzt auch lebt.
Was hast du denn da schönes hier gehört?
Ich hab mir mal dieses Teil, das ist dieses Teil, was mal auf den Kickstarter angedingst wurde. Jetzt hab ich den Namensschilder vergessen. Wie heißt das? iClub.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es hieß.
iClubyp und das ist irgendwie so ein ganz einfaches kleines Plasteteil, dass man schön einfach seitlich an das iPhone 4 so ran drücken kann und es hält dann schon relativ gut an dem Ding fest. Einfach nur dadurch, dass es sich exakt ran schmiegt, also genau an die iPhone 4 Maße ausgelegt ist, auch die entsprechenden Aussparungen hat. Wenn man das an der Stelle ran macht, wo die Volume-Buttons sind und der Stummschalter...
Passt das denn an, überhaupt aufs iPhone 4S?
Wenn das iPhone 4S genauso ist wie das iPhone 4, dann wird es sicherlich passen. Das kann ich dir jetzt nicht genau beantworten.
Das ist ja mehr so wie so ein CDMA-iPhone 4.
Ja, da war irgendwas anders.
Der Stummschalter-Button ist ein bisschen weiter nach unten gerutscht.
Ja, aber das ist nicht so das Problem. Hier ist halt einfach so eine Vertiefung. Ich zeig dir das gleich. Ich zeig dir nur kurz, was man damit noch machen kann. Also der Clou ist, du drückst es halt an der Seite ran, dann hält es und dann hast du unten so eine Stativschraube.
Die Standard-Stativschraube, oder?
Die Standard-Stativschraube. Ich hab jetzt kein passendes Stativ, aber ich denke, ihr könnt euch das ganz gut vorstellen und dann kannst du halt einfach dein iPhone so Landscape-mäßig auf so ein Stativ drauf machen und damit halt Fotos schießen. Oder Videos. Und ich hab, wo war denn das hier, bei dem Space Tweet-Up hab ich irgendwie jemand getroffen, der ist mit so einem Manfredo, Manfrotto, Manfrotto, ein Bein Stativ durch die Gegend gelaufen. Manfrotto ist so eine der angesagten Stativmarken. Manfredo, ich komm jetzt mal durcheinander. Und das Teil halt, und das war irgendwie alles, und damit macht er dann seine Video-Podcast. Ganz großartig.
Na ich hatte ja auch schon mal, hier ist irgendwie draußen grad Musik, aber dick.
Hört keiner.
Nee, der Bass kommt dir nicht mehr an.
So, jetzt kommt der zweite Clou. Jetzt machst du nämlich diesen Eye-Clip wieder ab und jetzt hast du noch so eine andere Aussparung. Und dann kannst du ihn einfach hier an der dicken Seite einfach so seitlich ranmachen und dann hast halt so ein, ich gucke einen Film-Ständer, dieses typische iPhone-auf-Bock-Problem. So, jetzt dürft ihr hier mal mit rumspielen.
Guckt ihr tatsächlich Filme auf eurem Telefon auch?
Das ist die einzige Möglichkeit für mich. Ja, also Video-Material zu konsumieren, ist das iPhone für mich die einzige Möglichkeit.
Mach's nicht auf dem iPad, nicht mal das.
Dann muss ich das iPad halt dabei haben. Aber ich hab das iPad nicht immer dabei.
Krass. Ich hab noch, ich glaub, ich hab noch nie...
Es gibt auch genug Situationen, wo ein iPad einfach extrem unpraktisch ist, vor allem im Bett. Und das Bett ist für mich eigentlich der optimale Ort, in Ruhe einen Film zu gucken. Weil ich erst dann Ruhe hab. Vorher tue ich andere Sachen und... Ja, das ist ein Luxus, den man mit Kindern selten genießen kann.
Du armer, armer Mensch.
Beziehungsweise dann musst du halt... Na, das ist das Problem, wie krieg ich den Scheiß auf dem Fernseher? Ich meine, man muss ja diesen Content auch in dem Moment haben. Ich meine, jetzt mit diesem neuen Airplay-Mirroring, das wäre dann wieder ein weiteres Argument für das neue iPhone.
Weil, wobei der Teil geht ja auch noch mit dem alten.
Wobei, das geht ja jetzt auch schon. Genau, den Airplay könnte ich auch jetzt schon machen. Da hast du recht, ne? Nur, Fernseher heißt halt, es ist laut und...
Funk-Kopfhörer!
Ja, Funk-Kopfhörer heißt Latenz.
Du holst hier so ein paar analoge Billig-Funk-Kopfhörer und dann...
Wie Latenz, wieso?
Na, Latenz. Bluetooth hat einfach Latenz.
Ne, muss ja nicht Bluetooth sein, nimmst du einfach, nimmst du hier so diese Spezialen, gibt das so, Funk-Kopfhörer?
Ja, gut, aber warum soll ich mich dann noch in so einen Raum setzen mit einem Fernseher, wenn ich dann auch direkt aufs iPhone gucken kann? Ich meine, die Auflösung ist auf meinem iPhone besser, oder? Da seh ich dann mehr Pixel, wenn ich das Ding irgendwie von der Nase hab. So blöd es klingt, aber der Fernseher hat zwar mehr, aber der steht ja dann auch meterweise weg. Wie auch immer, es ist ja egal, kann ja jeder das so handhaben wie er will. Für mich ist das auf jeden Fall so, dass das iPhone eigentlich der primäre Ort ist für meinen Videokonsum, also was auch immer läuft, wenn ich nicht halt vor meinem Rechner sitze.
Wie kommen wir jetzt eigentlich auf das Thema gerade?
Weil wir halt überhaupt so bei dem neuen Phone waren.
Na ja, kommen wir mal zu diesem eigentlichen Feature.
Na ja, dann sind wir aber wieder bei iOS 5.
Dann sind wir bei iOS 5.
Wir können ja über Sachen reden, die es dann halt nur auf dem neuen iPhone gibt. Bei iOS 5 hatten wir ja auch schon.
Ja, aber lass uns doch mal über diese Siri-Ding reden.
Na es gibt ja auch nur beim neuen iPhone. Wobei es ein bisschen fies ist, weil es gab es doch schon vorher. Das ist ja eine App gewesen, die die gekauft haben. Das gab es eigentlich auf allen Geräten.
Ja, aber das war halt nicht in dem Maße integriert, oder? Ich hab die nie ausprobiert.
Nee, war nicht integriert.
Die konntest du ja auch schon ewig nicht mehr runterladen. Die ist auch schon ewig auf den Store raus gewesen.
Aber heiße steht da irgendwas, dass es wohl kurzfristig abgeschaltet war. Aber jetzt ist die Stimme, die sagt jetzt, dass sie bald ein Update kriegt.
Was dachtet ihr? Als ihr das gesehen habt, was war euer Gedanke?
Also ich hab gedacht, ich hab mir im Vorfeld überlegt, wie wollen sie sowas demonstrieren? Weil du stehst da auf einer Bühne, also ich mein, das ist genauso, als ob du irgendwie so eine Kinect oder sowas vorführen möchtest. Du hast halt so Situationen, wie oft gehen irgendwelche Präsentationen schief, weil hier kriegt die Kamera das falsche Licht oder das Mikro kriegt das falsche Licht, weil es heilt, weiß der Teufel was. Und dass die es schaffen, da so eine Situation herzustellen, in der das offensichtlich zuverlässig genug funktioniert, dass es ausprobiert, also dass es testen und dass es dann wirklich ohne Probleme in jedem Fall, den sie probiert haben, funktioniert hat, finde ich beeindruckend.
Na ja, aber ich meine, die haben ihre eigene Software da im Griff. Und vielleicht haben sie genau nur auch die Sachen aktiviert, die auch wirklich da reinspricht, damit die Hitrate irgendwie größer ist. Also die können da schon noch ein bisschen drehen, das so ne...
Natürlich, ob das in der Praxis so gut funktioniert, ist die nächste Frage. Aber das...
Ich meine, wie oft haben wir ja schon dieses Voice Assistant irgendwie benutzt und so. Und ich meine, wie oft klappt das nicht? Und diese Serie, vielleicht ist es jetzt wieder ein Stückchen besser, aber ich glaube, es liegt auch gar nicht an der Qualität der Erkennung, sondern auch, wie man sich halt zum Deppen macht, wenn man irgendwo rumsteht und in sein Telefon quatscht. Also es ist einfach nicht für jeden Ort. Du kannst ja in der U-Bahn stehen und plötzlich in deinem Telefon reden. Also das geht einfach nicht.
In der U-Bahn soll es ja auch gar nicht.
Im Auto könntest du es mir vielleicht so ganz gut vorstellen, so mit Hands Free. Aber sonst, nee, tippen geht schon doch irgendwie schneller, ohne andere Leute zu belästigen. Oder die hören ja auch mit, ja, so.
Also ich telefoniere ja, ich würde ja mein iPhone gerne mehr auf dem Fahrrad nutzen. Und habe ja dafür schon dieses Call-to-Speech-to-Call oder wie auch immer, also dieser Voice-Control genutzt. Und das hat ja irgendwie auch immer ganz okay funktioniert, wenn man denn 2, 3, 4 Versuche gemacht hat und nicht wegen Frustration aufgegeben hat. Und wenn das jetzt besser wird, geil. Und wenn das Ding auch noch SMS-Nachrichten vorlesen kann und mir Termine setzen kann und so was. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie gut es funktioniert. Also es ist, damit steht und fällt das Ganze. Aber wenn es so ansatzweise so gut funktioniert, wie da beworben, dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das ein absolutes Killer-Feature wird.
Hands-free-Operation.
Und weißt du was, weißt du was, ein bisschen vergessen haben und ich hatte das ja eingeboten. Es ist mir sofort an einer Dramaturgie sozusagen aufgefallen, dass es fehlt. Weil dieser Scott Forster hat ja ganz kurz gesagt, irgendwie was war mit seiner Marmene, ne mit seiner Frau, Molly hieß die ja. Dass er irgendwie einen Termin mit seiner Frau machen soll. Und dann hat er ganz kurz erwähnt, dass das Siri, weil er immer betont, dass Siri sehr doll im Kontext arbeitet, dass Siri ihn ja schon gefragt hätte, wer dann seine Frau ist. Das heißt, dass wenn er gesagt hätte, auf der Bühne dort, hier mach mal einen Termin mit meiner Frau und er hätte Siri vorher noch nie verraten, wer dann seine Frau ist in seiner Telefonliste, dann hätte Siri gefragt. Und das hätte ich auch noch ein bisschen mehr beworben. Das wäre nämlich ein bisschen cooler gewesen. Weil dann kommt wirklich so ein bisschen...
Welche dieser zehn Mädchen, mit denen du regelmäßig telefonierst, ist deine Frau?
Wir haben uns heute auch gefragt, wie läuft das bei den Mormonen oder ähnlichen Volksgruppen?
Ich frage mich, was so ein Siri alles über einen auspackt, wenn man den irgendwie richtig fragt.
Aber da kannst du ja schon auch schon sehen, was die da in ihrer iCloud so alles sammeln. Also die interpretieren schon im Kontext halt. Also da geht's ab.
Und wenn man so mit einem Apple Support telefoniert, so wenn der Mensch am Telefon irgendwann, könnte ich sie bitte mal, würde ich sie mal bitten, dass ich mal mit dem Siri unter vier Augen sprechen kann.
Aber weißt du, was ich noch gerade gesehen habe? Ich spüre so ein bisschen rum hier mit dem iOS 5 die ganze Zeit. Deswegen bin ich auch immer so ein bisschen geistig woanders. Und zum Beispiel bei den Wetterdaten, da gibt's jetzt, weil vorher hast du halt immer Berlin gehabt, weil ich bin jetzt hier in Berlin irgendwie. Und jetzt hast du da halt Actual Location. Oder Current, genau. Und der zeigt dir mal das Wetter, wo du gerade bist. Und Berlin hab ich jetzt einfach nach hinten geschoben, falls ich mal woanders bin, dass ich bei Berlin trotzdem gucken kann. So, aber wenn jetzt zum Beispiel mit Syria, du bist halt wieder mal irgendwie auf Reisen und dann sagst du Call my Girlfriend, dann weiß er alles klar. Du bist gerade in San Francisco, ruf dein Girlfriend in San Francisco an. Und wenn du sagst halt in Hamburg irgendwie Call my Girlfriend, dann sagt er dir, ja, hast du aber nicht, geh mal Reeperbahn.
Meinst du, das ist die Matrosenoption sozusagen? Location-based Girlfriend.
Ich finde das schon befänglich ganz cool.
Also ich dachte mir, als erstes, als ich das gesehen habe, dachte ich mir ja so Creepy. Ich finde Spracherkennung und irgendwie mit so einem Teil reden, ist irgendwie Creepy. Ich meine, du redest mit dem.
Kommt doch an, wie es funktioniert. Also man müsste jetzt mal abwarten, aber.
Also meine Erfahrungen mit Spracherkennung waren bisher nicht sehr gut, ja. Also es mag Horistiken geben, es gibt auch eine Ausnahme, die ist schon ewig her.
Kannst du dich nur erinnern, wo ganz früher bei jedem Mac irgendwie ein Mikro dabei war?
Computer? I did not understand.
Hätte ich das jemals erzählt?
Also das hat niemand benutzt, niemand.
In der MacUp stand irgendwann mal vor Jahren stand mal so ein Artikel, so ein Tipp drin, dass wenn man, ich glaube der Spruch war, Long live the Mac, Death to Microsoft sagt, dass man einem dann ein total lustiges Gedicht vorlesen würde.
Stimmt das?
Und ich hab, ich hab den, ich hab so mit, das muss so Ende der 90er gewesen sein, ich war Schüler, mein Englisch war unter aller Sau und ich hab dann den ganzen Tag vor diesem Rechner gesessen und Death to Microsoft, Long live the Mac. Und wirklich so probiert das, bis ich dann irgendwann drauf gekommen bin, dass es Aprilheft war. Ja, okay, ich weiß, wovon ihr sprecht.
Es ist so ein bisschen Creepy, ja? Geht da irgendwie durch deine Daten, redet mit dir, la la la. Und ich meine, klar, sie haben jetzt natürlich 1000 Beispiele, wo das alles ganz wunderbar funktioniert und ja, und ruft mich an, wenn ich, sagt mir Bescheid, wenn ich zu Hause bin und so viele Reminders. Ist schon eine coole Idee alles. Aber das will ich echt erstmal im Einsatz sind. Ich war schon sehr, sehr, sehr überrascht, dass sie das zum Start weg in Englisch, Französisch und Deutsch rausbringen. Also gleich in zwei der etwas komplexeren Sprachen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt so entscheidend ist, wie komplex die Sprache ist oder ob nicht die eigentliche Logik wirklich die, also ob eine komplexere Sprache es ihm nicht sogar einfacher macht, den Kontext zu finden. Ob es nicht im Englischen sogar viel schwieriger ist.
Könnte sein. Komplexe Sprache heißt ja mehr Information. Genau, das ist einfach so mit... Packungsdichte.
Genau, du hast da irgendwie Fälle und so weiter. Keine Ahnung, ob der das irgendwie berücksichtigt. Das wird auf jeden Fall noch mal spannend zu sehen.
Also wenn wir sagen, rufen meine Freundinnen an, ist irgendwie alles klar. Wenn die sagen, call a friend oder call my friend, dann wissen sie ja gar nicht wen.
Aber es gibt doch diese Spracherkennung. Wenn ich hier irgendwie rufe Dennis ansage, ich meine, ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass irgendein Gerät und vor allem kein Apple-Gerät jemals auch nur ein einziges Mal das Richtige getan hätte. Also ich...
Du benutzt halt keinen Schwein, siehst man ja.
Ja, es ist ja drin, diese Sprache.
Wobei, wir wissen ja, Finanzamt für Körperschaften 2.
Ja gut, Finanzamt für Körperschaften 2, Telefonnummern-Auskunft, gut.
Ja, aber es gibt da offensichtlich was in der Richtung. Und ich meine, sie haben sich da vermutlich in den richtigen Laden eingekauft. Und sie hätten... Wie war das damals beim 3GS? Wurde das überhaupt so richtig fett erwähnt, dass es jetzt auch diese Sprachsteuerung hat? Oder war das nicht mehr so ein...
Ja, das haben die das erwähnt. Die machen da mal eine riesen Story draus, so wie da auch. Hauptsache, die Leute kaufen es und wenn die nach einem Monat es nicht benutzen oder sowieso später, dass keiner benutzt es, ist doch egal. Hauptsache, die haben den Hype und die Presse.
Bei dem 3G S, da war... Hey, wir haben jetzt das iPhone 3G S und SSS steht für Speed und das hat mehr das und eine bessere Kamera und kein Video. Das waren so die primären Dinge, die da so im Vordergrund standen. Und ja, es hat auch so Voice Control. Das war dann so eins von, wie ich fand, relativ viele Features weiter hinten. Und hier ist es so, dass ja, das ist ein geiles Telefon und technisch besser und alles besser, aber ganz weit vorne, also hat ja auch mit Abstand die meiste Zeit gehabt in der Präsentation, ist diese Serie.
Und ich glaub, die scheinen sich sehr sicher zu sein. Aber das heißt aber lange nicht, dass die Scheiße wirklich funktioniert.
Natürlich nicht, aber wenn Apple sich sehr sicher ist, dann wie lang haben sie denn bezahlt für den Laden?
Also die werden es schon wissen, aber gesagt haben sie es glaube ich keinem. Was, ich hab da ein bisschen darüber nachgedacht. Es gibt natürlich einen sehr interessanten Aspekt dabei, wo ich sagen würde, gut, fine, prima, wenn das wirklich gut funktioniert, bitte schön. Das ist die Tatsache, dass natürlich überall wo jetzt Texteingabe ist, kann ich auch Spracheingabe machen. Und wenn das wirklich bedeutet, dass ich eben meine Tweets diktieren kann, oder SMS, dann wäre ich ganz angetan davon. Also dann wäre das echt cool, weil manchmal dauert mir das einfach zu lange.
Ich glaube meine Freundin wäre auch sehr glücklich.
Weil sie dann mehr twittern kann, oder weil du da mehr Zeit hättest?
Weil sie dann, also sie hat im Augenblick sogar so eine leichte Sehenscheitelentzündung vom Tippen auf dem iPhone. Was die für Mails auf dem iPhone runter tippt, ist echt sagenhaft. Ich gucke da manchmal so, sie sitzt die ganze Zeit auf dem iPhone und macht irgendwas, dann gucke ich immer über die Schultern, sehe ich, dass sie da schon, ich würde auf einer normalen Tastatur nicht so lange Mail schreiben, wie sie regelmäßig wirklich auf dem iPhone runterdrischt. Und wenn du da eine Spracheerkennung hast, wow, die funktioniert. Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das so für viele Leute wirklich, wenn es funktioniert.
Ja, die Blinden werden wahrscheinlich jubeln.
Na die sowieso.
Weil das bedeutet jetzt auch noch so direktes Diktieren von Text und gar nicht mal nur so das Sprachgestalt bedienen an der Tastatur.
Und ich bin mal gespannt, wenn sie das aufmachen. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt schnell passieren wird, dass Siri eine AP bekommt, aber wenn dann jede App sich da einklinken kann und ihre Dienste da mit reinpappen kann.
Haben sie da was zu gesagt?
Ich glaube nicht. So haben sie kein Wort gesagt, hab ich jedenfalls nicht mitbekommen.
Gab irgendwie so einen Moment, wo mir dann auch das durch den Kopf gegangen ist. Ich weiß bloß nicht mehr, ob das durch einen kommentaren, konkreten oder unkonkreten Kommentar ausgelöst wurde.
Also meine Vermutung ist, dass es erstmal nur für sich machen und jetzt erstmal noch so ein bisschen rumprobieren und dass wir dann spätestens mit iOS 6, vielleicht ein bisschen früher.
Ja, guter Hinweis von Homocyt ist mir auch im Video eingefallen, in diesem Video. Da haben sie doch diesen ganzen Dialog mit hier Antworten folgendes auf diese SMS. Und dann hat da diese SMS einfach nicht nochmal vorgelesen, sondern einfach losgeschickt. Also ich sag nur autocorrect me. Also was der autocorrect jetzt schon alles für Fails erzeugt hat, da haben sich Leute irgendwie erschossen gegenseitig, weil da die einen Buchstabe falsch war.
Guckt ehmals hin, wenn ihr eine SMS abschickt, die tippt ihr nur ein. Wobei von dieser Webseite, dieses Dan, you're autocorrect, das meiste davon ist doch fake.
Nee, glaub ich nicht. Also hatten wir schon mal die Diskussion. Ich glaub's nicht. Ich glaub, das ist sowas von echt.
Also da sind einige Sachen dabei, da kommt auch die Wortlänge nicht hin und so was. Das scheint mir doch sehr, sehr unglaubwürdig. Also einige mögen echt sein, aber...
Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass natürlich Leute da Sachen einschicken, die das so absichtlich so ein bisschen hinschummeln, aber ein paar sind einfach, das siehst du, wenn das so eine längere Konversation ist, da siehst du einfach, dass das nicht fake ist. Das ist so aus dem Leben gegriffen. Ja, ich hab in diesem Jahr, glaube ich, noch nicht so gut gelacht, wie beim Lesen von Demiou Autokorrekt. Das ist einfach so echt. Ich kann bei echten Sachen einfach am besten lachen.
Willst du dich hier ein bisschen akustisch entkoppeln, zwischenzeitlich? Dann benutze doch einfach meine moderne Information.
Ja, aber da ist doch immer der Akku alle und dann geht das nicht. Oder ist jetzt hier... Ah, mal gucken, welche... Akku geht, ich nehme alles zurück und...
Okay, was hatten wir noch an Hardware-Features? Die Batterie ist wieder ein bisschen, also nicht vielleicht größer, aber das verbraucht weniger das Phone oder wie die...
Warte mal, stopp, stopp, stopp.
Ich vergleiche ja nicht mit den alten Zeilen.
Es gab noch was Cooles und zwar, was ich wirklich geil fand, ist, dass sie Wolfram Alpha integriert haben. Mit Wolfram Alpha habe ich so... also 50% Erfolgschancen, aber da war ich zumindest schon teilweise sehr beeindruckt. Weiß nicht, ob du Wolfram Alpha jemals schon benutzt hast, aber das ist teilweise echt klasse. Bloß vor allem, was ich unglaublich beeindruckend finde an Wolfram Alpha, und an der Stelle geht es ja mit diesem Siri auch, naja, weiß ich gar nicht, ob die so Hand in Hand gehen oder sich nicht vielleicht sogar noch gegenseitig stören. Hängt von dieser Integration ab. Aber dieses Wolfram Alpha finde ich einfach irre, wie es deine Fragen auseinander nimmt und dann interpretiert, was du wohl vielleicht gemeint haben durftest.
Und wer sich unsicher ist, zeigt auch einfach gleich alles an. Also er fragt ja nicht nach, sondern...
Ja genau, der ist ja sehr auskunftsfreudig. Und Wolfram Alpha kann man halt schon echt komplizierte Sachen fragen. Das weiß ich so. Oberfläche der Erde und sowas, solche Zahlen einfach mal generieren und dann irgendwie gleich noch in irgendwelche Formeln einfließen lassen, etc.
Ich hab heute da mal den Wetterbericht abgefragt. Der war beeindruckend.
Bei Wolfram Alpha kann man sogar den Wetterbericht abfragen.
Da gibt es einfach ein Weather und dann sagt er ja alles klar, hier das Wetter für Berlin und dann zeigt er dir noch an die Regenwahrscheinlichkeit und was die Prognose war und was sind dann die echten Werte waren und zeigt dir noch die höchsten und tiefsten Werte für das letzte Jahrhundert mit an und weiß ja toll über was.
Ich nutze das viel zu selten, glaube ich.
Ich auch. Aber es könnte natürlich durch genau sowas, könnte es natürlich so richtig schön in Fahrt kommen.
Genau, das war nämlich auch so mein Gedanke. Weather in Berlin.
Schauen wir hier nochmal.
So, dann lädt er jetzt hoffentlich noch ein bisschen mehr.
Assuming Berlin, Germany.
Ja, und dann auch gleich so die Alternativen, die du hier angeboten bekommst.
Schauen wir mal runter.
Ups, Entschuldigung, ich hab gerade einen Fehler gemacht.
Ich mach das einfach nochmal hier.
So, was soll ich machen?
So, mal ein bisschen runterscrollen, wenn es fertig geladen ist. So, siehst du, da kannst du jetzt noch, da siehst du noch die Wetterkurve.
16 Grad, clear.
Dann siehst du noch die Cloud Coverage, da siehst du noch die prognostizierte Cloud Coverage.
Wie ist denn die Regenwahrscheinlichkeit zum Sendungsende?
Also im Augenblick sind wenig Wolken auf jeden Fall. Insofern sieht das mal ganz gut aus, ne?
Regenwahrscheinlichkeit ist hier gar nicht angegeben.
Naja, und doch doch, die Regenwahrscheinlichkeit aber nur tageweise, die ist nicht so exakt. Und da sieht man halt die Temperaturen der letzten Jahre am 5.
Oktober.
Bis 1930 zurück, ja?
Ja, mehr gibt es wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht.
Und dann noch mal ein paar Informationen, wo denn die Wetterstation eigentlich ist, was natürlich immer ganz spannend ist.
Ja, das ist einfach unfassbar.
Wisst ihr, woran mich das Ganze erinnert hat? Und ich war nicht der Einzige, den es daran erinnert hat? Besonders als er ihn gefragt hat, wer bist du eigentlich? Und er geantwortet hat, I am your humble personal assistant. Na, ein Herr sowieso, aber... An den Knowledge Navigator. Habt ihr das Video gesehen? Knowledge Navigator hieß das Ding. Und das ist ja das Krasse. Die Prognose, also das ist ein Video von 1987, wie Apple sich die Zukunft vorstellt. Und es ist halt so ein Typ, so ein Universitätsprofessor, ich hab mir das heute nochmal angefangen, der mithilfe seines Knowledge Navigators seinen Tag rettet, indem er seine Mutter abweist und weiß der Teufel was und sich noch auf in der letzten Sekunde eine Vorlesung zusammenklickt bzw. zusammenspricht. Er kommuniziert die ganze Zeit mit seinem Gerät. Und es ist wohl auch ein Datum angegeben in diesem Video, wann sich das Ganze abspielt. Und es spielt sich ab am 16. September 2011. Das heißt, sie lagen um einen Monat daneben mit dem Gerät.
Vorausgesetzt, dass das Gerät jetzt auch, also ich meine, noch nicht ganz da, aber es geht in die Richtung.
Es ist schon ein anderes Device und ist auch wesentlich kleiner. Das echte iPhone ist wesentlich kleiner als das, was sie sich damals vorgestellt haben. Es ist auch schon geil zu sehen, wie diese Vision damals, wie sehr die abweicht von dem, was wir heute haben. Aber wenn man sich dieses Video, was der da abspielt, wenn man sich das einfach mal anguckt, was die dann vorgeführt haben mit dem iPhone und was man dann so denkt, wenn man zum Beispiel, also er hat so was gesagt...
Kommunikation, eingehende Kommunikation, Kontext interpretieren oder auch bereiten.
Oder auch, wie wär's denn hier? Willst du diesen Artikel von deinem Freund sowieso vorlesen? Das ist ja mit Facebook-Integration. Ist der jetzt mein Freund oder nicht, ist da wirklich relativ simpel. Also, was die da drin erzählen, ist alles andere als undenkbar. Das ist, also 1987 mag das Science-Fiction gewesen sein, aber wir sind jetzt wirklich so weit, dass so viel fehlt da nicht mehr hin.
Schon krass.
Dit fand ich toll.
Alarm-Clock fand ich noch ein gutes Beispiel. Das ist in der Tat etwas, wo ich mir dachte, das müsste man doch auch einfacher machen. Also wenn du wirklich dem Ding sagen könntest, weck mich morgen um acht.
Nee, wir haben auch Weck mich in einer Stunde.
Oder sowas.
Das kann man im Augenblick dem Ding nicht sagen.
Jaja, richtig.
Und dann richtig geil ist dieser Reminder, wie der heißt, wo man sich einen Location-Fans machen kann. Ich bin jetzt auf Arbeit, wenn ich hier die Gegend hier verlasse, dann erinnere mich, dass ich ja noch einkaufen gehen wollte. Das könnte man dann auch wieder umdrehen, dass man sagen kann, weil es gibt ja auch hier die, dass man seine Freundin jetzt finden kann. Man kann sich freischalten so für einen Tag. Und man kann schon sagen, okay, wir sind bis heute Abend irgendwie unterwegs, solange dürfen meine Freunde mich lokalisieren. Und dann könnte man ja auch bauen, dass man sagt, irgendwie remind me, wenn meine Frau nach Hause kommt, damit ich meine Freundin schnell wegschicke. Mit iCloud dann, ne?
Ja, dieses Find my Friends haben sie ja auch vorgestellt.
Also ich finde es gut, mit diesem, dass ich sagen kann, bis heute Abend, also mit diesem Disneyland, er findet seine Familie auf Disneyland, war schon eigentlich eine ziemlich coole Idee. Wenn ich mit meinem Kumpels Motorradtour mache, sagen wir alles klar Jungs, bis heute Abend machen wir hier, dass wir uns gegenseitig finden können, wenn einer dann mal die falsche Abzweige nimmt, dann weiß man genau, da ist er. Das ist schon ein Messebesuch. Ja, oder sowas, genau.
Das hatte ich schon häufiger. Da wollte ich dann immer Latitude dann irgendwie dafür benutzen, und dafür war es dann immer zu schwierig. Und da man dann immer weiß, Gott, wenn ich das jetzt einschalte, vergesse ich bestimmt, das wieder auszuschalten.
Aber da muss ich sagen, so, ich finde das, das ist so Apple, also zum einen zu Find My Friends, dieser Lederlook, der geht ja echt gar nicht. Das ist...
Ja, es ist...
Es wird langsam mehr.
Das passt überhaupt nicht zu diesem Alu- und Glas-Bauhaus-Style, den die so ein bisschen haben, finde ich. Dieses schöne Technische, finde ich so.
Ich finde ja so Leder, Glas und Alu geht jetzt schon noch an sich.
Ich finde diese Apple-Holztische da, ich finde die passen auch schon gar nicht mehr so richtig.
Die fassen super, finde ich.
Die haben Glas-Tische. Also, willst du das haben? Glas-Tische?
Nee, schon auch Holz, aber irgendwie anders als so.
Anderes Holz.
Ja, und nicht so grob...
Sperrholz.
Nicht so grob eckig, sondern irgendwie ein bisschen...
Runder.
Vielleicht, weiß nicht.
Kann ich nicht so genau sagen.
Steve schickt mich.
Aus welchem Film ist es? Die Andersons wollen alles geändert haben. Na, wer hat's?
Ich kenn den Film nicht.
Und Eddie Murphy sucht ja ein Haus, sieht, dass die da gerade am Bauen sind, geht da so hin und meint, ja, nee, hier, die Andersons wollen alles geändert haben.
Wie ist das wohl im Original?
Da hab ich noch viel mehr Deutsch gekostet.
Ja, also okay, der Lederlook geht gar nicht, aber ansonsten fand ich auch, hat so dieses, da könnte so viel mehr rein, das ist natürlich, also ich, ja, so dieses iPhone-App, das ist so Apple-typisch, wir haben so ein absolutes Minimum, und dabei wird es jetzt wahrscheinlich bis ans Ende aller Ewigkeiten bleiben. Man kann sagen, hier, das sind meine Freunde und den kann ich jetzt follow, und das ist alles sehr auf Privacy und alles eher konservativ, aber ich hab mir zum Beispiel, was ich ja ein tolles Feature wäre, wenn, dann zeig mir doch nochmal die Freunde von den Freunden an und frag die, also wenn man sich sozusagen spontan zu einer Gruppe versammelt, also du bist irgendwo und dann haben die das Beispiel mit der Familie bei Destiny Land. Nun kann es aber ja auch sein, dass da durchaus noch die Familie, also das Zweifamilien zusammen losfahren. Und dann hat der Sohn sich mit, hat sein Sohn sich mit seinem Kumpel da, den Ort geschert und das dann dein iPhone dir dann zeigt, hey willst du den nicht auch gleich noch mitfragen, wo er ist, damit du die ganze Gruppe zusammenhalten kannst für den einen Tag. Das würde ich ja zum Beispiel ans Dufte finden.
Aber eigentlich reicht es ja, wenn du deinen Sohn hast, weil wenn du den gefunden hast, dann findet der ja auch seinen Kumpel zur Not. Also es würde schon auch irgendwie gehen.
Ja, aber du willst ja vielleicht spontan, also ich will nicht nur, Ich hab das mal verstanden, dass du da beliebige Leute mit reinwerfen kannst. Die müssen ja nicht in deine Hand...
Wie funktioniert das dann?
Dass du die halt irgendwie hinzufügst, über die Telefonnummer, Mobile, Me, iCloud-Adresse oder was?
Ja, aber warum bietest du das eh nicht direkt an?
Vielleicht tut es das ja auch. Die haben ja mit diesem Programm nicht sehr viel Zeit verbracht.
Also ich vermute mal, das wird tendenziell relativ simpel gestrickt sein und wird das, was es kann, halbwegs gut machen, aber...
Vermute mal... Vermute mal heißt nicht wissen.
Na das sowieso nicht. Aber wir sind ja nicht bei Bits und so. Wo man weiß, wir sind hier bei Puma Max, wo man vermutet.
Ja das stimmt. Das stimmt. So. Das wars irgendwie mit meinen iPhone Notizen. Der Rest war alles unspektakulär.
Ich hab hier noch was entdeckt beim Durchstöbern von iOS 5.
Achso du wurdest ja für den Hörern ja schon vorab gelobt.
Stimmt.
Preiswürdig erachtet.
Wobei ich ja ehrlich sagen, also es ging darum, dass ich ja auf die Bold Prediction einer Uhr, dass Apple eine Uhr rausbringt.
Das haben sie jetzt in dem Sinne nicht gemacht. Sie haben zumindest zugegeben, dass es Leute gibt, die ihr Nano als Uhr benutzen.
Und haben eine Mickey-Maus-Uhr zum Nano hinzugefügt.
Und eine Mini-Maus-Uhr.
Und eine Mini-Maus. Und die ich ja tatsächlich ganz schick finde, diese LED-Leuchtuhr. Die fand ich ganz cool. Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, dass so früher in einer Markthalle zu DDR-Zeiten stand ein Wagen rum, die hatten solche Anzeigen. Ich fand die total geil als Kind. Das ist so richtig.
Also das könnte wirklich... Ich weiß nicht, hat jemand von euch eine Uhr?
Nee.
Kennt ihr Leute die Uhren?
Die Armband-Uhr.
Die Armband-Uhr. Wann hast du das letzte Mal eine Armband-Uhr getragen, Dennis?
Ich hab keine exakten Zahlen, aber es könnte sowas in dem Dreh sein. Vor allen Dingen, mittlerweile ist es ja so, wenn man jemanden mit Armband-Uhr... Ah, der hat keine Ahnung von Technik. Würde und der würde eine Armband-Uhr tragen, dann würden alle sagen, hey, wer bist du denn?
Hm, nur hab ich das noch nie gesehen. Es gibt so Tage, da denke ich mir, so eine Armband-Uhr wäre schon cool wieder.
Um die Zeit abzulesen?
Naja, weil man sich dann schon anders synchronisiert und dieses ganze Uren, also ich verspüre eh einen Mangel an Uren in meinem Leben. Weil die Uhr ist mir auf dem Alphorn...
Kann man dieses Zitat so, ich verspüre einen Mangel an Uren in meinem Leben?
Ja, weil das Problem mit diesen ganzen Handys ist, dass es auch weniger öffentliche Uren gibt. Deutschland ist ja eigentlich ein Land, was gepflastert ist mit öffentlichen Uren. Der Deutsche an sich ist obssessed.
Mit Uren.
Mit Uren und Zeit-Synchronisationen.
Wie mehr zählst du das?
Öffentliche Uren sind einfach mal... Fahr mal in andere Länder. Ich meine, da gibt es auch welche, aber du merkst sofort so einen Mangel. Allein so dieses werbefinanzierte Uhr steht irgendwo rum, Ding ist hier sehr weit verbreitet, Bahnhof-Uren und so. Wie gibt es schon auf dem Bahnhof, auf dem Hauptbahnhof gibt es mir schon zu wenig Uren. Das finde ich furchtbar, wie wenig Uren es auf dem Bahnhof gibt. Weil eigentlich erwarte ich beim Bahnhof, dass ich auch nur irgendwo hingucke und ich sehe sofort, wie spät es ist. Weil das ist auf dem Bahnhof mal wirklich, wirklich wichtig. Habe ich eine Armbanduhr, dann schaue ich da auch auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise hin. Ich synchronisiere mich sozusagen die ganze Zeit. Ich habe mehr die Sekunden als nur die Minuten im Kopf. Und da ist man dann irgendwie ganz anders getaktet. Ich würde wahrscheinlich sogar weniger Straßenbahnen verpassen. Wahrscheinlich.
Ernsthaft? Das Problem habe ich, glaube ich, gar nicht.
Ich würde es schon gerne mal drauf ankommen lassen, nur mir ist der Nano jetzt für so einen Test dann doch zu teuer.
Ich finde ehrlich, ich bin mehrfach, wurde auf Twitter gesagt, dass ich sozusagen die Bold Prediction, wobei das würde ich nicht mal gelten lassen, weil die haben halt den Nano so ein bisschen aufgepimpt. Der ist eigentlich nur 10 Euro billiger geworden. Und dann haben sie halt nochmal so ein paar mehr Watchfaces mit reingeschmissen.
20?
Oder 20, weiß ich nicht. Der kleine ist 10 Euro, der große 20 oder irgendwie so. Ist ein bisschen billiger geworden. Ansonsten hat sich da echt gar nichts geändert. Na doch, die Navigation hat sich ein bisschen geändert. Dass die Eigens jetzt größer sind. Damit auch Blinde, wie ich jetzt, hinzukommen.
Schick mir mal eine iMessage bitte.
Soll ich mal eine iMessage schicken?
Jetzt weiß ich, glaube ich, sogar wieder, was die letzte Uhr war. Die letzte Uhr, die ich wirklich aktiv benutzt habe, habe ich so Mitte der 90er Jahre benutzt. Und das war eine Sportuhr. Also eine sehr ausgefallene Start, Stop, wie sagt man, Stop-Uhr-Funktionalität.
Ich hatte hier so eine Casio, diese dicken Klopper hier, so eine G-Shock. Und warum blinkt jetzt hier die LED nicht? Ja, es gibt jetzt hier bei dem Assistant so ein Ding, dass man so ein LED-Flash machen kann, wenn man Alert kriegt. Aber es hat nicht funktioniert gerade.
Macht er das vielleicht nur im...
LED-Flash vor Alerts.
Wo ist die Einstellung dafür?
Bei Accessibility?
Das finde ich ehrlich gesagt mal...
So mit Höhenmessern, so einen Uhr hatte ich. War eigentlich ganz cool. Ich bin bis dreieinhalbtausend gekommen in Neuseeland.
Aber mehr nicht.
Ja, nur der iPod Nano hat aber keine gute Stoppuhrfunktion, oder?
Ich glaube irgendeine Stoppuhr hat er. Doch, die wird eine Stoppuhr drin haben. Der hat ja auch ein Pad. Dieses Nike Zeug und so, die müssen doch sowas haben, oder nicht?
Die hat ja auch nicht mal richtige Knöpfe.
Ja, dann touch da halt aufs Display drauf. Aber der wird eine Stoppuhr haben, schon allein für dieses Nike Zeug.
Aber aufs Display drauf touchen ist kein...
Auf jeden Fall, was ich... Was ich sagen wollte ist, von der Uhr habe ich was komplett anderes erwartet. Nämlich, dass das quasi, dass das... Erstens, dass das dein Siri-Input-Device wird. Kid, fahr schon mal die Wagen vor.
Starte die Stoppuhr jetzt.
Beim nächsten... Das wär eigentlich ganz cool.
Ja, so Dick Tracy ist ja eigentlich so ein bisschen die Vision.
Das wär's. Oder eben auch ein Display noch drauf zu haben, dass man so... Ich find ja so, diese Uhrzeit, ja, das ist eine nette, das ist eine schöne Sache, aber das ist halt so Pull und nicht so Push. Das ist... Du sag dir nicht...
Ja, was wir brauchen ist ein iPhone Nano.
Du meinst so ein Mini-iPhone?
Ja, also wie ein Nano, so groß, aber eben mit der Funktionalität eines iPhones.
Oder dann hält man sich so...
Mit 3G und Siri und viel kaputt.
Also ich muss jetzt gerade ein bisschen... Damit man telefoniert.
Ja, also die richtige Dick Tracy Uhr. Weil eigentlich, wenn du das iPhone auf diese Nano-Größe runterpolizieren würdest, angenommen es wäre möglich, alles, was jetzt im iPhone ist, da reinzubauen. Man könnte ja ein paar Kompromisse eingehen mit Flash und so weiter. Halt, dass das Ding 3G hat und dass du diese ganzen Kommunikationstools hast. Und dass du es trotzdem noch halbwegs flexibel mit Touch benutzen kannst, auch wenn es eben eine andere Display-Größe ist. Damit auch eine andere Input-Größe. Auf dem Webbrowser könnte ich da sogar noch verzichten. Oder man hätte halt speziell auf den Nano angepasste Webseiten.
Der Akku hält fast acht Sekunden.
Aber dann hättest du genau diesen Dick Tracy-Effekt.
Naja, aber den könnte man ja eben auch haben, wenn das Ding einfach nur Bluetooth kann und mit deinem iPhone was in deiner Tasche steckt, die ganze Zeit über kommuniziert.
Das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist...
Nee, Gebimsel.
Das ist so wie diese Scheiße, dass mein MacBook eher kein 3G hat. Da muss ich dann immer noch so ein iPhone daneben liegen haben, um ein Internet zu haben.
Das ist einfach, das geht nicht.
Das ist so süß, einfach immer dabei.
Das ist erniedrigend. Doch, furchtbar. Wieso? Ich meine, gibst du dir hier so ein Höllen Geld aus, hast du irgendwie so ein Teil, was riesig viel Platz hat und dann ist du noch nicht mehr in der Lage zu funken?
Bitte dich.
Du mein, es hat alle möglichen Antennen, aber die benutze ich ja nicht die ganze Zeit.
Bluetooth und so weiter.
Dann benutze ich schon mal Bluetooth am MacBook Air. Nur um mit meinem iPhone zu tazern. So, gleich 3G einbauen.
Aber das wird jetzt viel besser gehen, dann ja mit dem neuen iPhone 4S, weil das hat ja dann auch Bluetooth 4.0.
Was hilft mir das?
Stromspanne. Also die können wohl, dass eine Bluetooth-Verbindung dann, ich glaube, in 1, irgendwas Millisekunden aufbauen.
Ja, aber muss es ja mein MacBook Air auch können.
Du hast ja das Aktuelle, das kann das. Also dafür könnte das echt spannend sein. Und ich bin mal gespannt, ich würd's mal, wenn ich's dann habe, werde ich mal...
Es bleibt immer noch dieses ganze Getessere. Dann funktioniert das nicht, dann siehst du das Teil nicht, dann weißt du nie warum und dann Pairing und nochmal löschen aus der Liste und wirst bekloppt. Ich will das nicht. Ich will da einfach Internet an sagen auf meinem MacBook Air. An, an, an.
Musst du Siri sagen.
Genau. Sie sollen hier Creepy in das Air einbauen und dann setz ich mich da vor und sag, Internet an. Und Schluss, keine Diskussionen. Keinen, wo ist denn dein iPhone, Nachfragen oder so ein Scheiß? So was durch mit dem iPhone-Thema? Also Fazit, ich finde das Upgrade ist okay.
Hardware-mäßig.
Ja, da ist einfach jetzt was geschehen irgendwie. Das Ding ist jetzt ein anderthalb Jahr auf dem Markt.
Ja, aber mal ehrlich, da ist auch eine Menge nicht geschehen, was viele dachten, was so geschieht. Also breitere Bildschirme, Metallrückwand.
Nee, ist Quatsch. Also ich hab von mehreren Leuten gehört, ja jetzt kommt ein 16 zu 9, 4 Zoll, irgendwas Display.
Nein.
Nee, war nicht. Also warum?
Das hätte mich wirklich echt extrem überrascht.
Weil warum jetzt die armen Entwickler noch mal zwingen, dann noch eine Auflösung mit einzubauen?
Wie groß hätte ja die gleichen Pixel sein können?
Wir hätten einfach eine Größe.
Dann brichten aber alle Annahmen, die deine Software macht über Touchfeldgrößen und Auflösungen und Pipapo.
Und was hat man davon? Dann hättest du ein größeres Gerät mit kürzerer Akkulaufzeit, weil ja dann mit größer und...
Ja jetzt kann man das sagen, dass es ja alles total klar ist, wo das nicht draußen ist, aber es wurde vermutet.
Es wurde vermutet, ja.
Das hätte mich sehr überrascht.
Mich hätte es sehr überrascht. Ich hab es nicht ausgeschlossen, dass sie irgendwie auch bereit sind, irgendeinen Bold Move zu machen, weil sie jetzt der Meinung, weil sie irgendwie festgestellt haben, dass die Welt, dass die Ölreserven 10 Jahre länger halten, wenn sie das machen. Aber es hätte mich trotzdem bewundert. Und eigentlich sprach relativ wenig dafür. So, aber jetzt sag mir nochmal, was dem iPhone 4S fehlt. Was du jetzt... Ich erinnere mich noch an deine Worte. Du meintest ja auch, an dem Ding ist ja jetzt eigentlich alles okay. Dir würde ja gar nicht so viel einfallen, was sie da noch anders machen sollten. Dann haben wir es aufgezählt, haben gesagt, bisschen schneller, bisschen mehr Grafik. Bisschen schneller, bisschen mehr Flash. Das ist alles passiert. Was haben wir noch gesagt? Ich weiß es im Einzelnen nicht mehr so genau. Fällt dir noch was ein? Aber im Wesentlichen war der Meinung, dass das Industrial Design so okay ist. Und so ist es gekommen. Jetzt ist es total da. Und ich finde, es ist ein Worthy-Upgrade. Es ist nicht unbedingt so, dass man sofort loslaufen muss, wenn man ein iPhone 4 hat. Es sei denn, man ist im Fotografier- oder im Videobereich schwer unterwegs. Ich meine, es ist immerhin eine 1080p Videokamera mit 30 Frames pro Sekunde. Das ist nicht ohne. In der 64 GB-Variante ist das mal eine echt billige Videokamera. Die haben auch noch diese Bildstabilisierung mit drin. Also ich bin sehr gespannt auf die Ergebnisse. Aber wer so gerne Videos macht, für ihn ist das sicherlich eine geile Taschenkamera. Und mit diesem Stativ, mit diesem iClub-Ding und so weiter wird das echt flexibel.
Ich bin ja gespannt, ob Apple dann auch irgendwann mal die Lanze bricht und die Videos einfach mal mit 50 Frames pro Sekunde aufnimmt.
Was, das werden sie wahrscheinlich nicht tun.
Irgendwer muss ja mal anfangen.
Das sieht mir gar nicht an. Was mich wirklich überrascht hat, ist, dass der iPod Touch vollkommen unverändert ist. Das ist echt krass. Also so komplett unverändert ist. Die Erklärung haben sie mitgeliefert. Sie wollen ihn billiger verkaufen. Was waren das? 30 Dollar billiger? 20? 20, 30 in der Größenordnung.
Warum sollte man ein Produkt richtig doll ändern, wenn irgendwie das verkauft wird wie blöd? Weil du willst die Latte ja nicht unbedingt voll hochlegen, weil du musst ja auch was für dein nächstes Upgrade noch haben.
Ja, was dafür spricht...
Apple hat das schon häufig getan. Als der iPod Nano der erste war, der erfolgreichste iPod, genau den haben sie dann ausgetauscht.
Also ich finde, da spricht schon eine Menge dafür, insbesondere weil bisher das immer so waren, dass die iPod und iPhone weitgehend gleich waren, technisch, also was Prozessorleistung angeht und Displayauflösung und diese ganzen Sachen. Und dass man sich als Entwickler, wenn man für ein iPhone entwickelt hat, also für die aktuelle Generation, konnte man sich sicher sein, dass es auf dem aktuellen iPod ungefähr genauso laufen wird. Und gerade bei Spielen, was glaube ich für ein iPod ein extrem wichtiger Bereich ist, gilt das jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr. Nämlich der iPod hat jetzt einfach mal eine wesentlich schlechteren Prozessor und eine wesentlich schlechtere Grafik als das aktuelle iPhone. Das finde ich schon ein bisschen...
Dafür ist er auch viel billiger. Und er ist noch viel billiger geworden im Hinblick darauf, dass das iPhone sogar etwas teurer geworden ist.
Möglicherweise.
Und andererseits gibt es jetzt immer noch das 3GS. Auf welchem Stand ist dieser iPod Touch eigentlich? Da ist ein A4-Chip drin.
Das ist quasi jetzt iPhone 4.
Das ist wie ein iPhone 4.
Genau, nach wie vor.
Und das iPhone 4 geht bei 520 Euro los.
Und was kostet der so, der kleine iPod Touch?
Der kostet jetzt 200. Und 200, das haben sie ja auch gesagt, 200 Dollar ist so eine magische Marke. Das ist so, du tauchst unter diese 200 Dollar und hast auf einmal Kaufreflexe bei Leuten, die sie so einfach bei 220 Euro nicht anspringen. Oder Dollar. Das ist das Gleiche.
Warte mal, war das nicht, hat das nicht...
Wer hat das Ding vorgestellt?
War das nicht bei der Kindle-Prosentation mit den 100 Dollar magische Grenze?
Egal. Das kann gut sein und sicherlich ist 100 Dollar auch eine magische Grenze.
Es gibt diverse, die magischen Grenzen.
Genau.
Ja, also das finde ich einen schöneren iPod Touch, der so ein A5 drinnen hat und einen besseren Prozessor. Das wäre schon geil gewesen. Das hätte ich schon.
Ich frage mich jetzt allerdings immer noch, was die Produkttransition ist. Das macht mich total madig. Offensichtlich lag ich da komplett daneben. Tja, was ist denn sonst noch so passiert? Es war ja seit der letzten Sendung. Wir sind jetzt durch mit iPhone und iOS. Da ist ja nichts Neues. iCloud haben wir alles irgendwie schon besprochen. Das brauchen wir nicht.
Das sind Tausend Kleinigkeiten, die die Leute jetzt entdecken. Jetzt wo es irgendwie die GM gibt und die Beta sozusagen ein bisschen so ein Stable angekommen ist. Aber so richtig rausfinden, dann werden wir es in der nächsten Sendung, wenn alle das wirklich schon auch eine Woche haben. Und dann geht es richtig ab.
Genau, so sehe ich das auch. Amazon. Ich sage Amazon.
Du meinst hier dieses Fire-Dingens, ja?
Naja, ich meine, Amazon schickt sich doch an, so ein bisschen eine der wenigen Firmen zu sein, die Produkte veröffentlichen, die zumindest Sinn machen.
Die kein iPad sind, äh iPad, nach Ahmerversuch.
Genau, aber trotzdem in einem ähnlichen Bereich spielen.
Ist ja überhaupt so ähnlich, aber egal, da können wir ja erst mal drüber erzählen.
Naja, ich meine, es ist insofern ähnlich, als dass du eben, das sind nicht zwei komplett unterschiedliche Sachen, sondern es ist wie ein kleines tragbares Teil, auf dem man Bücher lesen kann. Du kannst ja mit dem iPad noch sehr viel mehr machen, als nur Bücher lesen, aber das kannst du jetzt eben auch mit dem Fire. Du kannst immer noch nicht all das tun, was du mit dem iPad machen kannst. Die Frage ist...
Wollen wir direkt reinspringen oder wollen wir kurz erwähnen, was da überhaupt passiert ist?
Genau, vielleicht erst mal erzählen, was passiert ist.
Äh, so. Amazon hat drei, mit einem riesengroßen Keynote auch, mit Apple durchaus vergleichbar. Ich hätte es mir auch gerne mal angeguckt, muss ich sagen. Ich hab aber bisher...
Du glaubst keine Filme, oder?
Ich glaub nicht. Ich hab aber auch ehrlich gesagt nicht richtig nachgesucht. Aber das würde ich mir schon mal ganz gerne geben. Und Amazon hat wie lange erwartet worden war, dem Kindle jetzt etwas hinterher geschoben, dem Kindle 3, den mir auch ich zu eigen nenne, und zwar den Kleinkindle... Wie heißt denn der? Der Kleine ohne irgendwas. Egal.
Der heißt Kindle.
Der heißt einfach nur Kindle.
Also der normale Kindle heißt... Also der kleinste Kindle heißt einfach nur Kindle.
Genau. Das ist einfach... Der sieht aus wie der bisherige, außer dass unten die Tastatur abgesägt haben, was sehr praktisch ist, wenn man die Tastatur eigentlich für nichts braucht und es ihnen nur im Wekrum liegt. Und der ist jetzt dafür wesentlich kleiner geworden. Und ansonsten im Wesentlichen das gleiche Gerät, aber die Software haben sie ein bisschen verbessert. Dann geht es soweit so unspektakulär.
Und kostet 109 Dollar ohne Werbung.
Genau, macht man nur die ohne Werbung Preise. Oder ich meine die anderen, das ist ja schon...
Das ist ja so ein Detail. Du sparst dir 30 Dollar, wenn du das Ding Werbung anzeigen lässt.
Also 79 Dollar ist schon echt eine fette Ansage. Es gibt Bücher, die sind deutlich teurer. Wenn man nur gelegentlich mal ein Buch liest, dann ist das wahrscheinlich schon ein Preis, den man gibt.
Ja, aber wie, das kannst du nicht vergleichen mit einem Buchpreis. Also klar, Marc, das Ding kostet so viel wie ein Buch, aber das Buch zahlst du ja trotzdem.
Natürlich zahlst du das Buch trotzdem.
Und wahrscheinlich sogar noch mehr als...
Aber das ist schon günstig. Also da würde ich sogar ich jetzt noch überlegen, ob ich mir nicht noch mal so ein Teil hinlege.
Also ich habe ja sehr abgerannt damals über den Kindle, aber inzwischen muss ich sagen, dadurch, dass ich die Kindle-Software auch auf dem iPhone und so was habe, so dieses einfach mal... also ich kauf wesentlich mehr Bücher. Ich sag nicht unbedingt, dass ich sie dann auch lese, aber so dieses, ich kann mir jetzt ein Buch kaufen, das ist sofort auf dem Gerät und ich kann mich nach draußen setzen. Jetzt, wo das Wetter noch so schön war, habe ich mich schön im Büro dann gerne mal auf die Dachterrasse gesetzt und ein bisschen gelesen. Das ist schon sehr, sehr geil, dass man nicht drei Tage oder mehrere Tage auf das Buch warten muss, sondern so, jetzt habe ich das. Also wenn man Bücher liest, dann sind diese 80 Euro oder 100 Euro und dann sollte man sich da wirklich eigentlich keinen Kopf drüber machen, sondern dann gibt man die eben dafür aus. So, dann haben sie noch den Kindle Touch, der ist irgendwie so, glaube 20 Euro teurer oder irgendwie sowas in dem Dreh, oder 20 Dollar. Wobei, das finde ich auch spannend, bis auf den kleinen Kindle haben sie ja bisher noch nichts für außerhalb der USA angekündigt. Da gibt es ja noch nicht mal Ankündigungen, wann die kommen könnten oder sowas. Das ist bisher nur der Original Kindle. Zumindest an dem Abend. Dann gibt es diesen Kindle Touch, das ist quasi der gleiche Kindle mit Touch-Bedienung, wobei das eine Infrarot-Touch-Bedienung ist, was für so ein Lesegerät gar nicht so schlecht ist, weil da muss halt keine zusätzliche Schicht über dem Display drüber liegen, sondern es wird über Sensorik gemacht, die mit einem Display-Rahmen setzt, die das Infrarot ausmisst. Also es liegt keine zusätzliche Schicht über dem Display, die das Bild verschlechtern könnte, aber diese Infrarot, das ist kein gutes Touch. Das mag ausreichen, um so ein Gerät zu bedienen, aber für mehr taugt das auch nicht.
So eine XY-Koordinatengeschichte.
Ja, und wahrscheinlich auch hinreichend ungenau und weiß ja toll, was. Aber für so ein Gerät sicherlich eine tolle Sache. Und dann haben sie halt, das war so der Angriff auf das iPad. Tam-dram-dram, der iPad Killer TM.
Moment, es gibt auch noch denselben Touch. Gibt es das auch noch in einer 3G-Variante. Den normalen Kindle gibt es nur mit WLAN, Touch gibt es mit 3G. Und dann gibt es diesen alten Keyboard-Kindle auch nach wie vor und auch in dieser 3G-Variante. Und meines Wissens ist es aber auch alles billiger geworden. Der kostet ja auch nur 99 Dollar.
Der Kindle-Keyboard kann sein. Ja, dann ist er halt ein bisschen billiger geworden. Den würde ich aber ehrlich gesagt nicht nehmen. Also ich weiß nicht, ob die Software dafür jemals aktualisiert wird. Ich glaube darin ist Amazon nicht, sondern nicht gut, dass man sozusagen die neuen Features bekommt. Weil er hat nämlich auch so ein paar, was der Kindle jetzt kann, das ist also im Wesentlichen der Kindle-Touch ist eigentlich nur eine Reaktion auf diesen Nuke oder wie der heißt. Also von Barnes & Noble, der dann so ein Maßstäbe gesetzt hat. Und was der Barnes & Noble nämlich hat, der muss keinen Refresh machen beim Umblättern. Das haben sie ihm abgewöhnt oder abgetrickst eigentlich eher. Er macht den Refresh nur alle paar Mal. Also normalerweise muss bei so einem Display einmal komplett schwarz, einmal komplett weiß. Und dann kann man erst hinschreiben, was man gerne sehen möchte.
Ja, kenn ich von Textern noch. Genau. Also Bedingungen von dem Display. Man kann das zwar so ein bisschen tricksen, aber dann bleiben so Ghosting-Effekte stehen. Man kann es so zwei, drei Mal machen, aber irgendwann muss man mal wieder ordentlich refreshen.
Exakt. Und bei diesem Barnes & Noble-Teil, da machen sie nur alle sechs Seiten, wird dann der komplette Refresh gemacht. Genauso macht es Amazon jetzt auch. Also die haben da schon sich sehr genau angeguckt, was Barnes & Noble da macht, und machen das jetzt genauso. Und dann haben sie halt diesen Kindle Fire vorgestellt. Und das ist ein Android-Gerät, bei dem sie wahrscheinlich nicht mal erwähnen, dass es Android ist.
Irgendwo erwähnen sie es im Hinblick auf den App Store.
Genau, dass ihr Android-Market darauf läuft. Aber das könnte theoretisch sogar, müsste das nicht mal ein Android sein. Und das ist jetzt sozusagen ihr 7 Zoll... Ich hab mir also gedacht, vor dem iPad hätte man das Ding als Media Player bezeichnet. Da hätte niemand gesagt, das ist ein Tablet, sondern es ist ein Media Player.
Wie das so bei Archos ist, ne?
Ja, das ist eigentlich ein Media Player mit Apps. Da kann man Bücher drauf lesen, da kann man Zeitschriften drauf lesen, kann man Filme drauf gucken.
Amazon sagt auch nicht, dass es ein Tablet ist.
Das sagen alle anderen nur.
Sie sprechen nur von E-Readern.
Und ich glaub nämlich, also ich sehs auch nicht so richtig, also ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich ein Tablet ist.
Was auch immer es ist, es ist auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Move, weil Amazon im Gegensatz zu den anderen Herstellern, die versuchen hier mit Android irgendwelche iPad-artigen Geräte auf den Markt zu schmeißen, die dann scheiße teuer sind, die haben halt richtig was zu bieten. Die haben Content. Ja und vor allem sagen sie einem von vornherein, wofür es ist, das zum Lesen, das zum Filme angucken und ist zum, was kann dieses Teil eigentlich noch hier dieser Feier?
Na was in Amerika...
Musik abspielen natürlich.
Was in Amerika glaube ich extrem beliebt ist, ist dieses Amazon Prime. In Deutschland kann man das auch dazu buchen. Das ist, dass man irgendwie billiger und schneller geliefert bekommt und dafür irgendwie 80 Euro im Monat zahlt. Genau und dafür hat man irgendwie, oder eben reduzierte Versandkosten zumindest. Was ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt 80 Euro im Jahr dafür ausgeben, damit mir Amazon die Sachen dann ohne Versandkosten liefert, finde ich ehrlich gesagt, für mich ist es kein guter Gegenwert. Aber in Amerika hat man dafür noch deutlich mehr. Da kann man nicht dann zum Beispiel auch auf Fernsehserien kostenlos zugreifen. Und die kannst du dir dann, also bisher konntest du dir halt über einen Webbrowser oder sowas angucken und jetzt geht es über deinen Kindle Fire. Und wenn du sowieso schon Amazon Prime Kunde bist, dann die 200 Dollar nochmal hinzuletzen, um dir so ein Gerät zu holen, mit dem du schön immer die neuen Serien kostenlos streamen kannst, das klingt schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Also ich kann mir das auch gut vorstellen, dass der Kindle seinen Erfolg haben wird. Ich weiß nicht in welchen Dimensionen, Amazon niemals bereit sein wird, diese Dimensionen zu nennen, die sie da erreichen. Ich meine, sie reden immer viel von, wie sie im Vergleich zu irgendwas ganz gut Dinge verkaufen. Aber mal so eine konkrete Installed Base habe ich jetzt von dem Kindle noch nicht gelesen.
Also bei Kindle 3 haben sie massiv mitbeworben das best verkaufte Produkt auf Amazon aller Zeiten.
Was heißt das schon?
Ich glaube, das war...
Vorher lief es scheiße und jetzt haben sie drei verkauft. Das ist auch das best selling.
Nee, von allen Produkten bei Amazon.
Anschließend der Bücher.
Einschließlich Alm. Also ich glaube, das Ding verkauft sich wirklich gut.
Da weiß ich immer noch nicht, was die maximale Zahl ist, die sie von irgendwas schon mal verkauft haben. Also es gab keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet.
Ich glaube, das Ding bringen sie schon ganz gut unter die Leute.
Machen sie uns das Glauben.
Und ich glaube, das wird beim Kindle Fire nicht anders sein. Das ist ein Gerät, bei dem weiß man wofür es gut ist.
Im Chat wird behauptet, der habe sich 250.000 Mal verkauft. Gucken wir mal, dass wieder nur verkauft oder shipped ist.
In fünf Tagen, das sind dann wahrscheinlich Vorbestellungen. Bei irgendjemand meinen Vorbesteller schon bei 350.000. Naja, das Ding wird schon gut weggehen.
Aber wie wir wissen, kommt es ja nicht immer nur auf die Hardwaren, sondern auch auf die Software und auch nicht nur auf die Software, weil da ist ja Android drauf oder was, ne? Sondern auch wie lange die halt ihre Infrastrukturen und halt die Backend-Services dahinter pflegen.
Also, ich glaube darum braucht man sich relativ wenig Sorgen zu machen. Das Ding wird eine Weile gepflegt werden. Also zum einen, von dem Android kriegt man nicht sonderlich viel mit. Das ist irgendein Android 2.1 Branch, glaube ich. 2.1? 2.1, das ist schon ein bisschen älter. Und seitdem hat das kein neues Android mehr gesehen. Das heißt, das wird über kurz und lang mit der normalen Android-Base nicht mehr sonderlich viel zu tun haben.
Meine Telefone haben ja auch noch nicht sehr viel Neues gesehen.
Klar, aber auch das User-Interface sah null nach Android aus. Das ist übrigens das erste Interface, was ich mal ganz spannend finde, was sich auch total vom iPad unterscheidet, insofern, dass bei allem, was man bisher gesehen haben, waren die Apps im Vordergrund. Wenn du so ein Telefon nimmst, egal ob Android, WebOS, bei Microsoft sind es immerhin diese Tiles.
Ich hab da alle aufgefressen.
Na, hier gibt es ja noch mehr. Guck mal, da sind noch welche. Da gibt es noch diese Tiles. Und bei Honeycomb sind ja auch Apps. Und bei dem Ding hier sind, wenn du dir das Pressematerial von Amazon anguckst, da sind Zeitschriften, Bücher, Videos und irgendwo ist auch noch Angry Birds zu sehen. Also es ist so ein bisschen als, dass es eigentlich mehr so ein Mediengerät. Ich glaube, da wollen sie es auch haben. Die wollen es gar nicht als Konkurrenz am iPad haben, so dringend.
Ich denke, dass es auch, ich meine, dieses iPad hat jetzt endlich mal Konkurrenz. Das muss man natürlich schreiben, aber es ist, glaube ich jetzt nicht unbedingt, dass es...
Das ist ein Killer-iPad.
Es ist kein Killer-iPad, sondern ich glaube, dass die Kindles einfach ihren eigenen Markt machen. Also durch das Kindle verkaufen sich, vielleicht gibt es irgendjemanden, der sich dann kein iPad kauft, aber ich glaube, dass die Leute, die derzeit ein iPad erwägen, sich jetzt nicht von einem Kindle davon abhalten lassen, das zu tun, sondern im schlimmsten Fall beides kaufen.
Was ich ja gerade auch an diesem Video, und das ist noch das Beste, was man sehen kann, auf der Kindle-Fire-Seite, da gibt es auch dieses Demovideo, man sieht, sie zeigen das Interface noch nicht. Sie zeigen, also man sieht im Wesentlichen immer nur dieses, man sieht den Startbildschirm, wie da irgendjemand durchbraust. Und ansonsten wird gar nicht viel vom Internet viel vom Interface gezeigt. Entweder ist das so extrem unwichtig. Aber das ist das Interface, was du da siehst. Man sieht dieses List, man sieht, wie es ein bisschen rumscrollt. Also das hier, was man hier sieht, dieses Bücherregal, ich glaube, das ist wie beim iPad oder iPhone das Springboard. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Vom Webbrowser sieht man gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Der steht total im Hintergrund. Ich glaube, es liegt ein bisschen daran, dass der noch gar nicht so richtig fertig ist.
Wann kommt der raus?
Irgendwann, ich glaube, was war es? Mitteln November. Also noch ein bisschen Zeit hin. Und was mir an den Videos aufgefallen ist, die ich gesehen habe, so bei den üblichen This is my Next und Gizmodo und so, keiner von diesen kamerahaltenden Bloggern durfte das Gerät selber in die Hand nehmen. Sondern es stand immer ein Amazon-Mitarbeiter, der gezeigt hat, hier guck mal, so geht das hier mit diesen Rumswipe und hier geht das und das. Dann haben sie auch einen Browser gezeigt und hier zeigen sie auch den Browser, also der funktioniert. Aber wenn ich von dem Produkt so richtig mega hundertprozentig überzeugt bin, dann würde ich da sagen, hier habt ihr, probiert es aus, überzeugt euch, wie geil das ist. Aber das haben sie noch nicht gemacht. Ich glaube, der ist noch nicht ganz so fertig, wie sie vorgegeben haben.
Der ist noch nicht fertig, sie wollen ihn aber trotzdem zum Weihnachtsgeschäft raushaben, deswegen haben sie jetzt schon mal mit Vorbestellung gearbeitet.
Was ich noch so gehört habe über das Ding, ist, dass natürlich jetzt alles wunderbar ist, die Gerüchteküche, aber dass das Ding nicht von ungefähr so aussieht, wie ein Blackberry-Gerät, wie dieses Playbook. Genau, das ist weitgehend dieselbe Hardware. Die sind zum seinem Hersteller und haben gesagt, wir hätten gerne dieses Playbook mit anderer Software drauf und haben gesagt, hier, bitte, nehmt's. Also es ist quasi, man kriegt ein Playbook für 200 Dollar. Und was war es noch? Achso, ja, und dass sie ein bisschen damit rechnen, dass es angeblich creppy werden würde in der ersten Version. Also das ist sozusagen Bananen-Software.
Wer rechnet damit?
Apple-User.
Amazon selber sagt, dass ihre...
Sagen sie nicht, aber hinter vorgehaltener Hand, so richtig fertig ist das eigentlich noch nicht. Und wahrscheinlich werden die da regelmäßig Software-Updates nachliefern. Die wollen erst mal rein.
Also schauen wir mal, ja, ich finde das immer so, dieses hat sich so und so 1000 Mal verkauft, das Teil ist noch überhaupt nicht da. Die Frage ist, wie viel 100.000 Mal wird es danach wieder zurückgegeben, wenn es tatsächlich mal ausgeliefert wurde und es gefällt den Leuten nicht? Also jetzt von irgendetwas zu sagen, es wäre jetzt schon ein großer Verkaufserfolg, obwohl es das noch nicht ein einziges Mal über den Tisch gegangen ist, ist ein bisschen schwierig. Trotz alledem, ich finde einfach Amazons Ansatz interessant und vor allem wird mir auf ein zunehmendem Maße auch klar, dass, ähm, naja, Amazon ist halt einer der Big Four. So, das muss man sich echt mal wieder wachrufen und das zeigt sich auch an diesem Produkt, dass sie mit ihrer Cloud-Technologie dahinter eben hier einfach schwer einsteigen in so ein ganz modernes Geschäft. Apple tut es jetzt auch. Sie hatten schon alles andere, ihnen fehlte nur die Cloud. Amazon hat die Cloud, ihnen fehlte quasi das Gerät vorne und die anderen beiden haben halt teilweise entweder noch gar kein Gerät oder, naja, haben vielleicht bald auch mal ein eigenes Gerät.
Die anderen beiden, Google und Microsoft.
Nee, Facebook. Facebook und Google. Facebook, Google, Amazon und Apple.
Und Microsoft?
Das ist nicht unter dem Big Four.
Aber Facebook?
Ja, Facebook auf jeden Fall. Was ich bei dem Ding ja spannend finde, bei Amazon, die haben das komplett gegenteilige Geschäftsmodell von Apple. Während bei Apple, das finde ich ehrlich gesagt inzwischen sehr sympathisch an der Firma. Ich weiß bei Apple, womit sie ihre Kohle machen. Nämlich darüber, dass sie mir das Gerät verkaufen. Und damit verdienen sie ein Schweinegeld. Und bei iCloud zahlen sie mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit drauf. Außer, dass es Kundenbindung ist, in der Hoffnung, dass ich irgendwann wieder ein iPhone kaufe. Ist ja auch nicht ganz unberechtigt, die Hoffnung. Die Hoffnung ist sozusagen, Apples Geschäftsmodell ist, Dinge zu verkaufen. Bei dem Ding zahlt ja Amazon wohl drauf, nach dem, was hier die üblichen Verdächtigen nachgerechnet haben. Und zwar die Materialkosten von so einem Kindle Fire liegen wohl bei 250 Dollar. Verkauft wird es für 200. Das heißt, sie müssen 50...
Das ist gar nicht erlaubt in Amerika.
Sie müssen 50... Wieso nicht?
Du darfst nicht unter Preis verkaufen. Du darfst keine Unkosten beim Verkauf machen. War das nicht so irgendwie?
Das wär mehr neu.
Dann hätte HP jetzt ziemlich massive Probleme.
Mit dem Touch-Best für 90 Dollar. Irgendwo gibt es ein Gesetz, du darfst nicht unter Preis verkaufen. Und das hinten drum verdienen, das irgendwie... Könnte ich schwören.
Das macht jeder Druckerhersteller dieses Planeten.
Aber unter Preis oder nur plus minus Null?
Du willst mir nicht sagen, dass HP-Druckerpreise kostendeckend sind.
Ja, so ein scheiß Plastedrucker kostet auch nichts.
Ja, aber eben so wenig, wie sie eben tatsächlich kosten. Sondern die verdienen an der Tinte.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber der Chat, oder wer auch immer, wird es besser wissen.
Genau, da wird bestimmt irgendwas rausfinden. Also auf jeden Fall... Das Kindle Fire kostet in der Produktion 250, wird verkauft für 200. Das heißt, sie müssen mindestens 50 Dollar haben, um es nach vorne zu verdienen. Und das finde ich mal ganz... Bei Amazon sehe ich ja wenigstens ein, womit sie das verdienen wollen. Die verkaufen ja da eine Menge Content drüber und darum geht es. Also das ist eigentlich, das haben sie bei diesem Bildet Analyze, dieser Marco-Armin-Podcast, haben sie so schön als Vending-Maschine, also als Verkaufsautomat. Du kaufst hier für 200 Dollar deinen Amazon-Verkaufsautomaten, mit dem du dann weitere Inhalte kaufen wirst.
Aber machen wir uns nichts vor. Auch das iPad ist ein Verkaufsautomat.
Natürlich.
Weil letztlich kannst du auch den Scheiß halt auch nur bei Apple kaufen. Oder eben zumindest verdient Apple bei jedem Verkauf mit.
Von daher ist es schon auch ein Verkaufsautomat. Wenn ich auf dem iPad Kindle-Content kaufe, dann verdient Apple daran kein Cent.
Doch. Weil du kannst keinen Kindle-Content kaufen auf deinem iPad.
Doch, indem ich auf amazon.com.de gehe.
Ja, auf dem Browser, aber nicht in den Apps.
Nicht in den Apps. In den Apps gibt es da nicht. Aber wenn ich Kindle-Content kaufe, verdient Apple daran kein Cent. Klar, the web is free. Und das könnte Apple zumindest theoretisch auch egal sein, weil sie haben an dem iPad schon genug verdient. Wohingegen Amazon wäre sowas nicht egal, weil die haben fett draufgezahlt. Das ist so wie früher die Spielkonsolen. Die zahlen erstmal schön fett drauf und hoffen, dass sie die Spiele wieder reinzuholen. Die hoffen halt hier über Spiele, Filme, Musik, weiß ja was. Die müssen dir halt noch eine Menge Scheiß hinterher verkaufen. Und ich glaube, darum ist es für Amazon auch extrem wichtig, je länger sie die Infrastruktur für dieses Kindle-Fire am Leben erhalten, desto weniger zahlen sie im Endeffekt drauf. Also die werden gar keinen großen Anspruch haben, dir jedes Jahr ein neues Gerät zu verkloppen. Weil wozu? Sie werden ja im Zweifelsfall wahrscheinlich draufzahlen.
Naja, wir werden es sehen, ne? Ja, was ich am bemerkenswertesten fand an dem Amazon, ist eigentlich die Software. So hardware-mäßig ist es ja nicht so. Dieses neue Silk-Webbrowser-Teil, was sie da sich zusammengeklickt haben, basiert ja auch auf WebKit. Und nutzt halt optional, und das ist auch der Default, nutzt eben diese ganze Cloud-Architektur von Amazon, also ihre ganze Elastic Cloud EC2.
Warum das?
Weil sie eben auch mit einem schwachbrüstigen Gerät noch volle Performance erzielen wollen. Das ist zumindest so ihre primäre Aussage. Sie optimieren einfach den Zugriff auf die Webseiten, so ähnlich wie das auch Opera Mini macht auf seine Art. Und wie heißt noch gleich dieses andere Opera-Produkt?
Ja, Opera Turbo.
Genau. Das ist ja auch alles so diese Beschleunigungsidee durch Cloud-Computing. In dem Modus verwendet der Silk dieses Speedy-Protokoll, was glaube ich Google mal in den Ring geschmissen hat, SPDY, was darauf optimiert ist, die Latenz beim Übertragen von Webseiten zu reduzieren. Das benutzt halt eigentlich kaum irgendjemand, aber Silk benutzt das eben jetzt. Und es ist wahrscheinlich ein Chrome auch mit drin. Nur, dass sie dann eben ganz bewusst ihr EC2 benutzen. Das heißt, Webseiten, die eben schon mal versurft wurden, landen da entsprechend im Cache und werden dann eben auch nicht aus diesem Cache über den normalen HTTP-Weg ausgeliefert, sondern dann eben auch über das schnellere Protokoll. Also es prirendert wahrscheinlich die Grafiken dann auf die Anzeigegröße, die in dem Moment eingesetzt wird, optimiert und so weiter und so fort.
Naja, aber so, also ich frag mich immer noch, wozu eigentlich, also was machen sie da genau? Weil, also Bandbreite sparen bringt nicht wahnsinnig viel. Weil das Ding hat kein 3G, sondern nur WLAN.
Na die Daten, es geht schneller.
Ja, genau, was geht da schneller? Also Reduzieren.
Die Übertragung.
Einfach durch die Latenz. Sie fragen nicht so viele Server an.
Ja, Latenz ist das, was Dinge langsam macht. Die Bandbreite ist gar nicht so sehr das Problem.
Na, es hängt immer vom Netz an, mit dem du bist. Bei GPRS ist auch die Bandbreite ein gigantisches Problem. Also da kannst du auch...
Ja, bei GPRS ist Hopfen und Malz verloren, aber trotzdem ist die Latenz dein Hauptfeind. Gerade bei so Webseiten, die eben... Ich meine, wenn du so Spiegel online oder so was runterlädst, hab ich jetzt nicht gezählt, aber bei halbwegs komplexen Webseiten, die du dir anschauen willst, hast du einfach hunderte von Objekten, die hunderte von entsprechenden Netzwerkverbindungen und entsprechende Latenz mit sich bringen.
Also wir haben es mal getestet. Wir haben es einfach mal nebeneinander gehalten. Und das einzige Video, was wir gefunden haben, wo jemand was aufruft...
Was habt ihr nebeneinander gehalten?
Erzähl ich gerade. Da sieht man so ein Video, wie einer von diesen Amazon Präsentations-Hinies, Präsentationsmenschen IMDB aufruft. Und das dauert so irgendwie um die zwei Sekunden. Dann haben wir einfach mal ein iPad genommen und haben da IMDB drauf aufgerufen. Das hat so um die zwei Sekunden gedauert. Also zumindest in dem Fall hat es jetzt nicht wahnsinnig viel gebracht. Zumindest was die Latenz angeht.
Das ist genauso schnell wie auf dem iPad. Das iPad kostet aber das Zweieinhalbfache.
Ja, aber es liegt nicht an der Bandbreite und es liegt offensichtlich nicht an der Latenz.
Wieso?
Die Latenz ist ja auch größer, wenn dein Rechner langsamer ist, weil er dann länger braucht, bis er dann wiederum antworten kann etc. Also alle Komponenten fließen damit ein. Das ist nicht nur die Latenz auf der anderen Seite, das ist auch die Latenz auf deiner Seite. Du musst verarbeiten, du musst JavaScript ausführen, bevor das JavaScript gearbeitet ist.
Der Prozessor von dem Ding ist doch gar nicht langsam. Also wenn das wirklich ein Playbook ist im Wesentlichen.
Du, wir reden hier über eine Hardware, die wir nicht kennen. Tatsache ist, Amazon hat das da eingebaut. Sie werden schon ihre Gründe haben. Ich glaube ihnen jetzt allerdings nicht, dass es nur diese Performance-Geschichte ist, weil sie dadurch auch einfach Proxy spielen für die ganze Welt und das ganze Clickverhalten auch noch mit abscannen können.
Da gab es doch diesen Artikel, wo drin steht, dass Google weiß halt nur mehr oder weniger, was du suchst und kann dann sehen, was gerade so aktuell ist. Bei Amazon wissen jetzt sogar, was du surfst. Also direkt, ohne dass da Google-Werbung auf der Seite sein muss. Und wir sehen sozusagen dann alles und wissen, was die Leute, was gerade geht und wie die Preise sind und so weiter und so fort.
Soweit die Verschwörungstheorie.
Aber mal ehrlich, wenn die so unterpreisverkaufen, irgendeinen Grund muss es ja haben, dass sie, oder andersrum, irgendwo muss die Kohle auch wieder reinkommen.
Na ja, über den Content, die sie verkaufen.
Die paar Bücher meinste?
Was heißt die paar Bücher? Das sind Videos, das ist Musik, das sind Bücher, das sind Apps, das ist, das ist alles, was sie verkaufen.
Das ist ihr Business. Keiner macht Retail, Electronic Retail, so gut wie Amazon.
Und das wird mehr werden, die machen darüber Fernsehserien?
Die besten, die verkaufen dir einfach alles. Und das ist schon nicht das schlechteste Business, in dem man drin sein kann. Amazon, wie auch Ebay und so weiter, diese ganzen großen Würfe der frühen Zeit, die waren vor allem deshalb erfolgreich, weil sie einfach von vornherein sich Geschäftsmodelle gesucht haben, wo es ganz konkret um Geld ging und wo einfach klar war, womit Geld verdient wird. Und nicht so was Kokosheim-mäßiges wie Netscape und viele andere, die dann halt irgendwann auch versagt haben. Oder bis heute noch nach einer Antwort suchen auf diese Frage, womit sie denn eigentlich Geld verdienen. Twitter und so.
Ja, aber Sie haben... Amazon hat im Augenblick ein überzeugendes Geschäftsmodell als Google, was ihr Betriebssystem, ihre Tablet-Ausflüge angeht sozusagen. Ja, keine Frage.
Facebook auch.
Facebook? Ach so, ja. Das fand ich auch ganz spannend, dass die da eine Facebook-App direkt auf dem Start-Screen packen. Das heißt, die haben da wahrscheinlich auch schön mit Facebook kooperiert bei dem ganzen Ding.
Ja, das brauchst du halt. Ich meine, das ist eben das, was die Leute heute wollen. Die wollen irgendwie Bücher und Videos und sie wollen Angry Birds spielen und sie wollen ihr Facebook-Brausen. Und das kannst du damit halt machen.
Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, ob und wie man da eigenen Content draufkriegt. Also beim Kindle, beim E-Book-Reader-Kindle geht das ja irgendwie, aber es ist wirklich Payne in the Ass und Amazon lässt einen schon an diversen Stellen spüren, dass das nicht der bevorzugte Weg ist, da Content draufzukriegen auf das Gerät. Ich vermute mal stark, dass es bei dem Teil ähnlich sein wird. Und die Leute, die kritisiert haben, dass das iPad ja nur reines Abspielgerät für Content ist, das ist jetzt glaube ich bei dem noch wesentlich stärker ausgeprägt. Ich glaube nicht, dass es da so etwas wie Garageband für geben wird.
Das glaube ich allerdings auch nicht.
Das glaube ich auch nicht.
Mir fehlt dabei diesen ganzen Tablet-Würfen, die die immer mal so schnell dahinschmeißen, wobei das hier, wie gesagt, Amazon schon noch ein bisschen größer ist. Aber mir fehlt aber so ein bisschen das Langzeitkonzept. Und da ich schon zu viel gesehen habe, irgendwie Geräte, die nach ein paar Monaten wieder in der Versenkung verschwenden und du hast dann so ein Device, das irgendwie keinen Support, keinen Nix und weißt schon halt, da wär's mir irgendwie zu risky.
Da würde ich immer erstmal abwarten.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei Amazon kommen wird, aber wenn du dir irgendwelche anderen Geräte anguckst, weiß ich nicht.
Also bisher haben die ja, die haben den Kindle, den gibt's ewig. Der ist jetzt in der dritten Generation.
Kindle ist doch was komplett anderes. Kein WLAN ist schon irgendwie schwarz-weiß.
Natürlich hat das Kindle WLAN. WLAN und gibt's auch mit 3G. Ich will da sonst Inhalte drauf bekommen.
Ja, aber es ist halt nur so ein E-Ink-Teil.
Doch, hat USB.
Man kann's aber keine Spiele spielen.
Na, mit dem Fire schon jetzt.
Mit dem Fire schon. Aber was kommt jetzt halt? Die wissen schon mittlerweile ein bisschen, wie man sowas macht. Die wissen, dass man da ein bisschen Atem braucht und den sitzt er auch bereit, beizustecken.
Der Kindle als E-Reading-Only-Teil in seinem ganzen schwarz-weißen Appeal. Das ist quasi der originale iPod. Ja, das war auch so ein schwarz-weiß Teil. Da sind ja aber echt sechs Jahre hinterher. Das ist eine andere Technologie. Digitale Musik gab es da, digitale Bücher. Das kommt jetzt erst. Nicht, dass man das nicht auch schon hätte früher machen können, aber so ist es nun mal. Aber auch diese E-Ink-Geschichte war 2002. Also es gab es zwar schon, aber in dem Maße war es halt einfach noch nicht produzierbar oder zumindest wurde es nicht produziert. So und jetzt ist der Kindle seit Anfang 2008, kann er glaube ich, raus. Ende 2007.
2007, genau.
Das sind also dann acht, neun, zehn. Das Ding gibt es also jetzt quasi seit dreieinhalb Jahren. Und jetzt versuchen sie eben ihren nächsten Schritt mit diesem Fire. Und das ist quasi wie der iPod Touch oder das iPhone eben, der dann eben aus dem Musikplayer auf einmal eben etwas macht, was noch sehr viel mehr ist, wo dann du auf einmal eine iPod ab drauf hast, wo der iPod nur ein Icon von vielen ist und so ist das jetzt auch mit dem Fire.
Aber wenn die da das Android benutzen, haben die da auch nicht so viele Möglichkeiten, da irgendwie richtig schön einzugreifen, oder?
So software-mäßig.
Sie haben es ja nur als Basis genutzt.
Nicht so wie Apple halt. Wieso?
Wir haben doch den Source Code.
Das sind auch keine Erfahrungen in US-Infrastruktur, alles drumrum.
Deswegen habe ich das vorhin mit den Big Four nochmal erwähnt. Was man sich glaube ich echt nicht klar macht, ist, wie dominant diese vier Firmen derzeit sind. Weil es sind einfach die vier Firmen, die das mit dieser Internetinfrastruktur richtig raus haben. Nix skaliert so sehr wie Google, Amazon, Facebook und Apple. Das sind einfach die Firmen, die erfolgreiche Internetinfrastrukturen haben und zu behaupten, dass Amazon keine Ahnung von Software Development hätte. Ich bitte dich, die haben Apis draußen für jeden Scheiß. Die haben diese ganze Elastik Cloud, dieses Computing. Die sind einfach der Mega-Hoster und verstehen viel von Internet. Das ist jetzt für die nicht so undenkbar, zumindest ein OS zu machen, wo sie dann ein paar Ups draufhauen.
Wir reden im Jahr noch mal drüber. Ich bin ja sehr gespannt.
Ein bisschen muss ich da Dennis Recht geben, weil die haben Backend und so, sind die sicherlich ganz weit vorne. Ich würde sagen, die haben wesentlich mehr Erfahrung als Apple mit hat. Also was diese ganze Serverinfrastruktur angeht. Was aber das Frontend angeht, finde ich, den Kindle, den ich jetzt zu Hause habe, finde ich von der Bedienung her eine totale Katastrophe, was nicht so schlimm auffällt, weil es ein Buchlesegerät ist und du im Wesentlichen die meiste Zeit über zwei Tasten nutzt. Und es ist halt, das Ding stinkt geradezu nach, ich bin billig produziert und ich bin nichts weiter als eine Verkaufsmaschinerie. Und da kriegt man mit, dass da mehr Marketing-Leute dran gesessen haben als Software-Entwickler dran gesessen haben. Und das ist halt, Amazon ist halt sehr stark ein Verkäufer. Und ich bin gespannt, wie sie das bei diesem Kindle Fire hinkriegen, wo sie plötzlich doch eine etwas komplexere Bedienung hast, wo es nicht mehr so einfach so vorwärts und rückwärts blättern ist, sondern du wirklich navigieren musst und du surfen musst und du so dieses ganze Zeug auch wirklich vernünftig brauchst. Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Na gut, aber um einen Web-Browser zu machen, muss man heutzutage einfach nicht mehr so sehr viel Hirnschmalz investieren. Das ist einfach beherrschbar. Ich traue Ihnen durchaus zu, dass dieser Silk einfach eine benutzbare Geschichte ist. Ich stimme euch ja total zu und ich will jetzt auch nicht Amazon als das nächste große Apple-File bieten. Das ist ja gar nicht das Ding. Dieser Fire entwickelt sich in eine ganz andere Richtung. Das ist jetzt nicht ein iPad. Sie sind nicht auf der Richtung, dass sie jetzt Applikations-Developer mit Myriaden von wohl ausgefeilten Apis versorgen werden, damit die da genauso großartige Software machen, wie sie jetzt auf dem iPad entsteht. Das ist ja nicht ihr Ziel. Ihr Ziel ist, diese Plattform als solche für Sie uber zu machen. Sie haben einfach eingesehen, wenn Sie da konkurrenzfähig bleiben wollen mit einem modernen e-Reader, dann muss man da auch Web drauf machen können und dann muss man da auch ein paar Spiele spielen können. Und wenn da jetzt ein paar Fullscreen-Ups drauflaufen, ich meine Angry Birds braucht einfach mal von dem OS quasi nichts und die anderen Spiele, die da laufen, da ist es wahrscheinlich auch ähnlich. So, und dann ist es halt einfach mit drauf und fertig.
Naja, aber das Ding muss vernünftige Usability haben und wir wissen, wie viele daran gnadenlos scheitern.
Ich finde das Gerücht interessant, dass sie vielleicht Palm kaufen.
Und du musst das stabil hinkriegen, dass es nicht abstürzt. Und es muss schnell sein. Und das ist was, was auch bis auf Apple so richtig noch keiner geschafft hat. Also das kriegt hier Microsoft so ein bisschen hin mit ihrem Windows, aber Android ist bis nach wie vor nicht schnell. Und das müssen sie erstmal schaffen.
Wie gesagt, das Teil ist ja nicht auf dem Markt.
Genau, das werden wir sehen.
Aber sie haben zumindest eine klare Vision, woher sie kommen, wohin sie wollen.
Und dass sie Palm kaufen wollen.
Hab ich so gelesen.
Das könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
Es ist for sale. Und sie sind die Einzigen, die jetzt noch ein Interesse daran hätten, so ein eigenes OS zu starten.
Ja, da könnte man, also, da gab es ja schon, ja, für die Patente vielleicht, weil jetzt sind sie ja plötzlich auch mit in diesem ganzen Patent-Wall drinnen. Ob das jetzt nochmal so eine spannende Frage wird. Und ansonsten vielleicht, um User-Interfaces vernünftig dafür zu bauen. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie auf Web-Oils schwenken würden. Warum nicht? Weil, weil sie schon, weil sie schon viel Geld in diesen Amazon App-Store investiert haben und da die Entwickler sich rangezüchtet haben. Und es gibt, ich meine, es gibt ja für, eigentlich ist das auch total...
Die Entwickler sich rangezüchtet, dieses Gerät gibt es noch gar nicht.
Nein, aber sie haben, sie haben diesen Android-Store, der ja auch sehr verhasstet von Entwicklern.
Ja, sie sagen, dass sie einen haben.
Nein, sie haben ja einen. Du kannst ja, du kannst ja, in Amerika zumindest, ich glaube in Deutschland geht es nicht.
Ach so, ja das Teil, das gibt es ja schon. Ja, aber das hat ja noch in dem Sinne gar kein Target, oder? Ist das für die alten Kindle gedacht?
Nein, für Android. Du installierst dir auf dein Android-Telefon, installierst du dir diesen Market. Und eigentlich ist das doch total schlau. Ich meine, die haben da diesen Market fertig, die nehmen sich das Betriebssystem, branchen das einmal, sagen, guck mal, hier brauchst du nur ein Knöpfchen zu drücken, hast deinen ganzen Scheiß bei uns drinnen. Für Android gibt es mit Abstand am meisten Geräte, Software außer fürs iOS. Ich meine, wenn die jetzt bei WebOS quasi nochmal bei Null anfangen, wozu? Da gibts doch den Scheiß schon.
Ja, sie könnten halt Android auch wegschmeißen. Wozu? Weil sie dann einfach unabhängig von Google sind. Unabhängiger sind von Google.
Ich glaube, die sind schon jetzt total unabhängig von Google.
Naja, wir werden es sehen. So, wollen wir das Thema Amazon mal beiseite legen? Dennis? Ich glaube, wir haben es, oder?
Haben wir noch irgendwas Spannendes? Ich kann ja noch mal meine magische Liste durchgucken.
Kleinkram hab ich noch.
Ich hab auch noch Kleinkram.
Wir haben jetzt noch nicht über Facebook geredet.
Was gibt es denn da zu reden? Ach, über dieses Dauer...
Ja, die haben ja auch diverse Dinge angekündigt. Du hast dir das angeschaut, ne? Ich hab mir das nicht so genau angeschaut.
Hat man hier schon dieses Ghostery in der Sendung?
Okay. Was ich noch mal schön zu den ganzen Amazons sagen wollte, ist die Schlagzeile. Verlegerverbände begrüßen Amazons Tablet als Gegenpol zu Apple iPad.
Da musste ich mir auch echt weglegen. So was von dumm und bekloppt, das ist einfach echt nicht zu fassen.
Ich meine, wie lange ist es her, dass Döpfner gesagt hat, dass die Verlagsbranche jeden Tag Steve Jobs anbieten, dem Herrgott danken soll, dass er ihn Steve Jobs gebracht hat, um die Verlagsbranche zu retten. Und jetzt kommen sie so, oh das war nicht der, ah der neue Highland!
Und in zwei Jahren werden sie dann einsehen, dass die Damen noch schlechter stehen.
Auch der hat das Gerät nicht nur auf den Markt gebracht, um uns weiter zu helfen.
Das ist halt das Gleiche, was man früher bei MTV gesehen hat. Das erste hatten sie Angst vor MTV, dann fanden sie MTV gut und am Ende hatten sie schon wieder Angst vor MTV, weil MTV den Markt bestimmt hat. Auch durch das, was sie ausblenden, war das nicht so. Und das war bei einer relativ langen Zeit. Und heutzutage geht halt alles ein bisschen schneller. Da kommt ein Jahr was, die freuen sich, haben dann gleichzeitig wieder Angst von der großen Macht und ein Jahr später freuen sie schon wieder auf die Konkurrenz. Aber ich meine, das stimmt schon, Konkurrenz ist für die immer gut. Also, dass sich das iPod mit dem Kindle battelt oder wie auch immer und die sich um die vielleicht um die Verlage streiten oder die zumindest eine Alternative haben.
Ich hab mir das erste Mal eine Keynote von denen angeguckt.
Du hast es nämlich gesehen, deswegen frage ich...
Genau, ich hab's gesehen. Ich hab auch Gründe gehabt, das zu sehen. Und zwar... Ich sitze ja mit in einem Büro... Also, NextBigSing, die Firma, bei der ich arbeite. Wir machen die Soundcloud-App fürs iPhone und sitzen mit Soundcloud in einem Büro. Und jetzt ist, hat Facebook etwas vorgestellt, wo Soundcloud mit Startpartner ist. Also, diese, die haben ja eine Menge vorgestellt, eine Menge Zeug. Und der Musikbereich, da ist unter anderem Soundcloud mit dabei. Und das wollte ich mir, ich hab das irgendwie im Vorfeld so gerüchteweise gehört. Oh mein Gott. Und dann wollte ich mir halt angucken, was kommt denn da jetzt tatsächlich. Und ja, so. Und darum hab ich mir das mal gegeben. Und am Anfang, ich bin ja voll drauf reingefallen, am Anfang war dieser Saturday Night Live-Typ, der Mark Zuckerberg nachmacht auf der Bühne. Na, die Einführung gemacht und ich dachte, oh Gott, ist dieser Mark Zuckerberg peinlich. Und dann nach einer Weile...
Du hast es nicht gedacht, dass es getwittert ist.
Ich hab sogar getwittert, genau.
Das hab ich nämlich gelesen.
Und dann nach einer Weile kam dann der Original Mark Zuckerberg auf die Bühne. Das war so ein bisschen so wie damals... Das gab's auch schon mal mit Steve. Es gab mal eine Kino, die ist nicht von Steve Jobs eröffnet worden, sondern...
Sondern von dem Typen, der in einem Film spielt.
Genau. Also das war eine... Aber das war halt bei dem Ding, bei der Steve Note war es damals so, das war ganz kurz und das war jedem sofort klar, dass das nicht Steve Jobs ist. Und dann ist Steve Jobs sofort auf die Bühne gekommen. Hier war das so, der hat erst mal rumgelabert, hat irgendwelche Zahlen vorgestellt und es war alles so mittelwitzig. Und dann war Mark Zuckerberg auf der Bühne und hat dann mit der eigentlichen Präsentation angefangen. Und dann wurde es erst mal so richtig peinlich. Der Typ ist wirklich so der Obernerd. Das glaubt man gar nicht. Der steht wirklich, der steht da, macht die ganze Zeit über Witze und kichert über seine eigenen Witze. Und das ist total komplett still. Also zumindest hätte er mal ein Mikro reinpacken sollen. Und dann so ein paar Lacher drauf synchronisieren. Und er hat wirklich die ganze Zeit über seine Witze gelacht. Das war echt nur so mittellustig. Und dann hat er seine neuen Errungenschaften vorgeführt.
Was waren denn jetzt die Errungenschaften? Mich interessiert Zuckerberg jetzt nicht so sehr. Ich fand den Typen schon immer ein bisschen peinlich.
Na die haben halt, was sie gemacht haben, ist Timeline. Also die haben das eigene Profil sozusagen. Das sieht jetzt komplett anders aus. Wenn man es sich dann freischaltet.
Kann man das jetzt schon freischalten?
Das kann man schon. Man muss tun, als ob man Entwickler wäre. Und also man meldet sich da als Entwickler an und sagt, also gibt es irgendwie bei Lifehacker oder so, gibt es eine Schritt für Schritt Anwendung, Anleitung, was man machen muss, um sich das freizuschalten. Das können dann im Augenblick nur andere Leute sehen, die dieses Profil auch freigeschaltet haben. Sieht ganz hübsch aus. Also hat ein riesengroßes Foto oben, so ein breites drin. Also ist schon sehr viel. Also Facebook hat ja immer irgendwas von so einer Art Betriebssystem oder sowas, wo irgendwie so kleine Bildchen da waren und jetzt so wirklich große Bilder und flächig und unendlich lang. Und so, also die wollen offensichtlich auch in eine wesentlich emotionale Richtung von dem ganzen Aussehen her. Und dann hast du da diese ewig lange Timeline, auf der du sozusagen dein ganzes Leben, da sollst du alle Punkte deines Lebens eintragen nach Möglichkeit. Und alles was so bis zur Geburt rückgängig und sowas.
Find ich voll gut. Das Konzept find ich voll gut, was mir nicht gefällt, ist, dass die Daten bei Facebook liegen und nicht bei mir. Also für mich hätt ich das gerne.
Ja, das ist so mittelspannend. Was mir auch bei Facebook aufgefallen ist, dass die ja anfangen, mittlerweile für eines Profils zu vervollständigen. Also und zwar gibt es zum Beispiel, hab ich irgendwie eine Nachricht bekommen, sowieso has indicated, that you live in Berlin, Germany. Dann kannst du sagen ja oder nein. Und ich wette, auch wenn du nein sagst, speichern die ab. Es gibt Leute, die glauben, dass er in Berlin wohnen würde.
Die wissen das. Also ich mein, das ist ja durch ganz viel Daten irgendwie klar.
Naja, die fragen aber auch noch mehr ab. Die fragen zum Beispiel, sowieso, also ich hatte auch so, sowieso, has indicated that you've worked with him. Und, dass wir zusammenarbeiten, dann stimmt es, dass du bei dieser Firma arbeitest. Und das sind Informationen, die ich auf Facebook eigentlich, also ich, ist jetzt nicht schlimm, wenn die da steht, aber, also das ist jetzt, mittlerweile brauche ich nicht mal mehr, mein eigenes Profil zu vervollständigen. Das vervollständigt sich von alleine.
Das ist wie mit so einem riesengroßen Puzzle, wenn das ganze Puzzle schon da liegt und nur noch dein Teil nicht drin steckt, dann ist eigentlich total klar, wo es hingehört.
Also ich glaube, die haben von jemanden, der nur, der selber gar kein Facebook-Account hat, aber sehr viele Freunde, die Facebook-Accounts haben, haben sie ähnlich viele Informationen. Jemand wie, also, ob man da noch ein eigenes Foto hoch, wahrscheinlich ist man auch auf genügend Fotos drauf und getaggt. Ja, das haben sie gemacht und sie haben halt dieses, also es sieht ganz hübsch aus, dieses Timeline. Bei mir stehen da halt nicht so wirklich wahnsinnig viele Informationen drinnen. So ist zum Beispiel sehr prominent der Geburtstag, also sozusagen ein Geburtsfoto von einem Cousin von mir drinnen, mit dem ich so extrem wenig zu tun habe, weil irgendwie so sind da auch so die Familienereignisse und weil der halt der Einzige ist, der da sein Geburtstatum offensichtlich so mit irgendwelchen Informationen hinterlegt hat, erscheint da jetzt in meiner Timeline ganz prominent der Geburtstag einer Person, die ich kaum kenne. Also mit diesem automatisch, wir finden für dich raus, was für dich interessant ist, das funktioniert bei Facebook für mich überhaupt nicht. Also ich gebe ja Facebook immer mal wieder eine Chance und das ist, also ich hatte unter Top News ungelogen ein Foto von einer Mülltonne geschossen von einer Person, die ich nicht kannte. Und das ist, also diese Algorithmen, da muss Facebook noch fett dran arbeiten. Und dann haben sie halt noch dieses, wie heißt das? Man muss nicht mehr Like klicken, sie schaffen das Like ab, sondern sie sammeln einfach so im Vorbeigehen Informationen über einen.
Was, man muss nicht mehr Like klicken?
Naja, es ist jetzt bei, zum Beispiel wenn du Spotify nutzt, das hat bei Spotify-Nutzern ziemlich einen Aufstand gegeben, dann wird jeder Song, den du bei Spotify abspielst, also so wie bei Last FM, die das Scrubbeln, jeder Song wird automatisch in deine Facebook Timeline rein. Und steht da drin.
Das kann man nicht abschalten.
Ich glaube, man kann es entweder pauschal abschalten oder pauschal anschalten. Auf jeden Fall ist es so, um Spotify überhaupt nutzen zu können, braucht man in Zukunft einen Facebook-Account. Oder braucht man ab sofort einen Facebook-Account.
Benutzst du das?
Spotify?
Nein.
Das gibt es auch nur in USA.
Nee, das gibt es auch. Das kannst du auch in Deutschland.
In Schweden?
Nee, das gibt es auch in Deutschland. Ich glaube, du kannst ja in Deutschland sogar eine...
Seit wann?
Ja, das ist ja bei denen immer so ein bisschen... Mal geht es, mal geht es nicht. Aber mal gucken. International. Get Spotify. Ich weiß gar nicht, was das jetzt kostet. Also ich hab hier irgendwie so eine kostenlose Version, damit kann ich auf jeden Fall schon mal eine ganze Menge machen. Und... Why Spotify is not available in your country?
Ja, das ist so meine Kenntnisstand.
Dann muss ich da einen von diesen berühmten älteren Accounts haben, bei denen dann doch irgendwas geht. Also was hier geht, ist Finnland, Frankreich, Norwegen, Niederlande, Spanien, Schweden. Großbritannien und United States. Ja, und von Spotify halt gehen die Sachen alle direkt zu Facebook rein. Und du brauchst einen Facebook-Account, um Spotify nutzen zu können. Und, ähm, also gerade ehrlich gesagt so beim Musikgeschmack hört es bei mir auf, weil ich schäme mich sehr für meinen Musikgeschmack und ich möchte nicht, dass alle meine Freunde dieses über Jahre lang halbwegs gepflegte Image, das wieder zerstört wird, dadurch, dass ich immer noch den Scheißworten vor 20 Jahren höre.
Du bist eigentlich gar nicht so cool.
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Ich höre auch alte Musik.
Machen wir hier mal einen Outtake, nachdem wir das letzte Mal als Adobe Nutzer geäußert ausgesagt haben.
Ihr werdet alt.
Zum Beispiel dieser Regisseur, der den 23 Film gemacht hat. Hattest du mit dem zu tun? Ich hab mich mit dem vorgehalten. Wo sie jetzt wurde, ist total oft Topic. Aber macht immer Spaß.
Christian Schmidt meinst du.
Genau. Und da der erste Song bei 23 ist, welcher?
Der erste, der im Film läuft?
Deep Purple, Child und Time. Was ja genau passend ist für die Personen, weil der Untertitel von dem Song ist The Story of a Loser, It Could Be You. Passt ja zum Film. Und dann hab ich mir letztens angeguckt, diesen Extrazisten-Verschnitt-Film. Ich weiß jetzt leider nicht, wie der auf Deutsch hieß. So eine wahre Geschichte, die irgendwie von ihm nachgedreht wurde. Und was benutzt er da wieder für einen Film? Deep Purple. Und was hör ich gerne ab und zu? Deep Purple. Das ist einfach uralter Scheiß, der auch das älteste davon ist, aus den späten 60ern. Find ich immer wieder gut. Und ich bin zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass er die Purple-Fan ist, der Regisseur. Sonst würde er nicht so einen alten Kram in seinen Filmen verwenden. Ist ja doch sehr untypisch.
Ich weiß, dass Sie explizit unbedingt dieses Lied haben wollten, weil Sie der Meinung waren, dass es so gut passen würde.
Das kommt noch dazu.
Und Sie haben, glaube ich, lange, lange Zeit nicht die Erlaubnis bekommen, das zu tun und waren schon total am Boden zerstört. Und dann, weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau, gab es dann... Ja, das ist zu lange her. Aber ich glaube, die haben sich dann irgendwie persönlich nochmal... Ich glaube, die haben irgendjemand über irgendeine Ecke, glaube ich, hat jemand von Deep Purple, ich glaube, so was war das, dass irgendjemand von Deep Purple selber davon Wind bekommen hat, weil das natürlich vorher nur über die Lizenzierungsfirma lief.
Er hat einfach auch mal da angerufen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht mehr. Ich glaube, so was war's. Und dann hat sich, glaube ich, einer von Deep Purple dafür eingesetzt, dass dieser Song dort zum Einsatz kommen darf in diesem Film.
Ja, das ist einer meiner Lieblingssongs. Schon immer gewesen.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ein Klassiker. Klassiker kann man immer hören, ne? Das ist ja nicht das Ding, aber es gibt natürlich so Musik, wenn du halt, aber das glaube ich auch vollkommen normal. Ich meine, du bist halt, wann hörst du am meisten Musik? Du hörst am meisten Musik, wenn du halt Teenager bist, in deinen Zwanzigern bist, wenn du viel Zeit hast. Und dann, wenn du gut bist, dann atmest du auch noch in deinen Dreißigerjahren noch frischen Wind ein. Aber irgendwann fehlt dir einfach die Zeit und die Bereitschaft und vor allem auch dieser extrem mega prägende Kontext. Ich meine, irgendwann hast du dann... Irgendwann hast du deine großen Lieben alle gehabt. Während der dann das tolle Lied spielte, hast du die wilden Partys dann alle gehabt. Du hast irgendwie alle Drogen genommen. Also irgendwann passiert dann halt auch nichts mehr, so bahnbrechendes, was eben dazu führt, dass eigentlich vollkommen bekloppte Songs dir total in der Birne hängen bleiben. Und die hast du dann natürlich auf deiner Sammlung und die kannst du irgendwie hören. Wenn das halt Leute hören, die 20 Jahre später geboren sind und den Kontext nicht kennen, die denken sich dann halt nur, ey, Opa, äh...
Ja, aber als ich den Deep Purple Song gehört hab, da war auch schon 15 Jahre später.
Ja gut, Deep Purple ist ja nun auch wirklich etwas, das bleibt dann auch, das ist wie Beatles. Ich mein, du kannst auch heute immer noch, wenn du... Ja, ich meine, wenn du Musik entdeckst in deinem Leben, dann entdeckst du halt auch die Beatles nochmal. Weil die Beatles sind einfach zeitlos. Ja, und vielleicht sogar mehrmals. So, für die Beatles muss man sich nicht schämen, so wie es aber... Es gibt halt so Sachen, das hast du halt in den 80er Jahren irgendwie geil gefunden, was weiß ich, dann hörst du halt Ediment The Ends, oder was weiß ich, ja. Naja, und damit kannst du halt heute echt keinen mehr hinterm Ofen vorlocken, das ist ja auch klar, weil das ist Musik des Zeitgeistes und es gibt eben Musik, die ist einfach Musik der Zeit.
Oder auch gute und schlechte Musik vielleicht.
Sag mal, das hier, genau, oder aber.
Gut, jetzt schäme ich mich wegen meines Musikgeschmacks noch nicht mehr und werde alle meine Musik ab sofort da rein pumpen.
Also du darfst ABBA hören, du darfst Beatles hören.
ABBA höre ich wirklich nicht, also das ist...
Nein, du hörst nicht ABBA.
Also jedenfalls nicht über Kopfhörer.
Aber ist schwierig, ich finde ja auch, dass ABBA total mega zeitlos ist, aber viele würden glaube ich aber eher in so eine Zeitphase rein machen.
Das geht.
Ich bin ja eher so, weil ich nie so den neuesten heißen Scheißhörer...
Der Film, den ich meinte, den ich letztens gesehen habe, der hieß Requiem. Dieser Exorzistenaustreibung, wo die Frau dann auch stirbt.
Ich hab das Gefühl, wir sind von Facebook und so weiter ein bisschen abgekommen.
Aber Facebook ist auch nicht so spannend, weil ich hab ja kein Facebook.
Nee, ich find das auch nicht so spannend. Ich weiß auch nicht. Ich weiß, das ist unheimlich viele Leute. Für die ist das unglaublich wichtig und benutzt das den ganzen Tag.
Facebook Podcast machen.
Ich kann mich wirklich, also ich hab solche Schwierigkeiten mit diesem System, irgendwas anfangen zu können. Das nervt mich. Mich nervt dieses Facebook einfach nur.
Aber ich muss sagen, den Film fand ich gut.
Hab ich auch noch nicht.
Das ist so schön. Der ist wirklich gut gemacht.
Den kann man sich echt mal geben.
Der ist ja auch von dem Regisseur, der der Sieben gedreht hat. Da dachte ich mir auch schon, wie passt das zusammen, so dieser David Fincher. Weil Sieben ist ja mal ein echt anderes Kaliber. Aber, nee, der Facebook ist irgendwie gut gemacht. Das macht Spaß, da zu zu gucken. Und dank diesem Film, dank des Filmes, wie auch immer, hab ich diese Geschichte mit diesen Zwillingsbrüdern verstanden, die er ja angeblich beschissen hat, wie auch immer, wo es immer noch diesen Rechtsstreit gibt, oder sie stellen ihn ein oder geben es jetzt auf, weiß ich nicht genau. Aber jedenfalls war ich dadurch im Bilde, was da so abgeht.
So ging es mir auch, mit dem Focke... Die Zwillinge halt da. Vor kurzem haben die jetzt noch mal richtig schön auf die Fresse gekriegt und sind nochmal so...
Ich würde ja... Also ich behebe mich da voll raus und vielleicht hat er sie beschissen, vielleicht nicht, wie das halt auch immer so ist im Leben, so kleine Ideen, aus denen was Großes wird, und dann hat man es ja eigentlich doch woanders her.
Was ist dir jetzt klar geworden? Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Na es gab... Der Mark Zuckerberg hat doch irgendwie... Er sollte eigentlich für zwei so eine Zwillinge, die auf der gleichen Uni waren, die meinten, er soll für sie so eine Social-Dings-Seite coden. Und das hat auch so ein bisschen angefangen, aber währenddessen meint er, oder es war so, kam ihm halt die Facebook-Idee, und der hat dann eigentlich an Facebook programmiert, und diese Zwillinge klagen jetzt, dass sie eigentlich ja die Idee hätten, und der eigentlich sozusagen deren Idee geklaut hat. Das Facebook eigentlich, das war, was er hätte programmieren sollen für diese Zwillinge, dass eigentlich denen das gehört, oder er die Idee von dort geklaut hat. Und darum hauptsächlich geht dieser Film. Und das an Arsches. Ja, schon.
Und hier um diesen Typen von Napster, wie hieß der gleich?
Ja, genau, der, also Napster waren ja zwei Typen, ne? Einer dieser Sean Fanning, und dann noch so ein anderer. Und dieser andere hat ja beim Start von Facebook irgendwie mitgeholfen und irgendwie die Connections geknüpft.
Und ist daran schweinreich geworden.
Ja, dem gehören 10 oder 15 Prozent von Facebook, oder irgendwie so.
Der andere von alten, nicht der Sean Fanning, sondern...
Naja, da gibt's irgendwie zwei und der, der zweite halt. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie der hieß. Wurde im Film gespielt von Justin Timberdingens da, den...
Jetzt hast du demonstriert, dass du alt bist. Aber ich glaub, Justin Timberlake ist jetzt auch schon wieder raus.
Ich hab neulich erst mal mitgekriegt, wer Ashton Katcha ist.
Na, ist doch der Sohn von Bruce Willis.
Ich glaub nicht ganz so.
War auch so ein Typ, ich weiß nicht, ob es bei Moska war, aber der denn so angekündigt hat. Hier kommt der Daddy von Ashton Katcha oder andersrum. Eigentlich ist er der Freund von Demi Nour oder der Mann sogar. Whatever, wir sind jetzt hier voll an der Kinosendung gelandet. Ja, aber das ist ja eigentlich ein anderer Podcast.
Aber den Teil kannte ich ja sogar. Aber ich bildete mir niemals einen Film mit Ashton Katcha gesehen.
Du, Where's My Car, das war der Typ.
Den hab ich nie gesehen. Aber es gab mal so eine 70er-Jahres-Show, die früher mal auf RTL kam, wo so irgendwie aus dem Ende der 90er Jahre und spielte so ein 70er-Jahres-Setting. Das war Ashton Katcha, das heißt, kapiert. Genau, die Twinkle Force Brothers.
Twinkle Force oder wie so genau.
Die haben eine Facebook-Seite? So, auf die kann...
Das ist die, die sie damals bezahlt haben.
Hier in dem Social-Network der Napster-Typ hieß Sean Parker. Das war irgendwie der Mitgründer von Napster. Der andere hieß... Jetzt hab ich's voll durcheinander gemacht. Der eine heißt Sean und der andere heißt Sin. Wo man es auch Sean ausspricht, das ist ja schwierig.
Ah, Facebook hat mir gerade vorgeschlagen, dass ich Tom Tester kennen könnte. So richtig gut ist der ein Algorithmus wirklich nicht. Tom Tester ist offensichtlich ein Test-Account, den er sich irgendjemand angelegt hat.
Das ist Butterfly Effect, das kann ja nicht sein.
Den Tom Tester? Nee, ich hab ja noch Max-F-Punkt-Winde. Das ist ja mein Test-Account. Der kriegt ständig auch irgendwelche Freundschaftsvorschläge.
Das ist auch geil hier. Person, ich nenne keine Namen. Person gefällt seinen eigenen Status.
Du brauchst den Namen nicht nennen. Du bist es.
Nee. Ich benutze Facebook nicht.
Na klar ist Tim in Facebook.
Ich bin da. Ich bin da, um... Wenn irgendein System kommt, was so einigermaßen Traktionen hat. Naja, es gibt aber zwei Gründe, warum ich dabei sein könnte. Das eine ist, weil ich unbedingt dabei sein will. Das war zum Beispiel Twitter. Ja gut, da ist ja eh der Google-Cont da ist mit mir. Hey, war nochmal separat, wie auch immer. Da will ich das ausprobieren und da will ich das irgendwie auch selber testen und so weiter. Und dann gibt es so andere Systeme. Es gibt drei Gründe. Der zweite Grund ist, ich will zumindest einen Eindruck davon haben, was es ist, auch wenn ich selber für mich nicht unbedingt jetzt Nutzen sehe. Aber ich will einfach sehen, man muss ja auch wissen, worüber man redet. Sonst bist du irgendwie wie der Chaos Computer Club, der so über Sachen redet, die er nicht benutzt.
Wir reden über Facebook?
Watt wer?
Der Club.
Ach, die ganze Zeit, also zumindest.
Niemals. Das ist ja genau eher das Schlimme, dass die oft irgendwie, oh Gott, Facebook? Nee, lass mal nicht drüber reden. Das benutzen wir ja nicht.
Ja, da gibt es genug Talkshows und TV-Sendungen, die man reinsappen kann, wo irgendwie man sitzt und FAZ-Artikel. So, nun, das sind schon. Also man muss schon ein bisschen auch, das heißt jetzt aber auch nicht, dass ich mich jetzt hier, dass ich mir die Nächte um die Ohren schlage, um dieses System auf Biegen und Brechen auszuprobieren, wenn ich für mich da keinen Nutzen sehe. Und dann gibt es so Systeme, da möchte ich einfach nur, dass ich Herr meines eigenen Accounts bin. Also da lege ich mir den Account an, damit ich das dann auch bin. So, aber das war es dann auch schon.
Ja, damit es sehr einfach die ID drappen.
Ich sage jetzt nicht, welche das sind, aber es gibt Systeme, die schweige ich einfach tot.
Kannst du jetzt nicht erwähnen, ne?
Nein, bitte nicht.
Kannst du dann nachher sagen, wer war hier?
Kann ich gerne nachher sagen.
Wahrscheinlich wissen, kennen wir den nicht mehr, wenn wir nicht so tot geschenkt werden von Tim.
Ich könnte noch ein bisschen was für, also vielleicht noch zwei, drei kleine Updates zum Abschluss zum Thema McIntosh-Applikationen oder iOS-Applikationen sagen.
Ich auch, aber ich will anfangen, weil du machst da eh den Redeführer, du hast ja dein Zettel, du vergisst ja nichts, ich schon. Deswegen. Die Leute fragen mich noch, weil ich so viel über Xcode abgerentet habe, woran das denn liegt.
Dass du erahntest.
Ja, also die haben mir auch geschrieben per Twitter, so dass bei denen würde ja alles irgendwie prima laufen. Ich hab jetzt mal so ein bisschen beobachtet, was es irgendwie ist. Und wenn ich so ein ganz normales Projekt irgendwie mache, so mit irgendwie einen Button, eine Action, einen IB-Outlet, wisst schon, dann crasht auch nichts. Aber ich mach halt viel mit dem Quartz-Composer und mit Quartz-Composer-Views und Patch-Controllern und Parameter-Views und all dem Zeug. Und das ist ganz eindeutig und bewiesend für mich, dass wenn ich diese Dinger speichern will, also Interface-Bilder gibt's ja nicht mehr. Das heißt, das X-Code muss ja auch denn hier das speichern, meine Quartz-Composer-Views. Und der hat halt Schwierigkeiten beim Serialisieren und Crash-Dun, und zwar immer und immer wieder. Ich konnte das jetzt schon umgehen, dann wird's besser, aber mit Quartz-Composer grundsätzlich alles, was ich mit Quartz-Composer mache, mir fliegt das Ding. Also nicht mit Quartz-Composer-Code. Keine Ahnung, pro Stunde sage ich mal 20 Mal ab. Also man kann schon so sagen, alle zwei, drei Minuten bombt mir das um die Ohren. Es ist aber schon wirklich auch stark an diesem Quartz-Composer. Und dann probiere ich jetzt noch was anderes für unser Display im Club. Und dann nutze ich gerade keinen Quartz-Composer, aber einen QT-Movie-View oder QT-Kit. Irgendwas mit Kit? Wie auch immer.
Movie-Kit.
Irgendwie sowas. Und da fliegt mir das auch immer um die Ohren. Also immer, wenn man was Spezielles macht, was mit mehr Grafik zu tun hat, scheint mir so. Also wenn so Views irgendwie drin sind, die dann irgendwie schon Grafik haben und nicht nur Bildchen, sondern bewegt, dann ballert mir das Xcode um die Ohren. Und das ist schon ziemlich häufig. Also es kommt mir fast so vor, als wenn das System schon Memory Protection hat, aber das Xcode irgendwie nicht. Also wenn ich da irgendwelche Programme über Xcode starte, dann scheinen die Programme mir das Xcode gleich mit weg zu ballern. Das wollte ich mal gesagt haben, weil die Leute alle denken, ich hab irgendwie eine Macke oder nutze irgendwie Schrott. Aber nicht so.
Das ist ja voll irre.
Sondern um mit dem Thema Standardanbau zu sagen, ihr nutzt einfach das Xcode nicht genug.
Ich nutze es halt richtig. So, jetzt ist es raus.
Jetzt ist es raus. Max? Abs?
Was soll ich jetzt für Abs haben?
Du darfst auch die oder das ab sagen. Oh, danke. Was für das Abs? Hast du denn so?
Ich muss ja sagen, ich habe...
Ich darf auch im Mac sein. Ich finde ja Mac auch manchmal echt immer noch interessanter, aber...
Was ich ja in letzter Zeit durchaus ein bisschen zu schätzen gelernt habe, ist Instagram.
Ich habe nie so richtig verstanden, warum das eigentlich alle so benutzen wollen.
Naja, im Wesentlichen, um ihre Füße und Sonnenuntergänge zu fotografieren.
Aber, ich meine... Was tut denn das anderes als Fotos machen?
Nein, nichts.
Sie aussehen lassen, als wären sie vor 30 Jahren geschossen worden.
Na, es ist halt so ein bisschen so eine Art Twitter für Bilder. Und du machst... es hat durchaus was Vergleichbares.
Twitter? So mit Followern und so.
Na, es ist zum einen mit den Followern, dieses Follower-Prinzip. Zum anderen ist es, du hast da dieses Fotografieren, was dadurch gewinnt, dass du eigentlich sehr eingeschränkt bist. Also du kannst nur quadratische Bilder machen und du hast halt nicht so wahnsinnig viele Möglichkeiten. Du hast da eine Handvoll Filter.
Kann man quadratische Bilder machen?
Jaja, du hast nur ein Bildformat und...
Warum?
Na, so wie du auf Twitter nur 140 Zeichen hast. Also ich hab mir das mal erklären lassen. Das kommt wohl aus einem bestimmten Fotografiebereich, wo auch lange Zeit Vollformat-Fotos oder Voll... Ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Mittelformat-Kameras?
Ja, Mittelformat, genau. Siehst du, das kennst dich doch besser aus als ich. Und du hast halt relativ starke Einschränkungen. Und so wie man es durchaus schafft, mit Twitter eine kleine Geschichte in 140 Zeichen zu erzählen, oder Leuten eine Freude zu machen oder sie zu informieren oder Ähnliches, so kann man mit Instagram das auch hinkriegen. Und dann kriegt man da so ein paar, quasi, die Favorites heißen da so auch Likes. Und man kommuniziert darüber. Und es hat was sehr Angenehmes, weil man kann sich so, also auf dem Desktop benutze ich im Augenblick Carousel, auf dem Mac, das ist so die Instagram-App der Walda. Wobei eigentlich, genau, um Fotos anzugucken, wobei die ist eigentlich, die ist nicht schön. Also ich bin verzweifelt auf der Suche nach einer schöneren Instagram-App, weil die macht zwar, ist nicht total scheiße, aber ja, es ist nicht wirklich gut. Und das Schöne ist halt, du kannst dich so mal schnell durchscrollen und so wie man auf Twitter so einen kurzen Einblick in das Leben von anderen Personen hat, hat man das auf Instagram im Zweifelsfall auch. Wenn man jetzt nicht gerade die ganze Zeit nur Füßen fotografieren darf oder so.
Also man kann sich sozusagen ein bisschen besser Katzenfotos angucken. Ja genau, eigentlich das bessere Katzenfototausch-Medium. Aber du kannst halt so, du scrollst halt so durch im Laufe des Tages und kriegst halt mit bei bestimmten Leuten. Die Frequenz ist halt deutlich niedriger als auf Twitter, weil so ein Foto machst du ja auch nicht so oft. Und du hast es auch im Zweifelsfall wesentlich schneller verarbeitet. Wenn es ein langweiliges Foto ist, dann scrollst du eben drüber weg.
Das hat ich noch überhaupt nicht verstanden. Das ist ja interessant.
Ja und dann packt man da halt diese Filter drauf. Jetzt gab es Instagram 2 und alle meckern über die neuen Filter. Weil die nicht mehr so schick sind wie die alten wohl. Und ja, weiß ja teufel was. Aber kann man echt mal...
Kann man das denn auch benutzen, ohne dass man in diesem Social Network da drin ist? Oder muss man dann alles posten?
Du musst alles posten? Ich weiß nicht, ob man das auch privat posten kann. Aber ich glaube, du musst das. Das ist der Sinn der Sache. Machst ein Foto und dann...
Ich kann keine privaten Fotos machen.
Ich glaube, man kann keine privaten Fotos machen.
Ich hätte auch noch eine Frage zu einem App. Ich suche nämlich ein bestimmtes und ich glaube, ihr wisst bestimmt da was in der Richtung, weil da gab es glaube ich noch was. Und zwar hätte ich gerne ein Programm, womit ich meine Bilder besser betrachten kann. Also mehr so technisch. Und zwar genau zu welchem Datum, die gemacht wurden mit Uhrzeit und alles. Und wo man pro Bild die ganzen Meta-Informationen rausziehen kann. So heißt es?
XIF heißen die Metadaten.
Ja, aber das Programm, was es anzeigt. Auf dem iPhone.
Ach so, auf dem iPhone.
Weil sonst, ich kann ja nichts weitermachen, außer die chronologisch sortieren oder halt in der Map angucken, wo die geschossen wurden. Aber dann fehlt mir wieder das Datum. Und ich hätte gerne eins, wo man das genau sieht. Und vielleicht doch mal dementsprechend sortieren kann. Oder, weißt schon, irgendwie so.
Ja, da gab es tatsächlich eins. Ich kann jetzt mal nur...
Exit-View, da schreiben sie schon welche. Ich guck mal, danke schön.
Also da gibt es sicherlich mehrere. Auf dem iPhone sagste, ne? Ja, gibt's ja tonnenweise. Ich überleg nur gerade, es gab irgendeins, was mir mal so empfohlen wurde. Aber das seh ich jetzt hier gerade nicht.
Was will mir denn ein eBay-Update sagen, wenn es als Verbesserung, Bugfixes und Umarmungen hat?
Umarmungen? Ich würde sagen, es ist eine schlechte Übersetzung, oder?
Gibt's sowas bei eBay?
Na, man kann ja ein neues OS Embracing sozusagen, neue Features einkleiden, aber bei eBay? Alles wird creepy, ja? Ich meine, diese ganze Technologie entwickelt sich irgendwie creepy, ja? Alles ist irgendwelchen Wolken und alles muss die ganze Zeit folgen.
Und Freunde und Umarmungen und so weiter. Du meinst, Apple ist evil, heißt das jetzt Apple ist creepy?
Ja, diese ganze Daten, digitale, virtuelle, diese ganze Cyberspace fühlt sich an wie eine Sauna.
Naja, aber jetzt eine Social-Fotonetwork vorzuwahrwerfen, dass es Social ist, ist ja...
Naja, du musst dir die ganze Zeit die Katzen- und Hundefotos von den anderen Leuten anschauen.
Nee, musst du nicht, kannst du auch beenden das Programm.
Musst du es natürlich nicht, aber du machst es dann doch den ganzen Abend.
Nein, das geht viel schneller.
Das ist alles creepy. Ja, das wollen auch die Telefone, dass man mit ihnen redet.
Ja, so ist das.
Ich meine, aber ich muss immer mit diesem, ich muss immer das Telefon ansprechen. Kann nicht das Telefon mal auf mich zukommen und sagen sowas wie, ach Tim, wie geht's dir eigentlich?
Ich schreib dir so eine App. Aber ob du das wirklich möchtest, so nachts um drei, so Tim?
Sorgen.
Kann man sich deine Stimme einstellen bei dem Siri?
Kannst du auch nicht schlafen.
Sorgen-Telefon.
Das ist aus Ernie und Bert. Oder?
Ist doch von der Sesamstraße.
Es ist doch immer so, schon hier Eliza und so weiter, immer musst du in diesen Computer reinfragen.
Ja, aber wenn mich mein Telefon anfängt irgendwie vollzunöhlen, wobei das wird auch kommen.
Dann wird es halt keinen Erfolg haben. Es muss halt auch Success Bites sein. Wenn man nicht drauf antwortet, dann hat es halt verloren. Das muss schon interessante Sachen fragen.
Naja, aber so diesen Reminder, diesen Location-Base. Wobei das vermeiden sie glaube ich im Augenblick. Ich glaube sie vermeiden das ganz bewusst, dass dieses Telefon dich einfach so anspricht.
Weil es nämlich noch creepier ist.
Ja, ich glaube nämlich so creepy ist es gar nicht. Weil im Allgemeinen, du, du, du, also ich glaube auch nicht, dass das bei der Generation schon jetzt der Fall sein, also wenn ich diese Sprachsteuerung habe, dann ist das ja nicht so, dass ich das Gefühl habe, mich da mit einem menschlichen Wesen zu kommunizieren, sondern ich probiere einer Maschine irgendwas zu vermitteln, was sie jetzt auf Teufelkammerhaus nicht hinbekommt. Also Touch-Bedienung, also oh guck mal, ich fasse ein technisches Gerät an, um ihm etwas zu vermitteln, ist ja eigentlich dann eigentlich auch creepy. Bisher hat man nur Menschen angefasst.
Der Chat bringt gerade sehr berechtigt ein, dass es ja dann auch noch entsprechende Stimmpakete geben müsste. Ich meine diese Sprache, mit der du gerade geredet hast, ich frage mich, welche Stimme sie da eigentlich verwenden. Alex war das nicht, ne?
Die haben mit iOS 5, das war früher eine Männerstimme bei iOS 4 und jetzt ist es eine Fraustimme. Das hat mich total verwirrt am Anfang.
Wo war es?
Na, dieses Voice Control.
Und jetzt ist es eine Frau.
Jetzt ist es eine Frau.
Du kannst das nicht umstellen?
Ich glaube, das kann man nicht umstellen. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt einfach die Default-Stimme, das ist jetzt eine Frau. Mein iPhone ist jetzt eine Frau.
Heugi hat mich mal auf diese Werbespots gebracht, die kennt ihr vielleicht von TomTom, weil die dann auch irgendwann diese Stimmpakete gehabt haben, wo du dann nicht nur so anonyme Frauen oder Männer machen konntest. Sie haben auch so ein Stimmpaket gehabt, unter anderem von Darth Vader, wo sie da wirklich extrem lustige Werbespots gemacht haben. Darth Vader im Aufnahmestudio, der die ganze Zeit irgendwie daher redet.
You should have seen his face when I told him that I'm his father. Aber das wär ja auch was, wenn das iPhone sich so zurückwerden würde.
Fühlt man das die ganze Zeit im Auto neben sich? Also beim Navigationssystem find ich das ja furchtbar, wenn man fährt auf der Autobahn, seit zwei Stunden irgendwie hat dieses Navi nichts gesagt und plötzlich so, in 500 Meter biegen sie, bitte rechts!
Ja und dann nicht nur die Stimme variieren, sondern dass du sozusagen auch noch bestimmte Charaktere hast, ja. Was weiß ich, dass du so einen Woody Allen hast, der dich die ganze Zeit mit so einem depressiven Zauberzug watscht.
Der dir einfach immerhin direkt, jedes Mal direkt nach der Kreuzung, Bescheid zeigt. Oh, da hätten wir jetzt abbiegen müssen.
Entschuldigung, ich hab das nicht so, aber es ist kein Problem, da kommt bestimmt noch, also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass es da auch gerade ausgeht.
Nein, ich frag nicht nach dem Weg, ich weiß wo es lang geht.
Oder so ein Witzboid, ne?
Wo die so zwei Stunden Autobahn, äh, dann so, AAAAAAA!
Der möchte nicht wissen, wie viel Leute da schon auf der Straße haben. Nein, das will ich von meinem iPhone alles nicht. Ich will nicht, dass mein iPhone mich anspricht.
Ja, aber das kommt. Ja, wir haben jetzt Creepy und Creepy möchte, dass du mit ihm sprichst. Ja, weil irgendwann fängt Creepy dann nämlich an, sich zu beschweren, dass du schon lange nicht mehr mit ihm gesprochen hast. Früher hast du mehr mit mir geredet.
Hast du jetzt etwa ein iPhone 5?
Du meinst ja, Sire kriegt dann irgendwann noch......ein anderes iPhone neben mir? Der kriegt dann Tamagotchi-Features?
Ich hab neulich gesehen, dass du mit der Google-Sprache kennengeredet hast. Das passt mir gar nicht. Du möchtest doch deine Daten behalten, oder?
Du redest doch mit dem, nur weil die Jünger ist als ich.
Natürlich kannst du dir weiter Filme auf deinem Kindle-Feier angucken. Oder wenn es dann anfängt, sich zu beschweren, dass man den Geburtstag vergessen hat.
Oder Klaus Kinski.
Beatrix ab, du dumme Sau!
Ja, Kinski Tourette sag ich nur.
Oder die Apple Store-Variante, wie amal klatschen.
Du sollst nicht nur einfach lenken! Das bringt, also ich meine, das Markt.
Aber vielleicht das iPhone 4 könnte ja auch klatschen, wenn man irgendwas erfolgreich gemacht hat.
4S.
So als Belohnung. So wie beim Apple Store. Immer, wenn man was gekauft hat. Immer, wenn man in einem Store was gekauft hat.
Siri, cheer me up.
Ja, das ist da wirklich sehr lebensbegleiternd.
Oder schnarcht.
Hast du dir das neueste iPod Nano gekauft?
Das heißt, der iPod Nano. Du bist aber heute wieder echte neutig.
Aber jetzt ist es ein Die-iPhone, der jetzt eine Frauensstimme hat.
Ja, ich sehe, also ich weiß nicht so ganz genau. Und alles ist irgendwie in der Wolke. Und eBay will uns alles umarmen. Ich meine, wo soll denn das enden? Ja, Umarmungen. Hast du irgendwie gerade reingekommen? Ah ja, hier ist das Update. Ich klick mal und gucke mal, was hier bei iTunes steht. Es stimmt.
Umarmungen.
Was? Laube? Eifern?
Jetzt gucken wir mal, was Umarmung noch so bedeutet. Das haben die doch bestimmt irgendwo in Indien übersetzen lassen.
Leute, sag doch mal, was Umarmungen bei eBay sind. Mir fällt da jetzt auch echt nichts zu ein.
Embracings?
Chat, rede mit mir.
Ach, der soll jetzt doch wieder mit dir.
Ja, oder vielleicht sollten wir mit dem Chat reden. Eigentlich ist das ja ein bisschen... Der Chat ist ja eigentlich unser Siri, ne? Wir reden da immer rein. Und der Chat muss darüber nachdenken, was wir wohl so meinen, und liefert dann so kontextorientierte Lösungen. Also eigentlich haben wir ja hier so ein Crowd.
Der mit vielen Stimmen zu uns spricht.
Creepy, dein Chat.
Mein iPhone hat mir gesagt, ich soll sie alle töten. Aber so lange ist es auch gar nicht her, das ist dieser Werbespot.
Ist das aus 2001?
Nee, das ist 2001.
Achso, das ist der Werbespot. Zehn Jahre her, 2001.
Nee, 2000 war es. Es war vom Millennium. Das ging darum, dass die alle abstürzen.
War das nicht genau 2001, dein Pass zum Film?
Nee, das war 1999. Kurz vor der...
Gute Frage, das weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr.
Es ging darum, dass die alle abstürzen werden, die ganzen PCs bei mir, 2000, dass nur Macintosh dauerhaft vorbereitet wird.
Stimmt, das ist die Geschichte damals.
You like your Macintosh better, jetzt sagt das iPhone demnächst, you like your Macbook Air better, Don't you Dave? Aber ob einem das die ganze Zeit auch mit einem Namen anspricht?
Hier ist es.
Da war sowieso eine ganz schöne Werbereihe. War ganz andere Style als jetzt.
Wobei ich ja gerade bei dem finde, das war noch so...
Da muss aber wenigstens, weil die Optik ist nicht so spannend, musst du den Sound mit in den Pod irgendwie move.
In den Pod? Ja, das tue ich. Wir hatten hier bloß die ganze Zeit nichts abzuspielen. Ich frag mich nur gerade, welche von diesen Ads die richtig ist.
Ist alles die gleiche, oder?
Na hier, die ist eine Minute und die ist zwei Minuten. Ich meine... Ja, warum sind die anderen alle nur eine Minute?
Mann, dann nimm eine!
Okay, wir probieren das mal aus. Ich hab's doch gesagt. Du hast gesagt, welche Apple-Ad ist denn schon so lang.
Aber überhaupt, das waren noch Zeiten, als Apple noch über Datumsformatprobleme, Werbespots getreten hat.
Es war ein Bogen, Dave.
Dieser Apple noch? Dieser rote, dieser rotscheinende Apple.
Apple ist evil, ich sag's dir.
Aber, jetzt guck mal, wenn man hier so dieses Hall-Auge neben dieses Siri-Mikrofonzeichen, was ja auch so...
Ist fast ähnlich.
Das ist schon, komm, das ist dasselbe.
Was, Max?
Nein, das ist nicht dasselbe, aber es ist so dieses pulsierende... Was? Ja.
Jetzt fantasierst du aber.
Ach, Apple. Das ist schon... Jetzt ist es soweit. Die Zukunft, jetzt ist sie da. Gesundheit.
Na endlich, wurde ja auch Zeit.
Ja, aber jetzt ist es wirklich, jetzt ist es eigentlich... Also, hey, kein iPhone 5, nur Zukunft.
Na gut.
Du bist ja doof, ich wollte ein iPhone 5 haben.
Jetzt haben wir so ein Metathema angehen. Ich wollte noch auf meine scheiß Apps zu sprechen kommen.
Ja, komm doch auf deine Apps zu sprechen.
Echt? Ich meine, wir müssen diese Sendung auch langsam mal zu Ende führen, oder?
Auch mal.
Ich muss bald mal aufs Klo gehen. Die Mate meldet sich. Ich wollte nur mal kurz, da ich früher mal so viel über mangelnde HBCI-Software geklagt habe und sich dann auf einmal so viel tat, wozu ich die Fortschritte begleite, weil das Software ist, die ich häufiger benutze. Und meiner Meinung nach gibt es da zwei wirklich interessante Contender, die derzeit so sich mit Features versuchen, gegenseitig abzuhängen. Outbank und Money Money sind so ein bisschen so die beiden Sachen. Das Money Money ist immer noch das schickere, aber Outbank ist auch nicht unschick und hat den großen Vorteil, dass es auch mit PayPal-Konten funktioniert. Bis vor kurzem hatte es auch noch den anderen Vorteil, dass man damit auch Überweisungen machen konnte, obwohl ich keine hinbekommen habe. Mit I-Outbank? Mit Outbank. I-Outbank wiederum kann komischerweise keinen PayPal. Sie haben das nur in der Mac-Version drin und nicht auf dem iPhone. Warum auch immer. Ob das eine Limitierung von PayPal ist, weiß ich nicht ganz genau, aber ich kann mir das eigentlich nicht vorstellen. Immerhin funktioniert das ganz gut. User-Interface von Outbank ist nicht schlecht, aber ist ein bisschen so. Ich habe generell an allem was auszusetzen, so auch hier. Und Mani Mani hat jetzt gerade ein Update bekommen und macht auch Überweisungen. Das ist sogar richtig ordentlich geworden. Das finde ich einfach so. Ich finde, dass die wirklich eine elegante Herangehensweise haben, ihr User-Interface zu gestalten.
Also ich habe mit Outbank schon einige Überweisungen gemacht. Und das kann sogar so Späße wie, ich habe das selber nicht, aber dieses furchtbare Flicker-Erkenn, also dieses, wo man unten seine EC-Karte reinstecken muss und dann generiert es einem eine TAN. Und man muss das vorher ans Display halten. Das kann das. Und Outbank kann da echt eine ganze Menge.
Das kann viel, genau, das ist der große Vorteil. Ich habe jetzt mit solchen Flicker-Kram nicht gearbeitet, ich habe halt jetzt auf SMS-TAN umgestellt, weil es halt einfach das Praktischste ist. Ja, dann gibt's Growl in einer neuen Version. Und es ist jetzt halt auf dem Upstore gelandet. Aber sie haben halt Growl sehr schön überarbeitet. Und ich kann jedem nur raten, da mal zuzuschlagen, das war ja lange Zeit frei, kostenlos. Frei ist vielleicht die falsche Bezeichnung.
Und jetzt nicht mehr?
Und jetzt ist dem nicht mehr so, genau.
Also ich hab, ich hätte kein Problem, ich kauf mir das, die App auch gerne. Aber irgendwie so, dass da die ganze Zeit so ein Eintrag in eine Menüleiste ist, das finde ich dann doch eher so, naja, noch so ein Eichen mehr, was ich da oben in der Menüleiste rumhängen kann, was ich eigentlich gar nicht möchte. Das ist, zumindest könnten sie es optional machen, das Menü.
Es lebt jetzt wohl vor allem da und es läuft auch nur unter Linen, also von daher.
Ach und die ganzen Kommandozahlen.
Ja, aber sie haben jetzt endlich eine Historie, also du hast jetzt noch die Sachen, dass die angezeigt werden, sondern du kannst sie eben jetzt in so einem Buch sammeln, dir das anschauen. Das heißt, du hast halt wirklich jetzt endlich mal so ein Logging-Feature durch Growl, also die Dinge landen dort, werden aber nicht nur kurz angezeigt, sondern kannst sie eben auch später nachschlagen. Und der reagiert halt automatisch auf Eidl. Wenn du also irgendwie Eidl bist, dann fängt er an, die zu sammeln. Und das ist ja eigentlich so das, was man so haben will, dass eben wirklich wichtige Sachen dann eben auch eingesammelt werden.
Und es gibt nicht mehr diese Growl Notify-Kommandozahlen-Binary-Weigerung, ob ich das jetzt App zu nennen, also dieses Kommandozahlen-Tool dafür. Das hab ich auch. Nee, das ist wohl jetzt auch tot. Also es ist eine Menge verloren gegangen für den App Store. Das finde ich echt schade. Also wenn das irgendwann nochmal nachgerüstet wird, sehr, sehr gerne, bin ich sofort dabei. Ansonsten hab ich jetzt, ich hab mein Windows-Telefon mal auf Mango 75 gebracht und hab da bei dem Windows Phone 7 Connector für Mac installiert.
Wieder ein Windows Phone.
Na, ich hab ja noch so ein Windows Phone rumfliegen. Die können jetzt auch fliegen? Naja, die meiste Zeit hat es rumgelegen. Da wollte ich jetzt mal Mango draufbringen und jetzt hab ich es auch nach längerem hin und her geschafft, was eine ziemliche Tortur war, weil zuerst wollte es, jetzt bin ich mal so tapfer erklärt, dass kein Update für das Telefon da sei. Dann ging das und nach ein paar Tagen kam dann irgendwann mal die Nachricht, dass ein Update da war und dann musste das um von 7 irgendwas auf 7.5 zu aktualisieren, mussten drei Updates installiert werden, nacheinander. Und vor jedem dieser Updates hat es ein vollständiges Backup gemacht, bis dann irgendwann mal da dieses Windows 7.5 Mango drauf war. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was sie da alles treiben in der Zeit, aber irgendwie finde ich, kann man das durchaus mal ein bisschen besser machen.
Ist das jetzt schon so das finale Release?
Ja, das ist jetzt ganz offiziell.
War das nicht so, dass sogar die Software inkopatibel ist zwischen 7.0 und 7.5? Da gab es irgendwie einen AP-Bruch, habe ich gehört.
Also ich habe jetzt nichts in der Richtung bemerkt. Das funktioniert alles weiterhin. Kann natürlich sein, dass jetzt sozusagen 7.5-Software nicht mehr unter 7 läuft. Auf Teufel komm raus. Was man aber echt mal sagen muss, diese Windows Phone 7 Connector, den kriegt man Microsoft untypisch. Leert man den sich einfach im App Store runter, klickt auf installieren, er ist da und funktioniert und ohne Neustart und ohne alles. Und sieht sogar noch halbwegs okay aus. Also, da kann sich Apple mal eine Scheibe von abschneiden. So baut man Tools, so in etwa sollten Tools aussehen, mit denen man sein Telefon synchronisiert und nicht wie iTunes.
Tja, iTunes, wie lange wirst du uns noch erhalten bleiben? So, jetzt ist das Pulver verschossen, würde ich sagen. Was meint ihr?
Ich glaube, das war ein Ja.
Der Sohn ist tot und ich fühle mich jetzt auch schon an. Ich denke wir haben es gerissen, wa?
Kann sich mal wieder niemand beschweren, dass die Sendung nicht lang genug war.
Ne, wie lang war sie denn?
Ich meine, wann haben wir angefangen? Wahrscheinlich acht haben wir angefangen, ne?
Dreieinhalb Stunden. Das muss reichen.
Ne, diese Beta ist glaub ich noch nicht draußen.
Ja, da meint einer, Growl Notify wird nachgeliefert. Kommt alles.
Ich kauf's, also wenn es dann soweit ist, kauf ich das total gerne und kaufen, kaufen, kaufen, kaufen, kaufen. Und die Growl ist wirklich ein, lohnt sich ja auch, also ich nutze das jetzt auch schon so lange und so und da kann ich auch mal ein bisschen Geld für ausgeben.
Kaufen macht die Developer unabhängig und glücklich und reich und das ist überhaupt alles gut. Wir brauchen gute Programmierer, die gut viel Zeit darauf investieren, gute Software zu machen, denn gute Software macht glücklich.
Und das unabhängig, ohne irgendwelche Marketing-Abteilungen, was wir hoffentlich möglicherweise anentwickeln können.
Genau, so sehen wir das. Deswegen, gerne Geld aus für gute Software und gute Podcasts. Raten über alles, was nichts taugt. Was mit Podcasts, die kann man nicht kaufen.
Aber dafür kann man die nicht kaufen.
Die kann man nur nachher kaufen. Post...
Flattern war der Vorausschuss. Musste noch mal dran arbeiten.
Ja, ich weiß. Musste noch mal dran arbeiten. Genau, also an der Stelle vielen Dank für alle, die uns hier auch unterstützen. Vielen Dank für alle, die uns immer bis zu Ende zuhören.
Du wolltest in deinem Kalender hier so eine Sicht haben?
Oh, willst du das Kalenderthema nochmal aufbringen?
Was hast du denn da für einen Kalendertacker?
Na, wie ein Reminder. Der hat da so eine Wochenübersicht. Du wolltest noch so einen Wochenabend zum Durchscrollen, ne?
Ja.
Dieses Reminder-App, das finde ich ja auch...
Wo ist das jetzt mit diesem Location-Fans?
Das haben sie wirklich getan. Okay, also sie haben zwar immer noch diese merkwürdigen Monatsbrüche.
Aber wenn man sich den jetzt mal anguckt, dieses Reminder-App, nachdem man gestern die Keynote gesehen hat, vorher dachte man, was ist das denn für eine merkwürdige App? Und jetzt, ah, das sieht genauso aus wie diese Siri.
Ja, aber mir fehlt da so ein bisschen dieses Location-Fans. Also geht es auch nur mit dem 4S, mit den Freunden und dem Fintender? Wo geht denn das? Wo kann ich dann sagen hier, dass du mich jetzt immer dauer finden darfst?
Achso, na, das ist doch was anderes. Das ist doch hier dieses Reminder. Das ist doch Find My Friends. Das kommt erst am 12. Oktober.
Oder am 15.
Aber auch bei der Version hier denn?
Jaja, aber das ist Reminder. Das ist hier nur mit der Location, dass du dich an einem bestimmten Ort an irgendwas erinnern kannst.
Genau. Leute, das habe ich schon so einen schönen Abschluss für diese Sendung gefunden.
Und dann habe ich wieder voll reingequatscht.
Wir machen einen Kalender nochmal.
Durchaus ein paar Bewegungen.
Remind me at location. Wenn auch noch nicht so richtig. Dennis und Max sind hier fleißig dabei und reden was dafür, über die sie nicht reden dürften. Und jetzt ist es ja offiziell vorbei. X ist offiziell.
Naja, stimmt. Xcode ist sogar Golden Master und IOS ist Golden Master.
Und überhaupt Goldenschauer.
Der Drops ist hier lutscht.
Gut, schöner hätte man es jetzt nicht sagen können. Dann sagen wir mal Tschüss und bis bald bei Movamex.
Dennis?
Wir sehen Huckel nächste Woche wieder. Übernächster.
Genau, Huckel holen wir gleich wieder aus dem Schrank.
Na gut, tschüss dann, ciao!